[Music]
it's Sunday here day two for the 2023
Champions chess tour finale beautiful
Toronto Canada the lovely CN Tower she
welcomes all she welcomes everyone to
this amazing city north of the Border if
you're in the states a capital of Chess
in Canada in many ways it's day two and
it's coming at you right
now you've heard the sayings The Road
Less Traveled rubber meets the road I'm
on the road to nowhere that need to get
up and go to just shut up and drive to
Parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road
has an end and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move check me there's been
curves Hills corners and even a
breakdown or two the game is over that's
a we see a reaction Magnus is Magnus
mous oh my gosh look at Jordan's face
some have pulled over but some what is
he doing slam that foot to the floor and
just kept going any second Nakamura is
the winner not a up Maxim vajra the
Frenchman he wins the AI cup after six
stops along the way it's time for the
greatest proven ground and online chess
to drop that final pin in the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove who the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there's ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge with my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to end it
well having the opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
it's always a challenge and I enjoy it
it's going to be a very close fight it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023 champ
Champions chess tour finals and it
starts
now I don't think there is a cooler
voice to help open a chess show than
Wood Harris no cooler pictures I think
we've ever had of the world's top
players than that hype video and no
cooler place to be alongside James candy
it is Danny wrench here we are in the
playing Hall in Toronto we're getting
set for day two but KY before we focus
on today biggest takeaway you had from
day one yeah hi Caro being my guy you
know I just like love hikaro that's my
guy everybody loves hikaro right so he
lost yesterday man on his birthday Danny
on my birthday man dude 0 and2 is not
how you want to spend your birthday I
think some players struggle on their
birthday but we're all hoping hikaro can
turn it around although he does he does
have two very tough matchup so all right
we're here in Toronto but as you know we
have a third member with us every single
day she is Ka and she is ready to take
it
away yeah dannyan I have to tell you my
heart is just warm from day one in the
CCT finals the players were so good to
me to the fans they stopped for
interviews even after losses even before
Arma get on drama they would come for an
interview to share their thoughts with
the fans to share their genius Minds
their feelings and I'm hoping for more
of that today the only player that I
didn't get to talk to I really wanted to
talk to yesterday was Hikaru Nakamura
you mentioned it on his birthday losing
two matches so my biggest hope today is
that we get to talk to iaru Nakamura But
first you guys let's go back to day one
in the CCT
finals the Champions chest tour finals
are off to a blistering start with
brilliancies upsets and of course
Armageddon in the first round of the
round robin Magnus Carlson took down
Dennis lazic Ali Resa fua defeated Notre
Beckham dorov and Fabiano marijuana
scored a win against Maxim bash gra
which required Armageddon in the
Armageddon game Fabiano showed
incredible attacking chess with the
black pieces winning with three
brilliancies and here we go the black
pawns are just marching two pawns up
still and uh if he can remove White's
remaining pors on the king side even at
the cost of his material advantage that
guarantees the draw and Maxim Vash grab
actually resigns wow the most shocking
result of the day came from Wesley so
and birthday boy hakaru Nakamura Wesley
secured un impressive win in the first
game with the black pieces at the end he
had a bishop against taru Rook but also
a passed Pawn that was
Unstoppable he's going for more he's
going for more in this position he's
threatening mate again check mate but
Wesley just gets his King out and
Black's winning CaRu he gambled he
bluffed and the bluff was called
Wesley's porn is simply going to March
down the board oh my there's no meate
the bishop slides back and you see a car
resign Wesley so the magic continues in
Toronto in the second game of the match
Wesley had yet another winning position
but agreed to a draw to safely win the
round the excitement continued in round
two with three of the four matches going
to Armageddon in fact in the Armageddon
game between Hikaru and mvl they bid the
exact same time that's Hikaru submitting
his bid and he burst out laughing as
they realized that they submitted the
exact same bid have we ever seen
anything like this in the chess was mvl
ended up winning that game with the
white pieces to win the match Carlson
also won his Armageddon game against
abdusattorov and carolana repeated moves
to draw with black in his Armageddon
game against
fua W so is the only player to not
require any Armageddon games to win his
matches and as a result he has the sole
lead of the round robin stage going into
day
two you know robertt said the magic
continues for so here in Toronto he is
the chess.com Global Champion the
defending and he sits there at top the
standings I agree with Robert something
about Toronto seems to suit Wesley so
well if it ended right now Magnus and
Wesley would get immediate buys into the
semi-finals and those middle six players
would still be here Hikaru and Dennis
would be going home how will things look
at the end of day two we're going to
we're going to find that out as we get
set for the matchups but uh yeah you've
uh you've got a lot of people already
feeling the nerves KY Carana Carlson
Vash the grao lavic Abdus tur off and
peruja Nakamura the matchup that sticks
out to you real quick before we start
previewing one by one yeah I mean it's
always kowana Carlson I mean that one
right there of course since the 2018
World Championship 12 draws going to a
rapid game I mean it was crazy there
Faby was right with him in the classical
but in the rapid he is having some
trouble but he wants to try to make up
for that today it will be interesting to
see what happens with Carana Carlson of
course but before we start previewing
that we're going to start with the guy
that as we said just seems to love
Toronto it feels magical to Wesley to be
here we know from talking to him that he
loves the hotel he loves the vibe he
loves the city and it is reflected with
chess whether it's on a computer or over
the board he may not have known that it
was over the board if you paid attention
to what we talked about yesterday but it
doesn't seem to make a difference will
his hot streaks continue as we look at
Wesley one of the most interesting
things about him is that throughout the
entire tour this is not just from day
one throughout the entire tour Wesley so
played the most accurate brand of Chess
of anyone in the entire Championship
field KY your thoughts on that that's
ridiculous I mean that's like 20 point a
little bit more what is that 21 more 24
more than than Magnus like you playing
better than Magnus I mean when do you
ever say that he's like no I'm not
playing better than Magnus I'm just
trying to play I just like playing Jess
and having a good time but he's playing
better than Magnus Danny we doing fair
play right cuz he like we're doing fair
play on Wesley we're doing fair play on
car we do fair play on everyone it
doesn't matter whether you're in a
facility with what I think is the
tightest fair play restrictions in the
world players have even been kind of
ruffled by what we've been doing here it
doesn't matter what you're doing into
Wesley the dude just plays an accurate
mistake-free brand of Chess and
continuing to talk about Wesley so right
now we're going to throw it over to Kaa
because she has
more Wesley so he is H so kind such a
good guy I did sit down with all the
players before the tournament started
and I got a chance to ask everyone their
thoughts on Wesley
so and uh what's your thoughts on Wy so
hyper solid player you know a very solid
player Wesley is solid I think that if
he had more uh maybe selfconfidence or
belief in himself then he could have
even achieved more than he did but what
he achieved in his career so far has
already been quite enormous and I've
always found him one of the most
difficult players to get even in the P
against if he can regain some of the
form that he had last year in the global
Championship here in Toronto then then
he has a chance Wesley is a formidable
opponent very early loses always ready
to pounds uh when you make a mistake but
otherwise it's also very difficult to
beat him so that's a great combo when he
feels the blood he's he's always there
normally I would say that the match
format is very well suited to to his
style but it feels that he's been he's
been considerably less solid maybe the
last year and a half doesn't really look
for win sometimes but he really H losing
so it's really difficult to beat him
he's a very good person his character is
really good so um I have a lot of
respect so good to hear just a massive
respect all the other top players have
for Wesley so so solid almost unbeatable
so the question today Danny can anyone
beat Wesley
so it's not going to be easy but NBL
Maxim bash the gr would like to answer
that question with a yes people are
going to beat Wesley so although you see
not as many draws historically as AAR
Nakamura has against Wesley so but KY 30
draws is still a lot I'm still I'm
getting bored like hey man I'm tired of
playing you maybe that's just the
strategy from Wesley play very solid and
you get annoyed and then you just crack
under the pressure somewhere trying to
make something happen you heard the
words from the players words like solid
words like difficult words like doesn't
beat himself we know it but NBL one of
the hottest players on the planet let's
remember he beat Magnus twice to get
here he is streaky by nature though so I
think even more than Wesley wanting to
be slowed down if you're the rest of the
field needs to write his ship right now
right of course I mean as tactical as he
is but he is very predictable too as
well as you we can prepare for his grfs
the night or we know this as fabbi was
able to do that in the candidates took a
whole year to prep still played night or
lost with this crazy P sack we just know
what you're going to play usually so
maybe he might have to make some changes
but then again he's not playing to his
style so we'll see well let's remember
he he already has won one match he beat
hikaro Nakamura in Armageddon so he's
not in the bottom rungs maybe he finds
the right mindset against Wesley so but
either way it's going to be ech epic my
first my first live slip up there let's
bring up what we also have to take a
look forward to the next matchup that
we're going to preview we start by
seeing the next matchup the two players
in it Magnus Carlson and Fabi on or
Carana are right at the top the
oddsmakers had Magnus at 50% before the
event now at 51% what's funny is as
crazy as that seems KY when we talked to
a lot of the players before the event a
lot of them said that that might have
actually been too low for Magnus yeah
that was scary to say I'm like you know
you guys are really good too right you
guys are forgetting how good you guys
actually are but it says a lot to the
testimony of how strong Magnus really is
especially in these rabbit formats and
maybe what you said there maybe it also
says a lot to how much the players fear
him right I mean Magnus Magnus has
dominated his generation and that can
pay off but of course Fabiano Carana the
second highest predicted player to make
it to the final and perhaps win it all
we know that Fabby played incredibly
well yesterday but a different type of
of well I guess you could say Magnus was
dominant in his games against the two
youngest players Fai had to go to
Armageddon twice but he won twice with
black KY oh I think he's his confidence
to the roof winning with black like that
too as well now I get you know white
pieces here it's a new day it's fresh
I'm at the top of the leaderboard I'm
feeling good now I just want to make
things a little bit easier for me today
if I can his pedigree also is a a strong
one he won the air things division 2
Division 2 is almost as hard to win in
this tour is division one he's a grand
chess tour winner won the singfield cup
and the rapid and Blitz this year among
many other things but how will he play
today against Magnus who no one will
ever let him forget that he lost a world
championship title in Rapid time
controls he never lost a classical chess
game to Magnus Carlson don't forget that
from 2018 but he lost in Rapid is that
in his mind today honestly it's it's
hard to get out of that of course
because you are playing Magnus you know
World Championship rapid but you just
kind of have to do it you know you just
got to really you know do it hey I have
to get out of my own head here and say
Hey look it's rapid it's a new day it's
only two games so we see what happens
especially if I can get get a good start
use my white correctly maybe draw with
black I can win this match it's only two
games here in day two but he played a
lot of games this year in the Champions
chess tour to get here and earlier this
week actually Kaa caught up with him and
here's her thoughts on that
interview we are in Toronto for the CCT
finals here with Fabiano Carana on fire
these days and you had a great run in
the CCT 2023 as well how will you
describe your journey through the season
poby uh I was really motivated from the
beginning so I played all the events I
think I was one of the few players to
play all the qualifying events and it
was a bit up and down for me some
disappointments but overall a lot of
really close ones I think they were all
close I don't know if there were any um
any uh you know wash overs one way or
the other and and some disappointing
ones because the when you lose and it's
really close that also is is a bit uh
painful now we are here with the top
eight players in Toronto what makes you
excited about being here now oh I'm
excited for the format it's going to be
really um I think unusual I don't think
I've played in a format like this and
also I think it's going to be a very
close fight yeah it's going to be very
exciting what are the fans in for this
week it's it's going to be exciting
that's all I can say um there there will
be a lot of tough fights and I hope that
I'll be able to um to keep the form that
i' I've been having recently but uh I'm
yeah I'm a bit nervous it's going to be
really tough and also excited can we get
you to describe your playing style I
don't know if I'm the right person to do
that I think probably someone else would
be better I was sort of known at some
point for my
calculation uh so I I've uh generally
been a good at very good at calculating
like because I I'm I'm sort of a
perfectionist in some way that I I
always want to to calculate to the end
and sometimes after that my um I I Veer
away from my initial assumption about
the position which was more correct so
I've noticed that at times that my
instinct is actually better than what I
achieve after I start to calculate
things what what would it mean to you
fby to win the Champions chest tour 2023
yeah actually that that would be amazing
I mean it would really Crown off the
year for me yeah for me this is like a
rapid and Blitz World Championship I
know that we'll we'll have that later
this month as well but uh this has
really all the all the best players or
nearly all the best players in the world
including Magnus and Hikaru and yeah
Maxim and Ali Reza and so it's it's such
a high level event that winning it is is
such a Prestige awesome well we hope you
have a great time in Toronto best of
luck thank
you I thought it was super
self-reflective the way Fabby broke down
his style talked about historically
really relying on his calculation his
perfectionist mentality see to the end
now even talking about the fact that he
wants to trust his intuition more maybe
his intuition is better than he thought
right away and I'm talking about him as
he's behind me because I've been giving
him that advice for a long time just
kidding Fabby remember how you were
going to make me your second and then
you
didn't never mind okay crickets all
right crickets all right there's Bobby
all right the players are are starting
to fill in we still got two more
matchups to preview though so we're
going to roll right into the next one we
haven't taken a look at yet that is fuia
versus Nakamura here we have a couple of
guys who played each other a lot online
I think fans are really used to some
epic epic throwdowns they both had four
D1 appearances this year canny your
thoughts on what speaks to you in this
match up this is very nice versatility
and both of course they can always mix
up openings I mean looking to strike
back is hearo here fza trying to you
know get it more of a lead win another
match here so that's going to be a class
of Titans as we always see as we see in
the Blitz and the bullet that they play
online now we have the lb here so it is
going to be one for the year well I
can't wait to see what foru is thinking
after his day one played really well
even though he's only one in one Kaa
caught up with him just a minute ago
before day two
begins I'm here with Al Resa fuja ready
for day two day one ending I know with
an armagon lost but overall how would
you sum up the start to the finals yeah
I think I'm playing decent chess the
second game against FAO was a bit
unfortunate but I am happy with my play
but the result should improve of course
and I bet ready and eager to bounce back
then today after losing that last match
yesterday yeah of course uh I think it's
very important match today Yaro also
lost too so um there's more pressure on
him than me so but it's a everybody's
trying to play their best so and you
andar both known as speed demons what
can we expect from the match with the
two of you yeah I think it will be very
interesting match um always when we play
a lot of people like to watch it so it's
a cool always cool to play Yaro and it's
very exciting always definitely and
finally beautiful outfit today I have to
say what was the plan behind your outfit
today alar I wanted to mix it up I
didn't care so how it would look I just
wanted to mix it up everything so let's
see how it go looking very good looking
very good looking confident so best of
luck to Al thank you thank you for
joining us he's looking good today Al sh
back to you
guys he is looking good today there he
is in the yellow shirt mixing up the
style you know it's funny and Magnus
said Magnus even mentioned all he res in
his postgame interview that despite
losing that Armageddon battle to Fabby
he felt like oi Resa might have played
some of the best chess in day one so
we'll see if he can continue that with
the he's all smiles right now looking
good in that shirt right if you look
good you feel good you feel good maybe
you play good what I'm saying maybe
feeling good you're going to play good
right got the drip right drip Master
Gucci Reser whatever you want to call
him of course the man is fly today and
he's going to try to do the same thing
on the board today all right we got one
more match up to get set before our
predictions let's remember the two
youngest players in the field are
battling it out and even though these
faces will continue to get to be more
known by fans for the next many years to
come they want to get the fans attention
today because if they beat each other
that might be their best chance to maybe
stay out of the bottom rungs who wins
this match up might still be here in a
few days can't he absolutely 100% I mean
lavic has a lot to prove here being uh
the youngest here in fact but abdur of
being the youngest World rap Champion
right ever you know so he's like I mean
you know I'm going to do my thing here
on paper that is but lavic is going to
try to change that tday there's Dennis
lavic as he was waiting in our player
refreshment area we keep that thing
pretty secure and that's right before
they step into the fair play room here
comes Magnus to get his fair play check
on people uh people tend to love love
seeing that and getting that going but
all right we've uh We've now talked
about all four of the matchups that are
getting set to go down here in day let's
remind everybody of what the format will
be throughout the entire week here in
Toronto the Champions chest finals are
here eight players who have earned their
Spot Will face off in an epic battle to
determine who will be this year's
champion of champions up for grabs will
be $500,000 in prizes with first place
taking home $200,000 for the victory the
action opens with an eight player round
robin the top two finishers Advance
directly to the semi-finals while the
bottom two are are eliminated the
remaining four players will do battle in
a double elimination survival bracket
again the top two players Advance while
the bottom two players will be
eliminated the final four Champions are
headed to a single elimination bracket
the winner will be crowned our champion
of
champions boy I'm excited to see this
play out all week it's time for us to
make our predictions for just today
though I'm throwing to you KY first
we're starting with Abdus satov lavic
who you got got to go to Abdus satov
there okay World rapping Champion I'll
agree with you Abdus satov yeah I'm also
going to go with Nordy I think this
could be close but I'm going with Nordy
all right let's
move oh sorry we're doing so mvl next
I'm sorry about that we're doing Wesley
so max V the gra your thoughts Wesley so
mvl I pick Sil that one okay okay I'll
disagree I'll say MBL I still think his
state of mind just something big happen
there I also think that NBL is going to
is going to find the form here and we're
going to get a very very packed and
close standings as this one plays out
now we're moving on to Carana Carlson
your thoughts on that one uh slight
favorite for Fabby Fabby yeah Fabby I
had a feeling you would say that and I
just want to disagree I'll say callon
it's funny because I'm also going with
Fabby even though they got here in very
different ways I think this is going to
be a really close one 2018 World
Championship rematch can't wait all
right last one Nakamura and fuja got to
go in Nakamura I mean you know bounce
back from yesterday yeah I don't see him
losing three in a row Nakamura I I tend
to agree I think it's hard to see hikara
losing three in a row so I'm also going
with him all right we've given you our
predictions for the four games that are
about to go down give us your
predictions in chat let us know what you
think how crazy are we or are we right
on before we throw it across the pond I
want to remind everybody that you do
have one last chance I think there are
very very few tickets available still to
join us in the fan Zone Saturday is sold
out completely sold out you missed it
wow you got to risk it to get that
biscuit you miss your chance but there
may be a few tickets left for Friday so
head over to the Champions chess Tour
website and get them to hang out with
the chess bras I'll be there Levy will
be there probably some of the players so
make sure you check it out and on that
note it is time for the games to begin
we throw this thing across the pond the
big pond over to Tanya and the boys
bringing you the hits since the 1980s
Tanya take it away hey dannie James Ka
you guys are ready the players are ready
and we are ready in the studio for the
reaction to begin David Robert day about
to get underway give me one name one
player you've got your eyes on today
Wesley so he's at the top and I think he
might stay there Wesley so he finds
himself uh at that pole position
currently along with Fabby and Magnus
Wesley today he's playing against Maxim
vasher gra that's not going to be an
easy one for Wesley no it's never easy
when you're playing Mex vrav but
Wesley's in great form we saw his
accuracy and he can bring it ah
for Wesley so it is so much about
ambition and confidence and the others
can't be too happy with the performance
he had on day one and the chess is under
way we see the handshakes between the
2018 World Championship players there
Magnus Carlson about to make his first
move against Fabiano Carana currently
ranked world number one and number two
and he starts with Knight to F3 are we
going to see a reti I thought I saw a
knight F3 there pretty sure we saw a KN
come out as well it looks like this is
actually a board from another game this
is the board between Wesley so shocking
right we see a grunfeld it must be Max
te yeah it's not Fabby here we don't see
his hands moving he's not making the
moves but uh yeah kg start there it
looked like neither player ready to
start the clock neither player in a
rhythm Magnus makes a move and Fabby
took a while to
respond I'm just wondering we saw our
gang in Toronto make some predictions
you think Fabby and Magnus had their uh
ears on what was going on there that was
definitely awkward because you could
hear them being like fby Magnus they
wanted to lower their volume because
they didn't want the people to be upset
with them and uh Fabby and Magnus
they're professionals they've been going
out for a long time specifically against
one another the 2018 World Chess
Championship came down to Rapid they
drew all their classical games and then
in the rapid that was where Magnus was
able to separate himself for a second
world championship in a row uh this is
not their board we will switch to the
Magnus and Fabiano game as soon as we
can but this looks like the Wesley so
versus Maxim V gr board love we got the
players it was definitely one a knight
F3 uh both these players with backto
back victories on day one and Fabby
almost did topple Magnus in the world
number one rankings back in 2018 he was
just two points behind him what do you
think is Fab's match strategy coming in
today well I think it uh appears at
least that he's trying to be solid with
black he will try and strike with white
Fab's so well prepared um he's known for
his openings he showed us that yesterday
he's been showing us for years now
already but uh yeah I think as long as
he can survive the openings he will
believe uh Queen B4 is a mouth slip
they're playing over the board of course
it's a an error there he did play Queen
takes Pawn on C4 of course um but yeah
if Fabby can survive the opening I think
he'll gaining confidence he's a very
brand new Fabby of course his rapid
skills have just grown exponentially
over the last uh few months it's been
amazing to watch uh how Fab's speed
chess has transformed uh this year and
he has been on fire now back in 2018 it
did go into tie breaks what are the
chances of this match going into an
Armageddon well I think the fans want me
to say 100% they want to see armagon it
is very fun but truthfully little
separates these two we've seen that in
some of their head-to-head clashes I
think David makes a good point that it's
not just classical but also rapid and
Blitz where fabbi has improved I would
say that magnet whoever he plays
whenever he plays them is the favorite
but Fab he's bringing it and in 2018
Magnus was so confident to take it into
the rapid playoff he just wanted uh
nothing of that final game but I think
now he just cannot feel that same
confidence in speech chest against Fabby
with the way Fabby has improved and we
see that it is Fabiano Carana who goes
into the first think of the position
this reminds me of Catalan structures It
Started From A Catalin and this very
familiar to both these players and David
you know Magnus very well he loves the
white side of a Catalin but how do you
think he's feeling about how this game
is developed I think Magnus is feeling
confident uh the Catalan uh as a mark of
respect was his world championship
opening uh in 20121 he's now using it
against Fabiano clearly this is uh home
cooking here and I'm not sure if Magnus
has played this exact move order before
he's got so many kind of one-off ideas
Within These openings something that to
test black to force black to be accurate
and he's essentially saying to Fabiano I
know everything here look at the clock
times he's barely paused Magnus and it's
definitely Fabby who's on his own it is
uh Fabby on the think right now and I
was just about to say that in these
positions it's all about Black getting
this break in the central break to get
more space to get out of that weakness
the weak Pawn on C7 usually when black
achieves this break it feels like you've
neutralized White's Advantage is that
fair to say here it's funny because I
was going to say the same thing but then
I thought this is Magnus Carlson we're
talking about level position equality
those are defined by who you're playing
in some ways so for five Carana he knows
that he's escaped the opening with a
good position but how quickly Magnus is
playing I think he smells that he can
actually get the upper hand the
evaluation Bar says well Fab's doing
everything perfectly and that is true
but maybe there's going to be a mistake
down the line and some players they'd
like to force their opponent to get into
this territory where it's a playing for
two results Magnus he can't really lose
this game but maybe he can win yeah this
feels like an IC illusion as
commentators because if you just showed
me the board I would say dead level no
chance White's going to be better
suddenly I look across and I see the
cameras I know it's Magnus Carlson I see
his clock time he's barely spent any
time at all and I'm starting to think
okay white must have an advantage
somewhere but why it must simply be
because Black's pawns on the queen side
are slightly vulnerable um I mean other
than that I'm struggling to see any real
imbalances any reason for Fabiano to
sweat here uh it must be very concrete
but surely with a couple of accurate
moves he has plenty of time he will find
uh a way to equalize this game and uh if
white is unable to create any pressure
in the next two or three moves this
one's going to fizzle out very very
quickly feels like Magnus not taking too
much risk here maybe hinting that he'd
be okay with a solid draw and uh
hopefully guiding it towards Armageddon
where he would Bank himself as a
favorite I'm already already wondering
what Fabby is so deep in the think tank
about because my first instant goes my
Pawn on B5 is under attack I should take
the pawn that's attacking me but I'm
getting the feeling that it's going to
be about a fight for some of these open
files let's say black does take that
pawn on A4 white takes back with the
Knight you'd be well advised to move
your Bishop because you don't want to
give up that piece for a knight so GL
you go back to A7 keeping on this
diagonal maybe white will just bring a
rook to C1 rather than D1 and I don't
know this kind of position where the A6
Pawn feels a little bit tender as the A1
Rook stares there and that's why fabbi
instead of capturing on A4 he brings his
KN back I think that's the wiser play
yeah very clever move here he's putting
some pressure on this night and uh if he
trades off this Knight then the B5 Pawn
feels much safer also hinting that he
might NAB the bishop pair uh if given
the opportunity I really don't see where
White's Advantage lies but Magnus
continues to Blitz continues to play at
break neck speed trading off I don't
understand I'm mystified I've got to say
black looks totally solid no matter
which way you take back in the center
with your knight Bishop where can the
problems lie I don't see anything at all
here for Magnus Carlson nothing looks
really solid for black so maybe Magnus
is saying I respect my opponent so much
that I'm going to play an opening
without risk Fabiano is handling this
perfectly thus far yeah it looks like
maybe after PA takes PA Magnus will try
and leap his Knight into the center uh
in the Catalan structure a D3 square is
a fantastic post for a night but at this
level this should be relatively safe
Fabiano opening success for
him definitely surprising uh how easily
Fabby with the black pieces has managed
to neutralize I was expecting more
ambitious play from Magnus uh starting
it's it's a mini match of just two games
they've got one white and then if Fabby
does secure the draw in this one he
might be the one getting ambitious in a
second game with the white pieces well
one player who needs to get ambitious
right now is Hikaru Nakamura there were
no birthday gifts for the five-time US
champion speed chess Beast Hikaru starts
his day he's on 0 to two he's playing
against ala later on he plays against
Magnus Carlson this is such a critical
game for Hikaru if things were to not go
his way that means a third loss in a row
that would really jeopardize his chances
to actually go through to the
semi-finals what are you expecting how
does Hikaru make the switch up from the
start that he had on day one Well it
can't really get worse from day one
because he lost both of his matches he
miss made a mistake against Maxim Vash
in a position where the computer said he
was even I think Hikaru knew that he was
playing quite well and the problem for
Hikaru they don't stop just because day
one ended you're playing Ali Raza fuza
we saw the Ferocious form that he was in
on the first day where he was
sacrificing pieces against FAO Carana
the match ultimately was a win for
Fabiano it was really an epic comeback
from him but fua showed that he's ready
to fight stylish alira with some stylish
play on day one and he did say earlier
today that he's looking to mix it up
against Hikaru Hikaru is speed chess
Beast currently wounded but a wounded
Beast can be even more dangerous what do
we make of the opening outcome that we
have right now David on the board has
Ali Resa managed to mix it up well it
feels like actually Hikaru just wants a
solid stable start here he just wants to
play himself into form perhaps uh alaza
looks solid as black white hasn't done
too much uh kind of anything special at
least in the opening stages white will
shortly Castle his King it looks
symmetrical other than the fact that
white has a set of double pawns on the D
file uh that gives more central control
however and gives a semiopen file on the
C file for the white Rook um so I've got
to admit I slightly prefer White's
chances um black is solid but a bit
passive right now and Nakamura does have
the luxury of time he plays a quiet move
like Pawn to A3 just on this last turn
he's basically saying to fua you break
out I'm going to slowly slowly improve
my pieces maybe creep forward later on
what are you doing in the meantime well
one way to break out for Ali RZA if he
really is in for an absolute brawl is
pushing the pawn in front of his King
two squares now considering his last
move was SL his Bishop back I don't
think he'll go for this choice but there
are positions where even though we're
told don't push Pawns in front of your
king you can get away with it because
white doesn't have the makings of an
attack so I do think that hikaro has
opted for a solid setup because of his
first day of action I'm with you David I
like his position with this semi-open C
file he's got those Pawns in the center
that mass is just controlling so many
key squares but for ala he's also done
nothing wrong so he should feel quite
confident himself yeah I think Nakamura
probably watched that game against k
yesterday where fuja Unleashed fire on
the board and he's saying okay I want
none of that fua is not going to attack
me in this one it's just going to be a
solid slow positional fight and okay
he's found another way fuia uh of
dealing with his slightly cramped
position he's trying to trade off pieces
often good classical chess wisdom if
you're lacking space if you're lacking
squares trade off and uh your remaining
pieces will feel much Freer more scope
for them and Knight to H5 not a great
post for that night but the dark squared
Bishops now are about to depart and uh
maybe a sigh of relief there for black
but in the meantime just looking very
very level and uh historically at least
I think that would favor uh Nakamura in
terms of this Clash of styles and it's
funny because normally I'm so eager to
jump into the X's nose of the position
it's just very solid there's really not
too much to speak of both players have
played sensible moves white will Castle
kingside eventually but with the bishop
staring at each other you need to make a
decision for Hikaru he can just trade
them but the way he's side eyeing the
position I can't tell if that's a carace
number six or number 16 where he smells
that he's a tactic or if he's just like
I really got a whole lot of nothing
right now well a bishop trade is on the
board and the only way to avoid it is to
fall back with the bishop in G3 giving
Ali RZA the option to cause the
imbalance by trading it off for the
night and Hikaru is about to take a
decision on it will he be more ambitious
with the bishop Retreat or trade off a
pair uh you can you you you always talk
about trading on your terms once the
bishop falls back to G3 it can even find
itself on that Central E5 Square I have
a feeling the more time Hikaru takes
he's going to decide to retreat the
bishop but he goes for the trade just as
I say he takes the decision this is
looking more and more level and while uh
this one continues let's head over to
Maxim VRA playing against Wesley so wesy
so with such a fantastic performance on
day one the only player who needed no
Armageddon for the two victories and
some decisions to be made on the board
right now Dynamic play that last move
which is being highlighted asks
questions Wesley needs to take a
decision on the center I think it's big
tactics that play here where Wesley
David I think Wesley's worse right now
Maxim has a dream come true out of the
grunfeld I'd be nervous if I Wesley yeah
first of all look at the clock times
Wesley has half the time of his opponent
mvl just blitzing he's gone back to
basics employing again his childhood
favorite the grinfeld defenses black
often a good strategy he's been
switching it up throwing new openings
out there throughout the last 12 months
24 months and he's uh somehow surprised
Wesley so early on here still looks very
tense a lot of pieces on the board white
has some control over the center but
yeah Black's pieces are all mobilized
and look how quickly mvl is playing he
sacrifices The Exchange oh we have to
dive in right now because Maxim's Rook
is under threat from that Bishop on G5
and he says I don't care take the rook
and that's probably what Wesley kind of
has to do otherwise he just lost the
pawn for no reason and The Rook takes
back and yeah you can take this Pawn on
D4 but after Knight takes D4 and we see
a trade of minor pieces trades are
supposed to be good for the side with
extra material but the problem for white
is black is Super Active there's a rook
staring through your own Bishops towards
the enemy bishop and queen there's a
queen on C7 that could line up with a
bishop on the diagonal maybe cause some
problems in front of the white king and
let's not forget a pawn count on the
queen side shows three for black and
only one for white that c Pawn can just
Rumble up the board C4 right in this
kind of position could be an option yeah
looks beautiful for black I've got to
say minimal material investment in
return you get so many uh advantages
long term and this is happening we're
rattling down this variation I love it
from Maxim I don't know if he's in
preparation or whether this is just
instinctive using all of those years of
experience in the grinfeld defense but
he's got the upper hand Wesley on the
back foot already as white he just
understands these positions so well
Maxim V gra the grinfield that we're
seeing on the board and he wasn't even
on the board when he took this immediate
decision he sits down and immediately
takes the pawn giving up the Rook it
just shows how much of an understanding
he has of this he loves the exchange
sacrifices whether it's the Rook takes
C3 Rook takes Knight in a KN off or in
this case a giving up and exchange for
initiative this just feels like The
Clash of styles between two of the best
players on the planet but Maxim VRA has
managed to get the kind of position that
suits his style while Wesley doesn't get
the kind of positions that he enjoys and
that clock that you pointed out that's
going to be a major major factor in this
one whether it's preparation or
inspiration he's taking him down this
tactical Matrix where Wesley doesn't
always feel the most comfortable or
confident and Wesley did just capture on
D4 we will see some more material come
off but what's the essential point of
this position is Black's King is very
safe so that means he could focus on the
queen side where he has three pawns just
one for white and that is going to tell
the tale of this position the eval bar
slightly favoring black I think from a
practical point of view how easy it is
to play We also should favor black as
well look at the speed would wish Maxim
is just blitzing out his moves I mean
he's loving those Bishops on the board
The Rook lined up he's got that extra
Pawn this is Maxim V lra's bread and
butter these kind of positions Wesley I
think he's in trouble and he knows it
yeah first I have to say Robert The
Profit you've predicted this whole
variation and uh secondly I think yeah
black just has a dream position uh you
still have to play energetically you
don't want to allow too many more
exchanges for example if the light
Square Bishops disappear if Queens
disappear suddenly White's Rooks might
gain in power
but for now with this exact material IM
balance um it feels like it does favor
black as long as you're quick and start
throwing pawns forward as quickly as
possible on the queen side uh I think
maxan doing a good professional thing as
well after that t tactical mess that
tactical melee he's pausing he's
deciding a pawn a plan of action and
then he'll change the pace again speed
up yet again and put pressure on Wesley
so a nice post for his Bishop here and
yeah massive pressure on white Wesley
has to be so accurate just to survive
these next few moves actually those
pawns are rolling the only bit of good
news I would say for Wesley is that he
has Pawns of his own and as soon as I'm
getting these words out he plays Pawn to
F4 so black has three onone on the queen
side of the board our left hand side
white has four on three on the king side
and you typically want to push the pawns
where you have that advantage and if
that pawn gets up to F5 and maybe even
all the way up to F6 we could see the
start of a checkmating net with the
queen running up to H6 and that could be
very dangerous so Wesley he understands
that he can't just sit and do nothing he
needs to act fast
active defense really uh really
instructive stuff from Wesley this time
and actually yeah F5 I think Maxi might
have underestimated this it did look
like oneway traffic black about to play
the move C4 but uh pushing the pawn to
C4 would allow a Counterattack white
will not passively react passively
Retreat he'll go forward and go for the
black king so far from oneway traffic
and wow Maxi Vash gra again playing so
quickly so instinctively just plays King
to h8 into the corner mysterious stuff
he's allowing the attack to continue
maybe he's recognizing that after F5
with his King tucked in the corner he
can actually capture and the G2 Pawn is
something that he can Target place that
Bishop in the center throw your Rook on
over to G8 white is not checkmating in
fact white is the one who might get
checkmated if you're not careful this is
some crazy tactical Affairs here on the
board and Wesley I think he did another
very smart thing instead of throwing
that pawn up too soon he needs to time
it correctly he just slides Queen out of
the rook's line of sight he's covering
that C4 Square another time if White had
a free turn maybe bishop C4 let's trade
off those light Square Bishops and then
I think we start to see an advantage for
White and the Queen on C2 is really
nicely placed because even now if black
was to go C4 you don't need to think
about your Bishop you can go with the
idea that you pointed out earlier just
keep pushing your F Pawn now uh you
stepped out of the pin and uh Black's
still in the pin so D3 Bishop will not
be hanging really nice play by both
players but again looking at the clock I
think it's pressure on Wesley in this
one yeah pressure on Wesley but the last
few moves he has been kind of fighting
that swing in momentum we thought it was
heading in Black's favor but the top
players in the world they always find
ways uh to kind of stem the flow and uh
yeah I love these last two moves Wesley
so playing really actively it feels like
again he's been woken up the opening
didn't go white uh favor but he's
finally finding uh his rhythm and that's
when Maxim is spending the time so
Wesley is doing the professional thing
thinking on Maxim's clock and I think we
will see this time start to even out
unless Maxim says I need need to make a
concerted effort to punish Wesley with
that 17th piece the clock but for now it
does seem like Wesley has found his
footing the position is double edge
chances for both sides yeah feels like
this is one of the most exciting games
of the round so far uh very different
type of game to the maneuvering battle
the kg uh kind of standoff we saw
earlier between Nakamura and fuja this
one is about to uh really heat up and
queen to E7 Queen slide feels really
slow suddenly uh from fash gra feels a
bit in Ive this one and all of those
plans pushing pawns forward exchanging
off the light squared
Bishops suddenly maybe I'm St to favor
white the evaluation bar certainly
shooting up in Wesley's favor and again
quick reply but if Maxim is also
starting to favor Wesley's position he
might be doing the defensive thing he's
saying you know what that even if these
bishops get traded I am down a rook for
a bishop and pawn that's a onepoint
Advantage for the white side and if
that's the case then I can actually get
a little bit of a fortress my Bishop on
D4 will blunt that D file nothing's
going on there the C5 pawn stops an open
file what do Rooks need open lines and
unless white is eventually going to push
that F Pawn the lines will remain closed
so perhaps Maxim says I can actually
hold this if I more or less do nothing
well that last move looks like Maxim
isn't doing much but keeping the
pressure on the clock and for more on
this game we're going to go straight to
Toronto we've got Danny with us Danny do
you think Wesley is in trouble right
now I definitely think Wesley's in
trouble and you know we were talking
about the game outside on the couch with
everyone weighing in and we obviously go
back to the point a lot about how mbl's
repertoire is so consistent almost
stubborn everyone knows he's playing the
night over the grunfeld but we also
observed that Wesley can also be a
pretty consistent creature of habit and
maybe against NBL those styles are not
going well I mean the most reflective
factor of the fact that Wesley is
obviously in trouble is actually not on
the board but on the clock Maxim is
playing instantly Wesley's position is
only getting worse I think we're going
to see the streaky Frenchman turn it
around
here big moment and uh when we were
having our chat earlier with Wesley I
remember you mentioned that for Wesley
it's so much to do with how confident
he's feeling now he's had a fantastic
start but things looking shaky here what
about Maxim did you catch up with him
yesterday how's he feeling about his
form after day
one what's funny is maxim of all the
players I feel like remains in the best
of spirits he's still teasing with Anish
giri on Twitter as far as where where
that autograph photo is being hidden
around I can't wait for people to see
the story of how he got that that's
coming that's coming later with some
content we did but no Maxim was in good
spirits obviously he lost one match in
Armageddon but won another and didn't
seem to phase him and so with Wesley
going right into the lions den here in
the grunfeld I'm I'm I'm surprised um
but before we move on I wanted to say
that the reason I had to jump in right
now is because Robert thought I was
going to let it slide that he referenced
whether it was number six or number 16
hikara Nakamura faces first of all
Robert
you got to stay in your lane bro
secondly it was actually number four cuz
what you misunderstood is it was the six
facial expression but when the wrist is
there that's actually number four which
is a sign of hikaru's confidence he's
very confident against fuja I don't know
why but he is but Hikaru also I think
Super confident and Robert don't don't
let that happen again please try to
involve you even when we are far apart
so not that's a lesson to me I won't try
to speak to you uh when we're in very
different countries and continents so
I'll learn my lesson turn this
relationship negative right now you know
this thing works long distance I'm just
I'm just needed to call you out a little
that's I I I was sitting there watching
and you're referencing number six and 16
and I about choked on my food I'm like
no no no I got to hop on
there thanks DY for that update T Robert
get a room guys I mean we got to get
back to the chest right now and look at
what we do have on the board the F Pawn
has moved forward the F6 square is under
control so at least that's not happening
anymore the one thing that worries me
for Wesley right now is that Maxim can
actually start getting ambitious on the
queen side with his own pawns can you
think about advancing that B Pawn one
step ahead and creating passes that can
cause trouble to White yeah feels a bit
inconsistent what Wesley has been doing
uh he's been trying to undermine the
black queen side something we call the
minority attack when one Pawn uh kind of
attacks a larger number of Pawns to
create some weaknesses suddenly he's
switched up and gone for the black king
but this looks like a shot in the dark
this is really not being uh this is not
a realistic attack for white you have no
pieces simply and I liked your idea
Tanya I liked pushing the pawns forward
why not that's where your advantage lies
push on the side you're stronger but
instead he plays a quiet move Rook to D7
he's just covering the king side
covering the queen side Maxim I think is
trying to hustle on the clock Danny
mentioned it uh maybe the biggest
problem isn't the position itself it's
just that White's position uh yeah not
so instinctive to play and no time two
and a half minutes only yeah B Maxim VRA
still about four minutes on the clock
and drops a little piece what do you
think those are nerves what's going on
now he knows that he's up on the clock
the position everything to play for and
the move that he just made right Rook
stepping up it's actually quite a nice
one David because there were these ideas
of trading on the G file opening up The
Rook the queen could have lined up from
the B3 Square create pressure on the
pawns so playing prophylactic and also
B5 always in the air I would pick black
any day uh of the week in this one oh
Maxim is definitely in the driver's seat
and the bishop on D4 dominates this
board because the dark Square bishop and
White's pawns are now in light squares
there's no competition over there and on
the queen side there may not be
competition for Black's pawns that are
about to advance all right we going to
keep an eye out on this one but it looks
like Wesley is in trouble on the board
and the clock uh and we will shift our
Focus to Hikaru Nakamura the other
player who has been in big trouble so
far in the finals against alira fuja and
once again alira with double Dr on the F
line this to me is very reminiscent of
his game against Fabiano Carana where
there was this kingside attack that
happened potential sacrifices on F3 is
Hikaru feeling the heat right now with
white definitely feels that way uh the
momentum of this game it looks really
solid for Nakamura maybe he had a small
Advantage he had a nice Pawn structure
but things have been turning black has
been improving every move look at this
fua suddenly centralizing his Queen
maybe Shifting the queen over to help
out the black Rooks White's Knights are
the final bastions of Defense here just
holding the position together but
Nakamura he is certainly on the
defensive look how passive White's major
pieces are the heavy pieces White's
Queen White's Rooks not doing any work
at all so I think black is slightly
better it's nothing kind of tangible yet
but it could certainly become that way
it would probably be almost winning for
black if his Knights were better his
Knights right now are passive but they
are great defensive pieces covering the
central pawns but if one of those
Knights could hop into the D4 square a
rook sacrifice for that Knight on F3
would be imminent so that's the thing
thing that is allowing hikaro to stay
afloat right now he's very passive
himself but he is trying to cover all
his bases on the king side yeah what do
you play though how do you I mean how do
you improve your pieces wh's Knights are
totally stuck White's Rooks I mentioned
a bit uh yeah I mean struggling for air
right now Nakamura he does have a small
advantage on the clock I've seen him so
many times online playing these Blitz
Games he kind of keeps the status go
stabilize stabilize stabilize and only
strike later but he's got to kind of uh
survive the storm first of all
absolutely David and and your question
very valid how does Hikaru create air
for himself in this position and I'm I
want to bring up a move here you know
you're looking for Pawn breaks you want
more space is D4 ever on the radar for
white in these positions to try to get
that space to try to get some activity
because one thing about Hikaru he hates
being passive in these kind of positions
and just letting alira do whatever he
wants D4 is that something that he can
think about I want that to happen I feel
like if you play D4 I'm sacrificing my
Rook on F3 because I was was just saying
my Knights need to become more active
now I take on D4 and if you take back on
D4 with your queen in comes my knight to
E5 and I'm about to go to forkville on
F3 hitting your queen your king and your
Rook all at once so this type of
position it can open up yes for hi carus
pieces but maybe even more so for Al
razas wow tactics Galore and uh I mean
D4 is so natural it's so desirable as
you say Tanya but if it doesn't quite
work concretely in this position you're
a bit stuck and Black's Knight does have
other ways around Robert mentioned the
D4 Square takes two jumps with one KN
and then you're in you're into D4 after
perhaps sacrificing first on F3 uh so
there are plans available to fuia and
suddenly the clocks have balanced out uh
it's pretty much level now on time and
wow black definitely in the driver seat
Nakamura just unable to break this trend
of the tournament so far and we've seen
Ali RAR when he gets his kind of
positions when he gets the attack going
he's just so good with that in
converting these positions it's far from
over but passive passive play here for
Hikaru really no way to break through he
does line up The Rook so kind of eyeing
that break that we were looking at
earlier D4 in the air now uh and also
let's remind everyone in the round robin
stage after this two players will be
eliminated Hikaru Nakamura is yet to
score a victory he's yet to go on the
leader board and he plays Magnus Carlson
next it's really critical for him to try
and get this one uh in bag and here come
the pawns if he's gonna try to prevent
Black's attack I don't know how because
all of Black's pieces are ready now he
pushed another Pawn that frees the C6
square up for his Knight and the big
question is now that D4 is unavailable
from the white side will he have to
capture a pawn in the center and that
does allow some more black pieces to
flow so I'm looking at this game and the
overall standings and I think that Ali
Risa must be the happier of the two he
did struggle against Fabiano in that
Armageddon game but it's a new day and I
think it's a new Ala yeah ala so
aggressive pushing pawns I love it
Robert these three three pawns for black
you could see a fourth Pawn joining the
uh joining the fight Black's Knights
about to come forward as well uh
Nakamura contorting he's really finding
some odd moves to say in this game
Knight to H2 looks like an odd square
and now if I were Alara I would not
hesitate I think that maneuver you
mentioned bring the Knight into the
center beautiful Outpost and uh big
Advantage he plays that move he's just
in the flow feels like Alara is really
hitting top form right now and Nakamura
such a critical match he needs to
somehow pull that break and Rive this
game this is a big one and now both
players under two minutes uh I think for
Hikaru especially alir a one-1 match if
he goes to 0 to3 Hikaru is staring at
elimination from the round robin stage
which would be quite disastrous he jumps
forward with the Knights so black does
have the opportunity to do the same uh
Ali Reza strong Position will he be able
to convert this one with the clock
situation that's the big thing is both
players are approaching severe time
trouble there is increment the players
get 3 seconds added every move that they
make so that is the good thing for them
they won't lose on time but when you get
down to those waning seconds that's when
the likelihood of a mistake does go up
and here I think that the likelihood of
mistake it's uh going up for both sides
because now that Knight has jumped into
G4 it's putting some pressure on the
black center it's also protecting that
weak spot on F2 so that Knight is doing
a whole lot it can continue rerouting
it's getting messy and the third thing
that you just pointed out I think that's
a really important point that he can
reroute and go to F5 and actually
challenge that uh very strong Knight
that Ali Resa has just dropped on D4
meanwhile we do have our first result as
the two youngsters nck and uh Dennis
lawick and their game one in a draw but
this is where the action is at and it's
really heating up yeah rotating those
nights Nakamura he's so good at that at
that uh kind of maneuver phase of the
game and right now he's suddenly got a
30 second time advantage and W I just
saw an evaluation bar switch uh in the
game between Wesley so and Vash Gra some
crazy tactics over there which we might
jump to but this one so tense Nakamura
he's traded off a set of Pawns with
white but Black's Knight on D4 so
dominant by far the MVP the most
valuable piece right now and uh okay at
least he's trying to trade it off
Nakamura he's fighting hard it's not a
night it's a stallion and unfortunately
for hikaro he wants to trade it off but
he also doesn't because if you take it
then black gets a pass Pawn cemented in
the center so look at hikaro trying to
undermine the defense of that night both
players are playing well I'll raise it
down under 550 second though and Hikaru
very resourceful he does keep the
tenacious defense going but we did see a
big slip on the eval bar in Wesley
versus Maxim Basher lra and we're going
to take a quick look and I think we're
also getting a result
in wow they just finished and Wesley so
goes down Maxim VRA sacrifices The
Exchange and gets the job done with the
black pieces taking the lead in his mini
match against the tournament leader wow
and we will recap that one later because
there was some stunning tactics towards
the end but all eyes on this clash
between Nakamura and fuja now both sides
down low on the clock just under 30
seconds for fua just over a minute for
NAA and uh okay a bunch of knights that
stallion has gone Robert it is and now
it's that Knight on F5 that white had is
replaced by a pawn opening up that Rook
that is sitting next to the White Queen
so all of a sudden Black's pawns look a
bit fragile they're all split apart a
lot of isolated ones this really is
becoming a tense battle with chance for
both sides and you can start targeting
those pawns already by doubling up on
the E file The Rook on B2 suddenly
really nicely placed it was defending
that F2 pawn and now it can start
attacking uh uh Black's E5 Pawn uh with
the idea of going ahead but he chooses
the Queen instead lines up Queen E5 is a
threat
defended the eval eval evil either way
it is planted in the middle but to me it
looks like momentum on white side
suddenly Tanya you highlighted a couple
of weak pawns three isolated pawns for
black such easy play for Nakamura Queen
in to the heart of Black's position
there nice uh kind of finesse added to
that move just with the gesture there
and wow fia's clock I don't fancy his
chances of holding this maybe it was
less a finesse and more invitation
because it hovered on that C4 square and
Al says don't mind if I do I'm going to
push my Pawn up there that Rook on F4
that's defending that pawn laterally
that's Behind Enemy Lines and now that
Queen is behind Black's lines here both
sides have different ideas and I think
that white Rook that's on B2 that was
previously defensive it's going up he
does it he's up a pawn he's up a pawn
but look at those white pieces the White
Queen the white Rook on the seventh rank
so many targets Black's King not
entirely safe okay there's a hit on
White's Rook at the bottom of the board
right now Black's Queen really agile
right now showing off all the angles but
surely that Rook just moves and also a
really nice Square because you defend
the C7 Square from White's Queen bubling
up on the seventh R oh and he reaches
for the rook and moves it to F1 yeah was
that that was a hesi he went to C1 and
over to F1 and here we see look at that
Rook that black Rook is defending the
Czech main square and it's putting
pressure towards the white king watch
out for some night sacrifices from Ali
Rea because he's trying to exploit the
fact that the white king may be in some
grave danger why is hiu hesitating so
much on every move are you seeing the
indecision there and there it is there's
that Knight sacrifice it couldn't be
captured and hikaro he attacks the black
queen the queen goes all the way back to
the corner keeping an eye at the square
in front of the white king the white
it's blocked yeah blocks it out again
dominance on the seventh Rank and
blunder from fua as he allows okay I was
going to say a queen check but the white
Rook comes in threatening to eliminate
the Black Knight the Black Knight once
it's taken this will end in Checkmate
wow a check and now the Knight is going
to be captured this is going to be a
mate on the seventh rank Hikaru Nakamura
escapes oh he turned it on just at the
right moment the black queen sacrifices
herself she dro drops off the board but
white has a decisive Advantage now queen
of Knight will beat two Rooks wow and
that Knight is going to jump to H5 a
threatening mate as well on G7 Hikaru
Nakamura with a big turnaround about to
take the lead in his
match what a tactical flurry that was
Nakamura really upping the pace turning
on the style and yeah this is a decisive
material advantage you're also Landing
potentially a check mating attack and we
see a handshake that is resigned by alza
Hikaru Nakamura relieved after his first
first win he takes the lead in his match
against Ali RZA and he needed this win
to stay in the race Ali RZA to bounce
back has to win the second game on
demand he starts with the white pieces
Hikaru there walking off but then takes
a pause let's take a look at the
remaining game and Desperation probably
just brought out the best in aaru
Nakamura and these two players they've
been in pretty locked battle for a long
time now very few pieces remain on this
board uh there's a bishop for black you
can see it very close to Fabiano there
white has a night but they've been
making little progress though Magnus
remains a pawn ahead no idea how he got
that pawn but Magnus is doing Magnus
things he's going to play this out till
the end of time yeah this makes me feel
all warm and fuzzy inside makes me glow
with pride that Magnus Carson is trying
to grind like a Grandmaster trying to
squeeze water from a stone and win this
end game which should of course be a
draw because white doesn't have uh too
much ammunition left but a pawn is a
pawn and you can tickle you can probe
away hope for a blunder Knights are
tricky As We Know uh but black
essentially should be fine with any Rook
exchange and uh it's hard to imagine
white winning this against solid defense
he's trying he's trying Magnus Carlson
the only thing you need to avoid as
black here is the trade-off of both the
pieces the rook and KN if it's a King
Pawn ending then you'll be lost but
that's not going to happen as long as
one piece stays on the board you're
doing good but the opening we had it was
hard to imagine Magnus actually getting
an extra Pawn to start with to even
start dreaming about creating chances
well I think Magnus dreamed of exactly
this situation where with absolute best
play Fabio would hold the draw you you
tip your proverbial cap you say you're
the second best player in the world
right now and for Fabby yeah he's down a
pond but he's holding everything
together there are very few ideas for
white and Fabby he's you know he's going
to hold this the second best player in
the world but robbert that's quite
debatable the year that Fab's had if he
stick to 23 he could be the best player
in the year just this year what a
performance he's had yeah what a
performance and uh it's really
instructive how he's holding this
position um Fab's body language looks
very stoic right now he's just keeping
his pieces active look at that black
Rook it's just annoying white it's just
a nuisance piece looking at the second
rank looking at White's F Pawn giving
any checks anytime the white king pokes
its head out Black's Bishop po kind of
poised perfectly as well blocking pawns
attacking pawns uh yeah Fabiano this is
one to learn from this game for both
sides and there is a 50 move rule in
chess if no pawns are moved no pieces
are captured and the game ends as a draw
so the Arbiters they're going to have
their jobs laid out for them on site and
it looks like well that King has a job
now the white King instead of passively
sitting protecting pawns it's out in the
open that could scare Fabby we'll see if
he's able to continue holding Magnus off
yeah Robert you mentioned the 50 move
rule the last time there was a pawn push
or a capture was move 49 so uh Magnus
has to make progress by move 99 look at
the move counter on the top left hand of
your screens we're now at move 83 he has
to it's reset push up on before we get
to 99 it's reset 50 more moves before
that becomes relevant again and the F
Pawn pushing forward does uh cause
Fabian some concern maybe and he's going
for the H Pawn and it can you actually
protect the H Pawn now it looks like
Magnus moved his rook and the H Pawn is
going down and with the H Pawn falling
maybe white will push the pawn but black
can sacrifice his Bishop for the pawn
just for everyone out there you may be
new to chess it is a theoretical draw
rook and Knight versus Rook that is a
well-known draw especially for players
of this caliber and that Bishop on H4
really nicely placed there it's taking
away so many key squares from White's
Knight to jump into to create any mating
net around Black's King and Fabby
playing really confidently he's playing
fast he's making All the Right Moves and
that is a forc rook trade and with that
a check comes in is he going to just
trade everything and the bishop takes
Knight Rook takes Rook King takes Rook
well Bishop takes Knight Rook takes
Knight is probably what caused probably
some concern but it was going to be a
draw regardless and now we see it a King
Pawn ending but black gets the
opposition this is going to be played
out and Magnus there he size he's not
happy but I think it was just impossible
to get anything more in this position
it's a draw this one ends in a tie just
like every classical game did between
these two in the 2018 World Championship
and I think Fabby is a happy man well he
played great defense I mean he did not
break there were moments there where
things could have gone wrong for him but
the fbby we've seen in 2023 is a man who
is not very mistake prone very few
errors throughout the year and the
conference that you talked about we've
saw it on full display in that game and
Robert you and I were having this
discussion before the start of the
broadcast today do you think that Fabby
actually has been the best player in the
world in 2023 it's one of those
complicated questions that you I'm not
trying to get a cop out on the answer
but he has had the best performance
rating in classical chess I think that
speaks magnitudes so there's definitely
the argument for Fabiano Magnus didn't
play oh so many classical events and you
could argue what are his Ambitions but I
think there is a good argument of Fabby
having been the best player in 2023 In
classical chess and he does start with a
draw against the world number one and
there we have our results from game one
of round three there is the final rapid
game coming up between these players
Wesley so has to win on demand to take
it to Armageddon Ali Raa fja needs to do
the same crazy crazy game between these
two players danis lazic Abdu satro was a
peaceful draw David what was the
highlight for you in this well fought
match well uh yeah I promised uh a a
glimpse a highlight of the so versus
Maxim VRA finale there and just the
tactics that flowed in the Frenchman's
favor I want to highlight this one
moment it actually looked like Wesley so
had escaped the worst whes Rooks lining
up it looks like white actually is the
one on the attack some targets including
the F7 Pawn however Maxim turned things
in his favor by pushing forward byp
passing the white F Pawn G5 not only is
this a good defensive move but we see
the attacking ideas after Rook to E1 and
now G E4 opening up the black queen on
this diagonal if you take this Pawn
you'd walk into a devastating double
attack a check hitting this Rook as well
but not just this after Rook to G3 a
beautiful tactic a queen sacrifice Queen
to H4 and if Rook takes Pawn now the
black queen would have sacrificed itself
and a nasty Checkmate on the H file
because the bishop covers the G1 Square
this tactic allowed Maxim to win
material and after Queen to D3 He simply
dropped back his Bishop now with Bishop
takes E5 double attack on the the queen
on the rook and he won the game that was
so nice the the ability to see that
Queen Sacrifice from a distance the
domination of the dark squares Maxim VRA
he every bit earned that game even when
things started to go to Wesley's way
Maxim never gave up he never caved in
and in fact he's the one who showed that
he had the upper
hand such a great fight that was and
we're seeing amazing chess all
throughout history he's being written in
Toronto for the fight to be the
Undisputed King of the Champions Chester
and you can own a digital a piece of
digital chess history and there it is it
is beautiful displayed of the trophy and
all you got to do is go to chess champs.
to bid on this stunning stunning artwork
the champion of the tour will receive
one of these and you could be the
recipient of the only other displayed of
this uh beautiful trophy in front so go
to chess champs.
and make your bid on this one and we got
a big big game two coming up off round
three the final rapid game between these
two players where Wesley so needs to
beat this guy Maxim Vash lra on fire in
that game one on the clock as well it's
going to be determination from both of
these we will be back with more action
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things this December they are back for
one more round chess GPT I'm already
liking this bot it's such a big troll
dead lost Grandpa Gambit decides to get
a bit crazy because he sacrifices the
queen Frank and Isa and everyone's
favorite Kitty mittens well if I go here
it's a fork if I go here it's a it's
another Fork so I guess the only safe
move is
this I didn't even see
that oh that is so sick that's actually
sick oh sh is 95 oh
my play them again while you can on
chess.com
[Music]
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com connect your chess.com account
and Twitch account at go. chess.com
connect accounts and bang boom voila
you're done 100% ad free Bliss forever
more whether you're following our events
on site or on stream type the command
connect in the chat and thank you for
helping bring these shows to
life Wesley so was qualified for the
first event as the reigning chess.com
Global championship winner but his road
to Toronto has not been without
challenges from tough matchups against
Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus Carlson to
his remarkable comeback through the
losers bracket in the aim chess rapid
black is completely winning the race
even without Black's three pawns this is
still actually a draw so Hikaru he knows
he's got this in the bag he's smiling
he's got a Time advantage and he
clinches his fist Wesley resigns fist
pump wow it's over Hikaru Nakamura makes
it through to the Grand Final good call
there Dan the N joins the attack he
takes the pawn and it's a big mistake is
there a finish here David I think it's
something to do with Knight D5 and the
B6 square is calling my name I'm
freaking out what is it it's over he
gets the draw I think there was a draw
offer that was made and Wesley just
accepts it nbec played Rook D7 it is a
dead loss situation but he just offered
a draw in the Grand Final he lost to
Magnus Carlson but Banks enough points
to qualify for the tour finals this
could be the last few moves of the a
chest
rapid and he wins a beast the pawn on D3
is going to
Queen back the check meting it's on the
board Simon
there we go oh my God and we have a
winner Magnus Carson checkmates Wesley
so and wins the a chess
[Music]
rapid
sh
[Music]
a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
to
the official chess.com merch store is
back and bigger than ever we've got the
perfect gift for the chess lovers in
your life fresh new designs for t-shirts
socks hats and more at chess.com do shop
or use the command merch in chat to shop
right now and we've got Ka with the
player who's been playing some big
chess well a big match here today for
Fabiano corana against Magnus Carlson
coming now from Mao in the first game is
that a good start for you yeah it's a
good start I was under pressure for most
of the game I think Magnus knew the line
better than I did uh the the opening he
got okay it should be an equal position
but he was more comfortable with the
position and in the end game it was
quite dangerous I think it should always
be a draw I don't think I was ever
losing or anything but of course I was
under pressure and low on time um
definitely it was uh a bit of a close
close call White pieces in game two will
we see a winner in this match or will we
see armag get on before that happens
well we'll see a winner in the match but
I don't know if there will be arm kenon
or not that's the that's the only
question but uh yeah of course it's
going to be tough uh one way or the
other of course it's a good start but
it's only a draw it's not you know uh it
hasn't shaken up the match uh in any
real way it's just um a normal start
let's say so for how long have you had
the the opening ready the plan for your
white game here against Magnus in the
round
robin I don't think I've had I even have
already now okay interesting interesting
so you will now prepare and find out
what you're going to play I'll think
about what I'll play for sure yeah right
it's gonna be interesting thank you Fabi
and good luck in that game all right
let's see what Fabian Carana opens with
with the white pieces against Magnus
Carlson in game two that is uh the big
question what will be the opening Choice
the opening approach by Fabby he
mentioned that he felt the pressure the
pull in the game one after the opening
but he managed to hold it quite
confidently and that's supp that has to
give you some boost when you're playing
against Magnus Carlson and you hold a
difficult end game you know you're
playing some of the best chess it's how
we described it in the studio that
Magnus wanted a slight pull tried to
play a position he was more comfortable
in but Fabiano played Perfect Defense
that was never an opportunity for Magnus
to get a win so Fabby he should be
feeling confident but you don't want to
get over confident and press tooo hard
with the white pieces and I'm going to
get our body language expert in David
you've just been appointed that you know
Magnus well what is that expression oh
did he just hear
me it's quite possible he did look over
at the exact moment you said that Tanya
um to me he just looks very calm very
composed look very looks very Zen right
now Magnus Carson um just the way he's
approached this whole tournament so far
it's still early days of course but he's
playing all of his best openings uh no
freestyling no troll open as we
sometimes see from the world number one
and uh yeah he looks in the zone can you
hear me Magnus smile if you can oh my
God I can see the smile I think he can
it's the telepathy right there between
David and Magnus he's ready to go with
the black pieces it's going to be quite
the battle will they go into Armageddon
or will we have a decisive result in
this one how ambitious is Fabby going to
be with white I don't think he will do
anything unusual by his own standards by
what typical repertoire is but I've been
thinking about this question that you
asked about Magnus and Magnus on day one
played Dennis lzic and nirc Abdus
satarov at least on paper the two lowest
rated players in the field the youngest
players in the field so Magnus got to
off to a great start with two match
victories but I do think that he
recognized that his toughest Road lays
ahead with Fabiano sitting across from
him with the rest of the opponents on
his slate I mean he knows that this is a
big match up against Fabby and it's
handshakes games are underway it's go
time and Fabby starts with one E4 is
that Knight to C6 wow commentator's
curse I said all of his best openings
Magnus Carlson he has played this move
and In classical chess as well uh very
recently including in the European Team
Championship over the board uh just last
month but okay this is provocative stuff
white already sees as a space advantage
and Black's Knight on C6 slightly
misplaced it's like a bad kocan because
your C Pawn can't challenge for the
center in any way the Knight on C6
actually would like to have that pawn in
front of it if that pawn could jump
across You' put pressure on White Center
all that being said even though white
has a spatial Advantage there are no
easy targets black is very solid out of
the gates and Fabiano showing that he's
willing to trade off pieces here and I
don't think that Ms is much worse
despite the provocative opening is there
such a thing as a bad caroan Robert
that's my question one of the favorite
openings of a bunch of streamers ly
Rosman you know Dina pound yeah but the
kacan they say in the Queen's Gambit is
all pawns no hope there are no pawns
going on here and I guess there still is
hope you're watching Magnus Carlson play
chess but the point is that you're not
challenging for the center so I feel
like black is not having the best time
with the board it looks like a mix
between a bad carakan but a good french
so this Pawn structure more reminiscent
of a French defense of course with white
seizing more space it's a bit locked at
least black does have the light Square
Bishop outside the pawn chain though and
uh even if it gets traded off these uh
pair of Bishops um yeah at least black
can breathe the S of relief no bad piece
there in the middle game and Fabby
starts with his non-standard sorry
Magnus starts with the non-standard one
Knight to C6 Fabby makes the most
natural moves gaining space in the
center offering a bishop trade to
Black's most active piece and Magnus
goes into a long T does that surprise
you it does um I think two surprises
firstly that Fabiana reacted so quickly
not being surprised by one 196 is
already an achievement but yeah it's a
bit odd because Magnus didn't have too
much choice on that last move he could
have have delayed The Exchange perhaps
um he could have run away maybe pinned
the White Knight but okay Bishop's off
the board now White's Queen on D3 nice
Square for it and Magnus needs to
somehow make sense of his pieces he
needs to decide which side uh which
flank to uh Castle his King on and there
there's no tension right now there are
no pawns staring at one another no Pawn
breaks in the position maybe eventually
we we will see black push that F7 Pawn
now that's the golden Pawn whenever you
push it you have to be very very careful
because it can expose your king but if
he does choose at some moment to play F6
I was about to say he will likely Castle
to the queen side he gets his Queen out
of the way to start maybe we will see
Magnus go in that direction but if I'm
Fabby maybe I play a move like Pawn to
C3 say are you sure you want to Castle
in that direction because then I can
play B4 and start going after the black
king on that flank so this is a very big
moment for Fabby is he actually worried
about Magnus cast and queens side I
think the answer is no but how is he
going to deal with Black's impending
ideas yeah P to C3 he's saying to Magnus
okay please commit your king and I will
go for Robert's plan throwing porns down
the board porn storm there Magnus delays
that decision and I think very wisely
does chip away at the White Center here
fighting against the head of the pawn
chain white One Connect Four white
achieved this Pawn formation so you need
to break it down and uh yeah nice move
this one very much in the balance right
now and uh very much about who Maneuvers
who kind of understands this type of
Pawn structure better and that black
Bishop on f8 the dark SC Bishop it
doesn't really have a nice space to go
to because of wh's Connect Four as you
called it so move it will help that
Bishop get developed which will in turn
help the Knight that's next to it get
developed which in turn will help that
Rook that's in the corner so black is
not been able to develop yet but in the
next few moves will the eval bar is
right there in the center so Magnus gets
away with another dodgy opening it
doesn't matter how dubious it is if the
opponent doesn't know how to capitalize
Magnus has proven time and time again he
knows how to get out unscathed and F6 is
this very thematic French break and when
you've got the French without the light
Squad Bishop for black you've got to be
a happy
uh happy camper with that uh the biggest
problem in Black's position in all these
uh in all these structures is having
that light Squad Bishop that's been
traded off Magnus gets the F6 break in
and it's really all about how quickly he
can develop the kingside
pieces I am hoping for opposite side
castling but I don't believe it will
happen because it just feels like Fabby
will be faster with the attack on that
flank oh you never know it's Magnus
Carson uh he does like to provoke his
opponents from time to time the black
king still needs a few turns to Castle
on the king side where it would like to
be you need to get the black Bishop out
the way the Black Knight out the way
first so it might come down to a matter
of timing but yeah it would take a brave
player as you say Tanya to commit
Black's King on the queen side and we'd
love to see it yeah we would love to see
it oh it's not happening ever definitely
not if you Castle Queens side after this
I don't think madman is a sufficient
term to use against that decision but in
general that pawn on E5 it's both a
great piece because it restricts the
territory that blacks minor pieces can
occupy but it might be an overextended
Pawn so look at that pawn in the center
there for white it doesn't have a pawn
protecting it which means it can be
vulnerable to attack so it's going to be
an interesting battle as we see it
continue from here yeah Magnus just
taking this time out gaining space and
uh covering the B4 Square not allowing
white to push forward because the center
is blocked he does have that luxury of
time so this game now will take a slower
pace and uh I think we'll check back in
a bit later on well this one promises to
be a heated fight between the world
number one and the world number two
Fabby with that last move defending the
E5 Pawn freeing up his own Knight to
perhaps jump forward and while Magnus
has a think we are uh going to move to
the other big clash between Hikaru and
Ali Reza Hikaru did win their first
battle Ali RZA has to win on demand and
the moment the board came up in front of
me I was like one second this has to be
the Roz and then I see white Bishop is
on G2 what just happened in the opening
yeah it looks like a distant relative T
of the royalz of the Italian game uh the
pawn structure in the center very
reminiscent of all of these one E4 E5
openings but yeah that light Square
Bishop does make a bit of an odd
impression um Black's Archer from afar
though Black's d square Bishop on A7 on
a nice long diagonal and Nakamura trying
to clarify the pawn structure on the
queen side but I think this is good
strategy from fuia all the pieces all
pawn still on the board at this early
stage in a must-win situation that's
step one achieved and in the meantime
Nakamura just maneuvering his Knights
over and what one of the biggest
benefits David of the structure that
white has chosen with the faneto bishop
is the Pawn in front of it that Knight
that just land on G6 going nowhere it's
purely a defense of piece while in the
Italian game sometimes that Knight hops
into F4 and cause some problems in fact
with ala had the black pieces against
fabon Carana we saw that knight jump
into the F4 square with a sacrifice
helping to deliver a vicious attack so
right now I feel like Al does have
everything under control it's going to
be a longer battle and as you're
highlighting here the Knight can improve
then that dark score Bishop can develop
I prefer White's chances even though
black has no real weaknesses thus far
yeah it feels like he's got a
full-blooded fight ahead here ala he's
going to plant his Knight on the C4
Square most likely he can at some point
open the center uh or at least block out
this black Dart Square Bishop with a
move like D4 um he's got a bunch of
available plans and I like this kind of
space advantage on the queen side from
experience it's always slightly
uncomfortable knowing what to do with
black do you ever push the pawn to C6
maybe loosening up things a bit more do
you ever get the time to open the center
with D5 Black's Bishops and um they can
be very good but they can also be
slightly stened um right now fua yeah
level on the clock all the pieces on the
board in a must win situation I think
he's achieved anything everything he
could hope for but of course still very
early days and for OA the other good
thing is that the next few moves come
way easier than they do for black right
White's Knight on A3 can be headed to C4
or even to C2 and then the center of the
board to E3 targeting some of the light
squares uh the break that you pointed
out of the dwn moving forward always in
the air uh the one idea that hi aru as
you rightly mentioned David at some
point you want to get that break in with
black as well you want to try to get C6
targeting that overambitious player on
the queen side uh opening up the files
right now development on both sides have
reasons to be I think pleased with the
opening outcome here yeah hiar is not
going to be upset but Ali Raza I think
is actually happy because he at least
has different ideas in the position it
may be symmetrical for now but once
white pushes that pawn in the center I
believe he should push the pawn to D4
right now he is creating some tension on
his own terms it's going to be a long
battle but it's one where ala he can say
if I'm playing the better chess today I
may be able to secure that point because
it's not a simple solution for Hikaru
yeah and Hikaru I mean talking of body
language looks so calm right now it
feels like he's really bounced back
recovered uh he's back in Boss mode uh
after his uh birthday Blues yesterday
and at least he has no weaknesses in
this position he's feeling confident
he's feeling solid and okay this one
will liven up but your move on the board
to Robert D4 white does occupy the
center first on his terms most
importantly and uh some work still to be
done for Nakamura you don't want to sit
passively for too long often you're
looking for ways to concretely break out
trading off a set of Pawns fighting for
the central squares um otherwise you're
just simply cramped and suffering and
for black that pawn push that you were
advocating for Pawn C7 to C6 just trying
to uh put pressure on White's extended
B5 pawn it doesn't really carry a threat
behind it because black doesn't really
want to capture that pawn anyway with
that on A3 sitting there so for black
there are ideas that I can see but I I
don't know the follow-ups exactly and as
I was point out if you take on B5 the
White Knight will take back that's
actually a very good trade a positive
trade for white gaining space so yeah
you see the evaluation bar go very high
up in White's favor with all the
pressure on that flank so I I don't
really see more than one move at a time
for black and I feel like for white
there are several different
options all right well this one the
break has happened D4 on the board so
it's going to be firewor works really
soon and uh we're going to head to
Toronto as we've got James uh joining us
as some of the players are fighting to
make a comeback James can you feel the
heat coming from the playing Arena right
now not only do I see the heat but
they're bringing the heat Tanya David
Robert Bobby chess without H H okay I'm
feeling so great right now guess why I'm
feeling so great guys can anyone tell me
while I'm feeling so great you had a
lovely breakfast there are chess players
that you admire and respect in the play
Hall you had a great workout today man
that's my twin brother Robert S over
there I can hear I had a nice workout
too as well what else what else yeah no
here it is I got you hiar Nakamura
played the Joe Bava jar jar Banks London
he played the London he played the Joe
Bava London and guess what the course
drops tomorrow I don't know if it was
promotion from me Caro I didn't talk to
him maybe he just telepathically because
he is half man half everything else
somehow he just tried to figure it out
but the course drops tomorrow and he
played it and guess what he won how you
think I'm feeling over here in Jo Jo
Bava Joe Bava London land how do you
think we feel it so James you're
basically saying that you're hikaru's
secret second for this
event hey I didn't want to have to say
it David you said it not me buddy okay
you said it not me David come on
breaking news of course I feel great
over here in Toronto he's played it he
won and we see a reverse Jo Bava too
actually in magnus's game you just you
know he felt it and you can play to joa
sometimes both ways that sagorin is can
be played in in reverse and of course
I'm going to go back and look at that
game and see how it's going but we just
got some Jo Bava landish stuff going on
with this chess course Dro in tomorrow
James I'm with you there the openings
have been quite fun and they're using
one of your repertoire but I have a
question about the players mentality and
the attitude after Ali Raza and Wesley
lost did you have a chance to see them
during the break how do you think they
were
feeling yeah you know I didn't see
either one of I think Ali Resa actually
came out I think the way he's handling
games Win lost draw uh it's very high
level I mean he's just you don't see any
really emotion from him he just kind of
it happened you know get get some he
grabbed a snack or two went back to play
and that was it didn't see Wesley on
this one um but I definitely saw Ali RZA
every time in between rounds he just
gets up he walks around he's calm you
can tell he's in good spirit and his
psych I think his Psych is really really
good right
now all right well James uh exciting
exciting jababa London's happening with
the white and the black pieces we will
keep checking in with you and uh yeah
have fun in Toronto and there's a lot of
fun going on on the board as well we are
going to head over to Maxim vasher lra
against wesle so Hikaru alza still
heating up alza has to win on demand and
uh Wesley so needs to do the same to
take it to
playoffs and there the players are Maxim
VRA with the white pieces needing only a
draw to take match Victory and he's got
an end game and I'm kind of liking
White's position already yeah f for
forward the flamboyant Frenchman
throwing the F Pawn to F4 now and I mean
queen off Wesley's quein side pieces as
well a bit asleep here especially that
black Rook on the corner on A8 I think
he's opening it up right at the correct
moment and vasel gra not playing for the
draw he's got the Queens off but this
last move shows he's playing the
position he's playing uh kind of
objective chess and there's some big
threats actually on the board Wesley has
to be really careful to survive let
alone try to win this game very
instructive moment right here because so
many players when all they need is a
draw they make passive moves Quiet Moves
instead of going two squares of the pawn
maybe they would have went one but Maxim
understands the position in all
practical terms calls for this push his
light Square Bishop is slicing across
the board towards the enemy King by
opening up the file his Rook next to his
King is about to see an open Line there
towards that very square and it black
takes on F4 he may be able to push his
Pawn up to E5 go forward and if that
Knight hops the side of the board to H5
I got an extra Pawn go me E6 slams down
the board Rook takes Rook on D1 I'm not
going to take your Rook back at least
not yet I'm first going to take on F7
intermo with Czech the king is forced
only legal move is sliding to the corner
and then after Rook takes Rook uh the
game is completely in White's favor your
pass Pawn the back rank issues it's all
going to lead to a Checkmate and a win
for white yeah beautiful tactics it just
works move by move and I don't think
Wesley saw this coming uh that
instructive moment just to mention again
Robert if white does nothing if white is
too slow if white just kind of takes
time out moves a rook for example this
would allow black to for example trade
off Dart Square Bishops uh get rid of
those pieces B5 might come at the right
moment black has severe counterplay and
long-term Black's actually doing pretty
well but yeah just short-term
deficiencies and F4 takes uh this one
kind of oneoff opportunity and I don't
even see a defense here I think Wesley
has to be really really resourceful a
two-minute think by Wesley so in big
trouble already by move 17 and game one
also f felt like a maxim show and this
one as well we heard it from the players
earlier where they said that Wesley the
toughest toughest player to crack but
today just Maxim has been getting his
kind of positions and I'm just wondering
uh David if it's possible to just do an
action replay that how is it possible in
17 moves Maxim gets this incredible
position out of the opening even though
the Queens are traded off he's the one
who's playing for the initiative and
Wesley in big trouble yeah let's uh go
back and show what has happened this
game as we see Rooks leave the board I
just want to highlight here very tense
position uh but Maxim influenced by the
match situation did just trade off a set
of Pawns in the center looks very
balanced very level but now an active
move Bishop to C4 landing on this
diagonal that Robert highlighted and if
we fast forward it's just about active
play Pawn to A4 clamping down on the
queen side and uh now Landing a bishop
on this beautiful A3 square and it's all
about the power of these Bishops and
this is how we saw Queens leave the
board uh the queens were traded off in
this really convoluted way but a really
accurate way and if we catch up with the
current position Wesley's only defense
now was to tradeoff Rooks parting with
the open file and a backwards knight
move now holding things together but
black is totally stuck black is
paralyzed immobilized you can you cannot
move this Knight otherwise the white
Rook will infiltrate you therefore you
cannot move the bishop which is stuck
defending the Knight therefore you
cannot move the rook in the corner these
three pieces will not play a role in the
next few moves and it's just about
whether Maxim can profit in the meantime
I'm expecting him to push forward you
don't want to allow this black Bishop to
open up on the diagonal but a position
like this is very one-sided and big
Advantage for white big Advantage Maxim
with a promising promising end game and
he needs only a draw to wrap up his
match Wesley in big trouble in this one
we will keep an eye out on this uh but
we have to head back to the Magnus board
because the world number one it looks
like uh has found himself in some
trouble also down on the clock we saw a
very different body langage from Magnus
at the start of the game David this is a
concerned Magnus right now yeah this is
a Magnus who's focusing because he needs
to his back is up against the wall
Fabiano is going for the attack uh White
has actually won a pawn in the position
as well you see a white knight uh near
to the camera here uh deep in enemy
territory on the H7 Square it's grabbed
a pawn simply and magnus's King stuck in
the center uncared uh unfaced undened as
well but uh yeah Magnus in trouble
objectively but he volun arily just
moved his King if we even go back a
single move you can see by the yellow
highlight on the board he played King to
d8 on his own bition and a move ago was
that Force I guess if we just can show
this that there was a huge idea for
White Knight F6 check was the threat so
if you play Knight takes E5 for black I
think white gets away oh I was going to
say I thought white would get away with
it but Knight F6 check oh this is funny
after Knight F6 you can play King to F
E7 and that way if Knight takes Queen
Knight takes Queen you lose your knight
but you gain the White Knight see this
is some really deep stuff of course
Magnus fobby capable of seeing it but
instead Magnus says I don't want a part
of that let me slide my king over so I
guess the tactics can be misleading in
some extent you get afraid of them but
he could have successfully grabbed the
PA in the center again we're going to
Deep dive into our live board but
because this is such a crazy position
David I want you to go back just a
couple of moves from where we left at
last to see how we actually got to this
point uh because is this is getting uh
very intense yeah very intense position
a crazy position and uh we left it just
before this moment black is actually
just brought the uh Bishop out to C5
white has put the Knight on D2 just
developing here Magnus played A4 and
Fabiano said okay I don't care you're
trying to clamp down on my queen side
but I don't trust you I'm playing B4
anyway allowing on passant and this is a
very bad strategic move from Fabiano but
a very good Dynamic move he's activating
his pieces with gain of tempo he gains
time against this bishop and now he
trades off this bishop and uh look at
how the White Knight is about to pounce
on C5 White's gained a bunch of time at
the cost of a couple of weak pawns but
who cares about weak pawns if you're
going for checkmate if you're going on
the attack and uh just beautiful
energetic play now another Knight lands
on the other side of the board Knight to
G5 hitting this square with a knight now
on H7 and uh we see greed being good
knight takes pawn and uh The Rook
defending this is how we got to the
current position a nasty night check
threatened as Robert pointed out and
discovered attack against this
undefended unprotected black Rook black
cannot castle kingside of course it's
illegal right now because the White
Knight covers one of the squares the
king wants to Castle through you cannot
Castle Queen side because there would be
devastating tactics such as Knight to C5
a sacrifice attacking the queen if the
Knight is captured suddenly the B file
is open and first you land a check of
course and this would end in Devastation
this would soon be Checkmate uh so
Magnus he had no other option uh or at
least he felt he had no other option
than King d8 and now Fabian says okay
your King's heading in that direction
I'm going to preempt uh that decision
and play A4 getting ready to attack if
the king continues but he is giving up
this Pawn on E5 so Faby says I don't
need this Pawn in the center of the
board black can take it with Tempo a
shot against the White Queen and I'm
guessing the White Queen would just step
back to a square like E2 and the
knight's in trouble A5 is coming but
this is getting very dynamic in fact
these moves are on the board right now
doesn't black have the better long-term
position because White's queenside pawns
they're split over there so if the
Queens come off the board suddenly black
is much better and the Knight is
attacked and if you go back to the squad
that it came from I think the trick that
you pointed out earlier becomes a
reality and the Knight can jump back to
F6 and The Rook is hanging on h8 you're
going to end up losing material which
means that now Magnus has to retreat
with the Knight defending his Rook on h8
yeah he has to be so careful Magnus
Carson maybe only two moves to survive
in the current position as you say t he
has to choose one of these two squares
uh maybe this one just to defend this
rook in the corner I like this one
better because it also creates a threat
introduces a KN Fork these Knights are
dancing around like nobody's business
it's they're dancing Like It's 1999
Knight F4 threatened with a nasty Fork
uh but who knows who's better at this
point it's chaotic question what are the
chances that if Magnus goes Knight G6 we
see a repetition with Queen G4 Knight E5
Queen E2 Knight G6 oh I think low ODS
but it would be a logical end to the
game Tanya a queen and Knight Tango to
end the end this one I could see that
happening because for Fabiano if he lets
this game continue and he doesn't have
this initiative that he was relying on
we're talking about he is worse longterm
the A4 and C3 Pawns in any endgame they
will be the weakest link on this board
so that repetition is a funny one we
sometimes joke that oh these super GMS
they may just find a wayed to get the
game over with here it comes T maybe
you're the profit after all wow hold
your bre if Magnus goes Knight E5 you do
have a check on G5 is that a dangerous
check I don't think so I think that
after the check you can uh even if
interpose with the queen and and that's
not what Fabby wants I think he is going
to bring his Queen back to E2 Armageddon
perhaps here we come but look at the
clock times Fabiano is four and a half
minutes up right now Armageddon I think
would favor Magnus Magnus earlier this
year in Norway chess won seven
Armageddon in a row on consecutive days
he's the king of Armageddon chess Magnus
I don't think Fabby should repeat but
you know who he didn't play in
Armageddon Fabiana a Carana because
Fabby beat him head-to-head in the
classical game so they did not get that
experience against one another of course
they have played so many times online
here but for Fabby you don't look at
magus's time like oh he's in severe
times he's Magnus Carlson how many times
is he won the world Blitz Championship
how many times has he been the world
champion how many times he won the world
rapid Championship he knows that even
with minimal time on the clock Magnus
can bring it and his position I think is
actually quite in danger of crumbling if
he continues this game and you know who
did win the two armag yesterday it was
Fabiano caruana so big question right
now will Fabby get more ambitious go
ahead with that check on G5 which as
David said can be easily blocked with
the queen coming to E7 and perhaps
doesn't give a white much oh well Fabby
just let go of the clock situation play
the position on the board I don't really
see another good Square for the queen
Retreat to E2 will we see this
repetition happen and Armageddon Moment
of Truth is incoming Fabian is reaching
out for piece plays on he doesn't repeat
the position I think Magnus was hoping
uh maybe even expecting a repetition the
dance between the queen and Knight now
this attack means that the Knight
probably won't choose the square that it
was last on if it goes back to G6 then
white could land a check on G5 gaining
even more time uh where's Magnus going
to plant his Knight he goes back to F7
in said no more checks also Mo most
importantly as Tanya pointed out earlier
defending Black's rook in the corner uh
everything protected now for black and
uh yeah Robert White is kind of a bit
loose on both flanks right now White's
Knight on H7 looks really oddly placed
and those pawns you mentioned on the
queen side longterm
horrible horrible horrible structure
there and that's why he pushed the pawn
because I was going to emphasize the
point that he would have liked to bring
his Rook on A1 towards the center but
that pawn a move ago was under Threat by
both the black queen and the Rook so he
goes A5 does it really carry a big
threat is white really willing to trade
off Rooks White's back rank is actually
quite vulnerable so if that A1 Rook is
traded for the A8 Rook there could be
some back rank Checkmate ideas and you
see the eval bar it is going in magnus'
favor he is down the clock but two
minutes from Magnus is an eternity to me
Fabiano kaana sending a clear message to
Magnus by declining the repetition that
was in his hand that he is playing for
more in this game with the white pieces
he feels he's got the pressure on and
it's understandable you're about four
minutes up on the clock Magnus King not
feeling safe all the tricks and threats
down the H file it is uh incredible to
see Fabby fighting this out for the win
yeah that's why he has so many fans
that's why we all love Fabiano he very
rarely takes quick draws he very rarely
takes the uh peaceful way out let's say
uh he's always up for a fight no matter
what color no matter what opponent and
um normally the chess Gods reward that
type of attitude that type of play but
this exact position is really still wild
and 5 minutes against just under 2
minutes is anyone's game still but no
natural moves for white I'm starting to
worry about that back rank as soon as
you said it Robert I'm seeing all these
tactics that end up in Black's favor
just because the white king is slightly
suffocated behind its own pawns that's
why he slid his King to the side did
Magnus he's saying please take my Pawn
on B6 there may be a back rank check
meting idea and I also want to point out
that look at how uncoordinated
discombobulated Whit's P there's a
knight all the way up there on H7 a rook
down there on H3 then a knight across
the board on B3 and a rook there in the
corner what are these pieces doing
there's no Harmony here and I feel like
in these types of positions it's so easy
to overlook a tactic in the back rank
problems that we just talking about a
takes B6 a swap on a A1 white is not
losing just yet but you could see at
some point that Queen jumping into B5
and then the B1 Square everything is
loose and Magnus under 2 minutes but
looking extremely relaxed right now he
also has these ideas of starting to push
the E Pawn the central pawns up the
board this has happened to me I don't
know how many times and I want to ask
you guys where you have just declined a
repetition declined a draw offer and
then you just start regretting it
immediately yeah normally one of two
things happen either you reject the draw
offer and your opponent suddenly panics
and they think oh no they must be
believing in their position if they're
declining a draw or as you say Tanya you
regret it immediately and suddenly the
opponent's like wait I was happy with a
draw a minute ago but suddenly I want
more and Rook to E1 instead I don't know
Fabiano he's giving up a pawn now uh the
a pawn can it be snapped off I like
Tanya's idea pushing the black pawn to
E5 in the near future um feels like
Magnus is the one with options but still
much much lower on the clock Fabiano is
he just hustling now he's going for it
he's saying if you take my Pawn A5 yes
black gains material but white gains
that C5 score access and Magnus he said
go for it maybe there's Queen up one
square trading off those Queens with of
course be in Black's favor now he's up a
pawn and it's not just any pawn it's an
outside pass Pawn some of the most
dangerous Pawns in end games I'm worried
for FAO right now the time is actually
evening Magnus is gaining some
confidence and he's now gained an extra
pass Pawn after winning that A5 Pawn one
thing's clear that Fabby whatever he
needs to do it has to happen in the
middle game end games are completely B
it for black even if the M for white
even if the material gets level even if
you win that E6 Pawn the A5 Pawn in the
end game will decide the result Fabiano
has to go all out in this middle game
yeah and that's the problem he's got the
C5 Square for his Knight but if the
white knight had landed on C5 black
could have forced a queen exchange
immediately Queen D D6 that's why
Fabiana has to run away and look at that
eval bar it's been shifting shifting and
black simply has an extra Pawn now and
it's that powerful Pawn so strong
against Knights these Rook pawns yeah
it's all going wrong for Fabiana right
now and this queen Retreat it's not a go
in go all out kind of move it does
signal that things have gone wrong for
Fabby they certainly have he is
retreating to stop that runaway passer
he couldn't play his KN jump forward
because a queen trade would have been
forced he can't afford that and it's not
like and I want to give a quick shout
out to lazic against abusar Dennis lazic
up a pawn trying to press in the end
game Magnus he's up a pawn but there's
so many pieces left on this board he
goes E5 the engine reacts at first
saying oh it's going back towards the
middle but then it with more depth it
realizes black is still in charge and
why not push those Pawns in Center
everything in this position is defended
for black every single piece ex save
that Rook on A8 next to the king over
there is defended so he's pushing his
pawns
forward Magnus Carlson up a pawn but
with a minute on the clock Fabiano's
Knights will be jumping in the Queens
side Knight coming on to C5 the kingside
Knight can come to G5 in certain
positions creating some tactical ideas
against that Rook on h8 yes Magnus with
the upper hand but with just a minute on
the clock and all the nights on the
board it's still a game for all three
results yeah still a game and uh great
chess quality here but also great air
quality out there in Toronto uh as we
see just below um just at the bottom of
your screens there uh CO2 levels uh not
ideal but uh everything else looking
perfect great conditions for the players
and that's why they're all bringing the
best chess right now it says air quality
is fair what would be a fair result in
this game Robert well for Fabiano I
think a decisive game would be the fair
result he's the one who chose to play on
I don't know in what direction but when
you make that choice that was a big
moment he could have forced the draw
more or less by repetition he chose to
play on and he may pay the price look at
the clock it's evening up here and
that's really bad news for Fabby because
I feel like magnus's moves are easier to
play Fabby just retreated his Queen
backwards he doesn't have an a natural
followup the knight jump to C5 no longer
comes with a threat against a pawn I
think that Fab's running out of steam
running out of options and well he may
be running out of time yeah he's put the
pressure on his own back back here the
burden is on white to do something
you're simply material down you have no
coordination I think it's the lack of
coordination that's really killing him
here um it's the hope that's killing him
as well that hope of trying to win
trying to play on rejecting that draw I
just don't see any ideas at all black
Central pawns Black's a porn they're
just marching and okay The Rook lands
back where it came from on A1 it was
just here two moves ago indecision from
Fabiano he's changing his mind he's
regretting his uh life choices and I
don't see any reason for Magnus not to
push that pawn push the black a pawn you
can move the black queen as well to B5
to protect it everything's turning it's
just collapsing move by move and the one
hope is still the clock Magnus
uncharacteristically taking a long time
here he's already gain the advantage
he's done the hard work and normally
he's so good at stabilizing okay he
plays one of the best moves clearly uh
Queen to B5 but 30 seconds that was half
his time he spent on that one turn you
give Magnus like one opportunity just
one chance and he's just all over the
the game uh Fabby declining that
repetition Magnus gets the A5 Pawn gets
that E Pawn rolling and now the queen is
coming out and it's him who's putting
pressure on white pieces right now both
players under one minute it's going to
take a miracle for Fabby to survive this
and it's easier for us we have the
evaluation bar we see what the
trajectory of the game is I don't think
Fabby understood uh some of the problems
he would face that their danger would
arise this quickly and you see that
Knight it was protecting The Rook it
needed to be there now it hops towards
the center into is going to jump forward
some more and look at Fabby move after
move he's retreating pieces as Magnus he
presses forward there are no issues in
Black's camp this is looking really
tough for Fabiano the last few moves
Fabby has been making retreating moves
one after the other while all of
magnus's pieces are coming into uh Fabby
Camp here the Aon is going to tie down
that Rook on A1 meanwhile the other Rook
on H3 and the KN on 87 have been stuck
there forever not able to create the
Tactical tricks that Fabby was relying
on and that is desperation yeah
desperation G4 he had to do something
Fabiano he was just stuck you cannot
just wait for your opponent to slowly
improve and kind of get their pieces to
Ideal squares and slowly Crush you uh
now the white king is eternally weak the
whole idea was to kick back the Black
Knights and go for black Central pawns
but this is a beautiful Outpost Black's
Knight on C4 where it's just landed not
just defending the center but supporting
the advance of that a PA again he's just
been playing with offside pieces that
White Knight on H7 it grabbed a but it's
been stuck on that square that useless
Square for 10 15 moves now and there's
not even a check against the black king
it's safely situated on C8 he goes
finally moves one of his Knights now he
can move the other but the knights are
Superfluous here they're stepping on
each other's toes and that a pawn it's
about to become a queen I wonder if
Queen B2 is he there it's played he's
giving up a rook with check in this
position because he will get a new Queen
wow that is beautiful Robert let's just
show that variation if the Queens had
been exchanged then Magnus Carson would
have won on the spot with a beautiful
tactic here Queen to B2 would have
allowed a simple Rook sacrifice this is
a check the king can move actually in
either direction but King to D7 and uh
no way to prevent the pawn from
promoting uh to a queen this would have
been deadly let's catch up with the
current position Queen's still on the
board here of course but look at this
Pawn on A2 it will decide the game
before too long white still dancing
around uh without any purpose as Magnus
tries to land the killer
blow and The Rook comes up just to
protect everything all of magnus's
pieces are doing something here and now
files are opening in front of Fab's King
so he stole a pawn but he opened a file
so the F files open the G file as well
and maybe this Knight on E7 can go oh
Queen B1 instead that is stunning take
my queen and give me a new one please
and on the way give your a rook as well
and Fabby panicking there doesn't make
his move in time just gives up he
resigns what happened there did he run
out of time it looks like his clock is
on zero T he ran out of time but it was
a lost position anyway busted for Fabby
Magnus Carlson he plays he wins and
there he takes his match against the
world number two without needing an
Armageddon what a game from Magnus
Carlson and as you've said on previous
days David when you poke the bear
sometimes you unleash the bear and
Magnus Carlson he leapt all over Fab's
position he takes game two he takes the
match he's perfect three out of three
Magnus Carlson will of course be back on
the bers he will play against Hikaru in
the uping quite a day it is for him
starts with Fabby takes him down and now
he will fight it out against tar
Nakamura and this match is still on as
wesle so is fighting to try and take it
into the Armageddon and the players are
blitzing out their moves David wow
Wesley two pawns up yeah Wesley has
worked his magic here his endgame magic
because last we left it white was in
control White had full domination and
now Wesley simply converting he he's got
two extra pawns he's forced Knights off
the board and then we see a handshake
and that's what happens with Wesley so
he is often criticized for making draws
but he had to win and he gets the job
done Wesley so wins with the black
pieces on demand against Maxim Vash lra
and Toronto continues to be magical for
Wesley so Wesley so now writing down his
Armageddon bid as he makes his comeback
win there both of them take a little bit
of a pause before giving that bid in
this one goes into our magdon we still
have one more game remaining as danis
laic is fighting it at against nbec
Abdus satro but Maxim is not happy he
knew that he had it in his hand
completely in control with the white
pieces but Wesley does Wesley things and
uh Strikes Back it continues to be quite
the run for him yeah quite the run and
just uh yeah instructive endgame play
that's a reason never to panic if you're
uh playing as black in these must-win
situations in the meantime both players
with interest rushing over to the other
game that's still in progress and Dennis
lazovic against Abdu satov also a rook
game and also black with two connected
pass pawns Abdu satov looks like he
should be winning this game oh my gosh
Dennis lazark was up a pawn for the
majority of this game notc could only
draw that was the best bet but no he has
turned it around because he is the most
determined player on the planet he
doesn't care who he's facing and you can
see that look on Den his face he can't
believe what's transpired yeah he kept
pushing and pushing and it took a risk
to many Dennis lazic and this might be
his third unlucky defeat in a match in a
rook end game and uh lessons for the
youngster but Abdu satov can he finish
it off we'd love to get a look at the
clock to get an idea nbak looks like
he's panicking right now he's got the
H&G connected passel but hasn't made
progress on them and there we have it it
is Dennis lawick who's playing on
seconds and NC with enough time on the
clock wow and a drawn position yet again
I think Abdu sattorov was completely
winning but now the black king is stuck
anytime the black king moves it will be
checked by the white Rook or the white
Rook will go behind the G pawn and uh
suddenly black cannot make progress oh
my goodness how instructive is this you
have the wrong Pawn remaining Rook pawns
are really bad in Rook end games without
other material and king of Pawn games
you have to take this A7 Pawn Black's G6
Pawn will come off the board and this is
just a dead draw now he's just repeating
is he even going to try you take A7 G6
and he says no he knows this is uh done
it is a draw Dennis lavic secures a draw
from a lost position but he did have the
upper hand in the beginning yeah I feel
like that's a fair result because with
best play nder Beck was proving he could
make a draw somehow Some Way Dennis lck
pushed too hard because he's showing
that he's also a fighter it's not just
nck and he was losing towards the
stretch down the stretch there he
survives he takes it to Armageddon you
gotta be excited for him it's his first
Armageddon it is uh we've got two
Armageddon on our hand right now with
Dennis lazovic nbec putting in their
bids really exciting stuff and Dennis
just turns around he says no peeking
there well actually make it easier to
peek because we can almost see his bid
uh so for no debeck he's strategizing he
hasn't written anything down yet and for
Dennis well I'm curious just how much
time he'll put on that board yeah and
the players it is nbec who is thinking
more on the bit d is the first one to
write down the time that he's bidding
for nck still very
indecisive yeah both players both fast
both young one of them is going to get
off the scoreboard remember they need to
avoid finishing in the bottom two in the
round robin to stay alive in the
tournament so this next Armageddon for
them is crucial they both need to win
and uh therefore this bid gains in
importance it's so important at this
stage not to go 0 and three because if
not if when one of these players wins
this match suddenly you're right back in
the thick of things have to remind
everybody that while the top two sail
through to the semi-finals three through
six play a survival stage to see which
other two join the already qualified
semi-finalist so if you're one wi match
win out of three now all of a sudden
you're tied with a bunch of people
you're feeling much better about your
chances yeah because the bottom two just
get eliminated It's the End of the Road
in Toronto so it's so important to start
climbing up the leaderboard and Dennis
lazic he's just 17 years old he is the
underdog he's got a cross on his back
and this is his chance to show everyone
that he does belong in Toronto in this
tournament as he will be playing the
armagan against nbec Abdus and it's not
the only one as we see there Maxim V lra
wesle so also go into the Armageddon
meanwhile Magnus Carlson Fabby did have
the opportunity to take it to repetition
but declining that it was all Magnus
Carlson David too many big moments to
pick from what was your take away yeah I
just want to highlight one game we
didn't get to pay too much attention to
and that was Hikaru Nakamura getting his
second win of the day closing out that
match Victory against Alara fuja and he
did it in style Hikaru in really
trademark style here uh it is a chaotic
position Hikaru has the black pieces and
he found the clear-cut way to an
advantage that actually most of us would
find difficult in this position White's
Bishop is attacked it is pinned the
Knight is attacked but Hikaru calmly
just traded off the Queens he knows a
draw is enough but he wanted more and in
this position black currently a piece up
had to decide uh what to do after this
Knight which was attacked jumped forward
to B6 and Hikaru actually caught this
Knight in a net after just moving his
Rook the beautiful move the calm move
Rook to d8 the Knight is trapped on B6
this is beautiful no way to extricate
this piece and as we saw a few moves
later a few moves down the line Rook to
D6 rounded up this night and Hikaru did
not look back in the final position if
we fast forward he actually found a
really beautiful check mate as well uh
in this position the white King has just
moved to H4 and after Knight takes F5
check the king finds itself pinned if it
steps forward this would have ended the
game Bishop E8 Checkmate Hikaru classy
game from start to
finish just amazing stuff by Hikaru
Nakamura a wounded Beast is a dangerous
beast and that's what Hikari showed in
his match today against uh Ali Resa and
of course you got two big armag gens
coming up but before that twitch
subscribers stay with us as Toronto will
be bringing in all the action after this
break uh of round two the armag Gaden
start but right now it's time for the
Champions chestor trivia for our twit
subscribers be the first to tweet the
correct answer and make sure to tag
champ chestor and use the hash CCD
finals for three months of the diamond
membership we'll be back with the armag
EV
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
ah
a
[Music]
chess kit is going live and in person at
the chess kid national festival bring
the whole family meet your favorite
Chess
[Music]
Masters solve
puzzles play kto five
tournaments compete for the chess kid
national championship title and so much
more
this Festival is surely one for the
books from February 16th to 19th 2024 in
Charlotte North Carolina book your seats
now before they're
[Music]
gone Dennis lazovic has been the
youngest contender in division 1 this
season on the Champions chess tour the
now 17-year-old who got his GM title
only last year has proven the age and
experience is no bar to Excellence
lavic won division 2 in the achess rapid
to qualify to division 1 in the Julius
bear generation cup he knocked out both
Wesley so and nbec Abdus satarov on his
way to the losers final eventually
losing a close match with Alara fua this
looks like it suddenly winning black
cannot improve his position white can
meanwhile and simple plan as you say
Tanya the white king will eventually
cross over it's not going to be cut off
forever Dennis lawick takes down Wesley
so Wesley is out of the tournament this
is incredible technique by Dennis Las
it's going to be king versus King in the
end the black rook's going to give up
give itself up for the pond and there it
is Dennis lavic takes down nbec Abdus
satra is on the
board this is oh I'm really happy to see
this that is it unbelievable
unbelievable chess here unfortunately
for danis Las after a fantastic run and
a big fight being so close to wict Tre a
couple of inaccuracies and it is the end
of the road for the 16year old banking
175 points throughout the season has
given lavic a golden ticket to the tour
finals can the teenager known especially
for his strength in online chess cause
more upsets when the 2023 season
concludes over theboard in
Toronto
[Music]
for
[Applause]
he
if you're inspired with all the chess
happening in Toronto find your local
group or take the lead at meetup.com and
grow the community and for now we are
going to Kaa who is on the ground with
the Wesley so and Maxim Vash lra and
they're about to reveal their
bids this is so exciting you guys we are
now going to reveal the Armageddon bids
for Wesley so and Maxim yellow grow I'm
going to count to three and when I hit
three you guys turn your boards and we
will see what's going to happen so one 2
three there it is so Wesley so bids 857
is that 57 Maxim
952 Wesley you go very low here what's
the thought behind that bit probably
made a big mistake I mean most players
bid 9 minutes and 30 seconds so I'm the
first one to bid low so we'll see if it
probably a big mistake but we'll see
we'll play with the black pieces uh any
any thoughts here ma um you know it just
matches from we'll see how it goes you
guys I'll let you go uh I I want to get
I want to get the players to start
beaing low so I started under nine
minutes starting a trend here Wesley
well this is going to be an exciting
game best of luck to both of you I'm
going to let you go prepare thank you
back to you guys wow Wesley so
disappointed with his bed yeah you saw
it on his face at the end there he's
like why did I do that I think it's
because he won with the black pieces in
that second game he's feeling that
Rhythm but he did go under 9 minutes
which over the board is not a lot of
time yeah online which we have seen
throughout this entire season 8 minutes
57 would be a good bid but you saw the
immediate reaction I think uh sometimes
you make a move you realize it's a
blunder that's exactly what happened
with Wesley so's bid there do you think
Wesley just gave too much away with
Maxim he just looked so confident after
seeing that Wesley reaction yeah but as
James calls him Flex Le so I think that
Wesley he could be playing some tricks
himself I know he might be disappointed
but he also could be letting mexim think
that's the case Wesley is a super quick
player he won the Fisher renom World
Championship we know that he has what it
takes to win the global Championship so
don't count Wesley out despite that
reaction I think he has very good
chances here and the so solid Wesley
needs only a draw with the black pieces
it is going to be an exciting one and
that's not the only Armageddon coming up
it is also the two youngsters who will
be taking it to the feier sudden death
not about ABD satov and Dennis lawick
here are their
bids all right we're going to have
another Armageddon bid coming in here so
you guys I'm going to count to three and
when I hit three you guys turn your
boards towards the camera so here we go
one two three let's see the bids so I
have an order back 1058 for black and 10
minutes that means you're going to play
with the black pieces how do you feel
about winning the bid
Dennis I I don't know
we'll see we'll see we'll see and you go
quite High there in orderb so you're
happy with playing with the white pieces
yeah after yesterday uh experience I I I
choose to play with uh with white wow
another exciting armag getd onc coming
up thank you guys for joining in best of
luck back to you
guys wow not a back alluding there to
his Armageddon against Magnus Carlson
which he did lose and he says he's happy
with the white pieces danis lawick 10
minutes that's quite a smart bid by the
17-year-old yeah it seemed like both
players are happy there because for
Dennis he bid low so he wanted black but
not brick said I actually wanted white
heading into this game he gets what he
asked for yeah so hard to pick a
favorite both players they've been kind
of trading blow for blow here and Dennis
lazic if he can maintain the level he's
shown so far today yeah I think he
actually choosing black there will be a
master stroke but the games have ready
to go two Armageddon we've got big
action coming up the players playing
with the white pieces have to win black
gets result odds and it is going to be
handshakes and we will be on the
way here we go it's a porn push it's E4
from Abdu satov and wow G3 which has
really become fashionable today fuja
employing something very similar against
Nakamura earlier in the round and our
friend Daniel nitzki often plays
openings like this online so you know
when you see this opening I think oh
we're playing online then I remember
it's in person and that's a different
feel for these positions you have to
play quickly and without any increment
until move 60 these players have to move
at a lightning Pace especially those
with the black pieces but I think Dennis
has done a good job stabilizing
defending his Center there's no tension
at the moment I think that he's escaped
the opening and he should be on Happy
Feet right now yeah step one when you're
black in an Armageddon is don't react
too slowly to a surprise and clearly he
cannot have predicted this opening I
don't think I've ever seen Abdu satoro
employ this opening before but lavic
yeah reacting instantly and continues to
do so brings this bishop out now after a
trade of nights this is a pin and uh
yeah very solid position for black no
real weaknesses Dennis is the underdog
for nck he has to win this game he's got
to be the one feeling the pressure more
right now the pressure is definitely on
nck because I also feel like going
through those two games Dennis has
played the better between these two and
for nck everyone in this field is
looking at Dennis that's the person that
I have to beat at minimum otherwise
there's no chance for me and is like hey
I'm a really strong Grand Master look at
my results over the board in the world
rapid in Blitz a year ago he plays the
quiet move Rook B8 defending his Pawn
not opening up the full length of that
light Square diagonal the fian ketto
bishop on G2 still has a ways to go I
think he's handled this perfectly thus
far and we'll see how NRE continues to
press yeah he's already eaten into that
time Advantage almost by a minute uh
thator started this game with still a
very level position actually a
relatively well-known type of position
and uh we'll check back in on this one
later but impressive start by lavic as
he lashes out with F5 not just content
to play for a draw playing active uh
objectively strong chess instead all
right this one is going to be a fun fun
battle that's clear from the position
that we have and another fun Armageddon
is on Maxim vasher lra against Wesley so
also a nonstandard outcome from the
opening and it is Maxim who has to win
with the white pieces Wesley needs only
a draw and what do we make of dis
position I haven't seen this before
chaos look at the pawns both sides have
six of them but they're in different
locations black has B7 and C7 pawns
white has those Pawns in the center now
you would think that has to favor the
player with Central pawns we typically
say control the center but black will do
that with his minor pieces also the
white King on G1 without its faneto
Bishop sitting in front of it that can
be dangerous so for those of you
thinking let me take that Knight on C6
with my Bishop ruin Black's Pawn
structure think again you might find
your king in a world of heur yeah let's
just show that Robert because it looks
like strategically you're winning here
this is just a horrible Pawn structure
uh for black but more importantly it's
all about this Square Bishop will park
itself there White's King I mean look at
the white pieces it's basically fish a
random chest and uh uh you don't have
any activity at all yeah simply this
would be disastrous instead he pushes
forward E3 and he's going to try and
build a pawn center it's essentially uh
these middle pawns against the flank
pawns blacks pawns are maybe harder to
push uh personally I prefer White's
chances and still with a six-minute
advantage on the clock looks like a
success for Maxi Vash he's got a complex
position and uh Wesley still needs to
find some stability he moves his Knight
into the center asking for the pawn to
push forward to def4 with gain of time
bit odd that one I must say a bit
mysterious he's cleared his throat he
said come again I think that Wesley
actually might be in some semblance of I
don't want to say pure preparation but
he has understanding of this position
because 95 is not a move you play I feel
like without a natural feel for the
position D4 is automatic but D4 doesn't
actually threaten the Knight on E5
there's a pin so will there he goes he
pushes with C5 exploding that pin push
your Pawn to D5 get a pass Pawn the
center that's great but you also hand me
a pass Pawn along C file and we saw
Maxim in that first game between these
two use a pass C Pawn to his uh success
and we'll see if Wesley can do the same
and I'm just wondering did Maxim forget
about this idea of C5 or that his Queen
was pinned because suddenly you've got
questions to answer you don't want to
create a weakness in the center of the
board with the trades that will happen
on before Maxim does slow down I'm still
thinking about Wesley's reaction at the
start about his bid starting with about
8 and a half minutes but with the draw
odds do you think he's happy with the
last few moves getting C5 in and feeling
more pleased now the Knight is attacked
yeah I think Wesley will be thrilled
that he's trading off pawns at least
it's clearer what black should be doing
now uh the more pawns pieces that
disappear the clearer uh Things become
but yeah Maxim he did react slightly I'm
trying to read maybe too much into the
body language but uh suddenly after C5
was played he's put his hand on his face
definitely a missed one there and Wesley
not actually clarifying the tension in
the center first planting his KN on a
nice Outpost threatening to remove white
dark Square Bishop a very important
piece but not just threatening that if
you slide your Bishop back to the corner
the Knight goes to D2 with a fork of
those two Rooks I have not seen a tactic
like this at this early of a stage but
Knight D2 is threat and I guess Maxim's
allowing can you take on D4 first and
then follow with Knight to D2 looks that
way why not this is a nasty Fork just to
highlight your point there Robert and
you're winning material he plays it this
must have been missed by Vash lra such a
rare pattern and you you see Maxim I
mean he hasn't reacted at all but I do
think he's flum mix he's like what just
happened here and now it's going to be
extra material for black a big blind
spot there a huge Miss Knight D2 coming
in um vesley about to win material
needing only a draw where does Maxim
find his Initiative for this exchange
wow it's crazy the valuation bar still
planted in the middle of the uh in the
center there still says 0.0 level but it
is onus on Maxi Vash gra burdens on him
to create some play he activates his
Rook very clever move and after Knight
takes Rook will he recapture no he hits
the black queen and suddenly a dilemma
for Wesley so what to do with the black
queen because you have to keep your
Bishop protected the black Dart squ
Bishop as well slightly vulnerable and
Black's Knight is trapped you can take
that at will whenever convenient first
though you need to decide what to do
Maxim remember he needs to win he cannot
just repeat with his rook and David that
was such a good option if you go Rook C5
black would have no option but to repeat
in this position but that just works to
Perfection for Wesley so Maxim has to
fight for more which means actually
getting into a worse position right now
the good news for Wesley I will uh
excuse me for maxim I will say the good
news for Wesley he's up material the
good news for maxim is that he has a lot
of pressure at least a lot of pieces
aiming towards that black king he can't
afford to make a draw that's the bad
news but that Bishop unform particular I
if he can aim at that G7 Square another
time he will have some chances and
actually Evo bar still sitting in the
middle over here despite that extra
material for black yeah and uh okay
Maxim needs to find an attack first he
hits that black queen she is rather
awkwardly placed and a bit of indecision
there for the first time worly so and
the queen is dancing around finding a
safe Square for now because she is
stared down by White's light squared
Bishop White's Knight surely is going to
move in the next few turns you cannot
right now because Black's uh Queen is
hitting your dark Square Bishop in the
center the bishop on E5 it's just
hanging in the air for both sides their
pieces right now and a queen A1 for
white that speaks to me throw that lady
in the corner nobody puts baby in the
corner except for maxim when he's aiming
towards the black king on G8 and that
look he plays it it looks really scary
all of a sudden because if I can steal
that pawn in front of your king I may
land a mating attack and if you push
your Pawn to F6 to blunt that diagonal I
might be sacrificing away you see the EV
alar going up and up and I think that
Black's King is just devastated lacking
material in front of it and maybe the
move is something we can work on but
Maxim has the time to culate it Max is
exchange sacrifice I want to call it now
and not a blunder anymore with the way
he's managed to create play against
black king the queen and the bishop
lined up a huge threat on the board
Wesley plays F6 this is a big moment
will we see Maxim go for the line that
you pointed out is he going to sacrifice
more material here it looks so tempting
either way there are options here here
you don't need to sacrifice you can keep
the tension you can Retreat your Bishop
but uh there we go the we get a helping
hand from stockfish from the computer
just below at the bottom of our screens
that pawn to A4 gives white decisive
advantage over plus two that must be
because the black queen she's actually
almost trapped it's the only move that
gives white the advantage everything
else is hovering towards the middle but
A4 the point is to kick the queen away
from its sights of that Bishop on E5
because white would love nothing more
than to move the Knight and expose the
bishop on F1 to that Queen on B5 but
after A4 you force that Queen to an
awkward square and only then will you
move your knight it's such a big
opportunity huge moment here for maxim
vrav he was the first to blunder but
they often say it's not the first
mistake in chess that often tells the
tale it's who makes the last one nicely
put there Robert and for maxim it is the
moment that you want to slow down and
look at your options it is without a
doubt that he's thinking about the
sacrifice on F6 but black queen is
ideally placed to come to defense after
Bishop takes Pawn David I think you can
just recapture the bishop white jumps in
with the queen and Black's Queen will
land on F5 and it just feels that white
will not have enough power play he has
gone for it he's gone for it but as you
say queen to F5 holds everything
together Maxim missed a winning
opportunity the black queen was actually
trapped uh that variation pushing the
pawn to A4 would have won material but
this one instead allows the black queen
to defend and I think he's banking on
Queen takes Pawn here with an ongoing
attack Black's King is naked it's just
forgot to get dressed this morning it
has no shelter around it but black is a
whole Rook up and should survive the
black Bishop for example can come into
C3 and back to defend so ma Maxim here
he's bluffing 5 minutes on the clock for
Wesley so if he finds Bishop to C3 I
think he's got an advantage and he
reached towards a piece there which
piece was he going for he needs to slow
down as well this is a critical moment
he needs to slow down but I'm looking at
his clock now dipping under 5 minutes
until he moved 27 so the decisions don't
look too easy even after Bishop C great
fine great shout out by you David uh
that does shield the black king but
white has three pawns for the sacrificed
Rook there are four pawns on the king
side that Knight can come into F4 Bishop
to D things like that I just feel like
wesy has a few things to figure out and
they're not always going to be that easy
yeah and Robert I'm thinking about a
tournament that you and I called on the
Tata steel chess India where Maxim was
down an entire Rook very reminiscent of
this one against vidit Gujarati and he
just created magic out of nowhere an
attack on his opponent's king and that's
what he's aiming for right now if if
Wesley defends accurately he's winning
but how easy is it to defend accurately
in these kind of positions with four
minutes on the clock and no increment
he's such a good Defender that's the
thing Wesley so Wesley solid and look at
this instantly reacts to a tricky move
Point E4 was a bit of a trap but uh the
queen drops back gaining time bullying
away the White Queen Queen exchange and
it's game over Black's extra Rook will
count suddenly Maxim has to retreat and
as soon as you start retreating you lose
all momentum lose all attack and Black's
Rook is actually going to come to the8
trade-off White active Rook I do fear
there are one or two traps but I do fear
for maxim if Wesley finds an accurate uh
kind of reply on the just the next two
or three moves and in a way there's
something ironic about the fact that the
queen on H6 which looks menacing in most
attacking positions it was actually kind
of Trapped over there and that's why
Maxine played the move E4 so his Queen
could slide back unfortunately if he
does slide back with the queen as you
mentioned the Rook can come into play
start offering some trades and while the
trade is now fully offered that Bishop
on F6 is loose so look at Wesley he's
like I got this you take my Bishop I get
a new Queen thank you that's a good
trade for me wow he literally doesn't
care about material here uh suddenly is
it level material on the board but it's
all about that Aon as you mentioned
Robert that uh potential future Queen
wow such a practical decision there by
Wesley SO trading off giving back some
material but going into a safe end game
and let's not forget Wesley needs only a
draw with no attack against the king
Maxim's only hope is to start pushing
the HB as quickly as he as as he can but
it's also the black a pawn that is about
to advance and it just feels like black
species will be able to stop the H Pawn
that Bishop from A2 can go back to G
defending the 87 Square yeah and we're
going to see this race and okay he drops
back attacking the white Rook instead
the black pent now three squares away
from touchdown uh from promotion okay
what does white do does white try to pin
this bishop he needs to move his Rook
there we go landing on the f file a
threat white wants to play Bishop to C4
next move the black Bishop is pinned so
still not over still all three results
possible and look at Wesley he slides
his King out of that pin now he's ready
to push his pawn and I think what white
is going to have to do is bring the Rook
to a passive square and sitting in front
of the passer and then there's a second
one that black will eventually push I
just think that Wesley has this one
completely under control I'm looking at
the move number 36 and he's got four
minutes on his clock and the position
actually is quite simple for him to play
yeah he's so good at just keeping things
simple keeping control uh kind of
minimizing tactics Wesley so um there
was that mess for a while but sudden
suddenly as soon as he stabilized I mean
it's been straightforward and Rook to E7
that is calm I would have been just
itching to push the pawn throwing it
forward but why calculate when you can
uh stabilize like this and the problem
is Black's King is well within touching
distance of the White H Pawn no other
real counterplay did you see Wesley just
grab another piece he's doing that chess
player thing where you're nervously
fiddling with material but he's also
taking all the material he's up he's
like oh there's that Rook that you don't
have I've got two of those and let me
get a queen while we're at it because
I'm going to get a new one an H6 check
that's a single check his King is safely
tucked away in the corner now no
promotion for white but I do think that
there's one coming soon for black yeah
White's Bishop just unable to join the
action he's basically playing without
that piece and um yeah Simple Plan for
black nothing to do for White and The
Time Advantage slipping away Wesley this
has been a masterclass just this uh kind
of defensive effort from him taking the
sting out of White's White's fun White's
play I wonder if the chess world is made
a mistake we know Magnus Carlson the
best player in the world but maybe
Wesley so in Toronto is the best player
in the world he seems Unstoppable at
this stage and look at mexim going for
tactics and Wesley says I'm not taking
your free pieces I'm just going to push
this Pawn to the other side but Wesley
so continues to thrive in Toronto
there's something about the Canadian Air
that makes him play his best possible
chess and also brings up the combative
nature that we often see dormant in him
he often is a bit more solid but now
he's spectacular
wow look at the tricks from Maxim Vash
lra Bishop to A2 the bishop still
attacked but if you take it there's a
knight Fork White would land a knight on
G6 with a check and probably still
winning for black but uh at least you
have to think twice I think you can do
it I think you can take this bishop he
does it because at the end he's going to
play Bishop to B3 to block The Rook the
oh he goes to F7 I guess it's going to
be winning in this manner as well but he
also for you know to be fany could play
Bishop B3 The Rook could not stop the
pass Pawn Yeah the A2 Pawn is coming up
anyway Wesley so on the brink of victory
of this one still Maxim a very very
tricky player you've got to sort these
last minute problems the bishop is
attack can he actually ignore it can he
go for A2 or it's too dangerous you take
on F7 do you want to get into those
calculations Wesley slowing down he goes
for A2 who needs Bishop when you can get
a new Queen and uh Black's King can
survive all on its own a draw does favor
Wesley as well is he asking for the move
number because it's a 1 second increment
once the players reach move 60 and they
are allowed to ask the Arbiter Wesley
calmly promotes to a queen I don't even
think he needs a move 60 here he's got
three minutes I'm surprised he's asking
about the move number uh even if there
weren't any increment I think he'd be
pretty confident of converting this
advantage and uh yeah what to play Queen
to E5 centralize what could be more
natural as long as you don't walk into
some kind of night Fork which happens
online all the time I think players they
see the board differently when they're
over the board here and he goes Rook E8
so centralization with the Rook instead
of the queen
and here as long as he doesn't blend
into a critical fork or a Checkmate he
can even make a draw at any moment yeah
and I think there was a Checkmate if you
go King to G5 you step it up there is a
pawn check a rook check and so there are
dangers with the rook and Knight and
Maxim continues to fight yeah Knights
are tricky and all the pawns connect
they defend each other o bit of
indecision there he drops his Queen back
and suddenly white can force draw with
just a bunch of Rook checks no way to
evade the Perpetual Che suddenly but
that's good for Wesley and that's the
nature of Armageddon a draw is a win for
black so Wesley doesn't need to end the
game by delivering a Checkmate he can
end the game with the draw and I think
that white you know mexim knows that he
has it but he can't actually go for it
because then he loses the match anyway
Maxim down a hole Queen cannot go for a
draw that is heartbreaking and it almost
feels that Wesley set this position up
he put that Rook to E8 to take away all
the Escape squares of the king inviting
a
pet
oh my goodness oh that would have
blundered and lost he walked into that
night at6 he was about to walk into it
and finds it at the last moment is
Wesley panicking what is happening right
now that was going to be an unbelievable
uncharacteristic blunder from Wesley so
now he can just do the repetition thing
but he almost blundered a KN Fork which
would have dropped his Queen and
dropping the queen for a knight in this
position whites up three pawns that
would have been an immediate win for
maxim he is human he does get nervous
Wesley so maybe he was just teasing his
opponent there he kept his hand on the
piece so the move was not completed he
was able to move it to a different
square if he had let go that would have
changed the game Maxim would have won on
the spot with the night Fork but wow
what a tense moment that was and uh he's
back to having things under control now
he gives a check from behind the white
king though marching up the board look
at the way Maxim just continues to play
this position he's down a queen and he's
just marched up the board with his own
King he's trying to set up some kind of
meeting patterns dreaming for it and
Wesley just panicking he's so nervy
right now yeah but now he can just take
this Knight on F5 so he'll never get
checkmated and he can deliver a ton of
checks with his Queen so I feel like for
Wesley he's about to get checkmated if
that Knight goes to H6 right next to the
king that's actually a checkmating
pattern and he goes and gives a check
with his Queen so a good decision he has
many options here but I would probably
just snag that Knight with my rook and
then just try to make a draw after that
yeah he's still in control just get rid
of that Knight eradicate all Prospect of
a night Fork of a blunder and also so
look at the counter move 60 they do gain
increment he's flexing here Flex liso
with the tactics he thought there was
another night I did because there is a
KN Fork Knight H6 check you might think
oh my gosh Wesley blundered his Rook but
the queen will sacrifice for the Knight
before The Rook wins the free white rook
and if you have to back up if you're
Maxim now it's at long last Wesley is
finally safe and it's the white king
that is going to be hunted down the
queen is coming on to G6 with a check
and another million checks to be
followed uh Wesley so he is very close
to wrapping this one up but just amazing
resistance and play by Max same I never
thought I'd say this but it looks like
even at the very best the top level in
the chess well it's not easy to win a
queen up yeah I mean you can see how
experienced how practical uh Maxim is
with his play uh just posing problems
despite his lack of a queen but this one
ultimately should still be winning for
Wesley with the increment especially and
uh okay it go it goes on goes on David I
just just amazing he can jump in with
the queen a check to F2 but that just
invites White's King forward King G5
there are no checks yeah he's found a
formation a setup he's happy with Wesley
so why break from your comfort zone the
queen back forth back forth it's up to
White the pressure is on white here to
actually do something and it's just
impossible to do so unfortunately no way
forward it is heartbreaking for maxim
who really did try to do everything in
this game with white a must-win game
with white in the Armageddon
and now it is uh that is that looks like
pretty much about to be the end Maxim
continues to fight King to H4 no checks
no checks but I have a feeling someone's
going to blunder I mean we nearly saw it
once right but it feels so difficult for
black to blund this away unless you let
that g Pawn start running up the board
that Queen will always have checks to
deliver against the white king but now
if you check on F2 maybe the King goes
up to G5 and suddenly we're talking
about the makings of a checkmating net I
mean this is just unbelievable Wesley
still has over a minute on the clock and
he's getting increment all of a sudden
but it's just weird that this game
continues in a way that we're talking
about attacking chances for white I've
never seen anything like this I I mean a
knight a couple of pawns for a queen and
Maxim continues to fight he continues to
play on Wesley it just looks like he's
finding trying to find a way to just
finish the game on the spot to try to
find his draw but in the process he's
giving maxing chances chances to improve
the position the pawn has moved up the
board the king is coming in now yeah
this really Rems me of game six of that
world championship match between Carson
and Nishi apart from the fact black has
a rook for one of White's pawns same
material imbalance but uh actually
pieces they do fight and pawns they do
fight quite well against a queen here
White's King is surprisingly safe but
unfortunately no way to get to the black
king and Maxim keeps trying keeps
probing away a check the King s side
steps getting nervous under control now
maybe Rook G8 is the move I would play
because I just want to deliver a
Checkmate from the black side the white
king it's trying to be used as a weapon
with limited material remaining whoa he
gives up his Rook cuz he's going to get
the Knight back that's actually very
clever I thought you know what is Wesley
doing but you could see the O in that
move he grabbed that pawn and slammed it
down ah he knows now he knows
psychologically that's a killer blow a
check the Knight oh he doesn't even Tak
the The Rook wow oh Maxim continues to
play but now with the Rooks on the board
this is over this is over only needing a
draw uh it should be straightforward now
you can just give all the checks in the
world just don't blunder a night Fork
White pawns will never really push
without okay that's that's that dgt
board just doing crazy things to us and
put the queen on a square the Knight
could take it but Wesley he's not going
to blunder the queen Wesley can't
believe that Maxim is still playing that
he hasn't resigned already hey
resignation is a loss getting checkmated
is a loss so why resign you only have a
chance to take this match if you play on
oh my gosh unbelievable play by Maxum
there he is probably going to lose this
game but just full credit to the
Frenchman to fighting this out till the
very end and that is it Wesley saw does
it he finds the draw sacrifices the
queen and takes the match against the
Frenchman what an Armageddon what an
Armageddon so many twists and turns ups
and downs tactics Galore ultimately
Wesley just too solid and uh yeah having
black there he was able to take the arm
again but still one game on going
between Abdu satarov and lazic and
Wesley so checking that one out as well
it's been an end game in that one I've
had my eye on I thought it's been a very
interesting uh situation where no near
has had the advance for a very long time
and now he is up a couple pawns but the
difficulty of this endgame that we see
on screen here is that sometimes there's
actually when you have a bishop pawn and
a rook Pawn with the Rooks on the board
it could still be a draw but not now
because look at this Brilliance from
nbec David you made the video on him he
just is dominant in the end game so
strong in the end game there was a
Checkmate threat there Black's King cut
off another Checkmate threat if the
white Rook ever lands on A8 the problem
is you cannot fend this off you have to
allow a trade of Rooks if the black king
kept Marching In A handshake lavic does
resign Abdu satov too strong in that
Rook end game really really nice
technique there by nbec in the end using
tactics in The Rook Pawn ending to
simplify the position uh and nbec gets
moving on uh the leaderboard right there
with that win against Dennis lavic two
really impressive Armageddon you have to
be heartbroken for Dennis lazic because
in this game he had opportunities to
survive and his three match losses have
all come down to almost individual moves
against Magnus that Rook end game he
slipped up in time travel against Wesley
he blundered upon Pawn in a position
that was quite level and then here
against nck okay it was 60 plus moves
into Armageddon nerves are there but
it's been a case of one move itis for
him in this event wow yeah he's he's
going to learn so much though 17 years
old it's always just these rooking games
just these small details small margins
as you mentioned there Robert and uh he
will bounce back lazic he will he had he
did hold Magnus to a draw as well for
Dennis lazovic he goes down to Abdu
satov in the Armageddon and wesly so
after being disappointed with his own
bid takes it takes it in the armagan
against maxan what an Armageddon that
was aaya is in Toronto with the winner
Wesley
saw Wesley so is here after such a
dramatic armag get on game
congratulations on winning the match
Wesley yeah fish well yeah thinkk God
all winds come from him but I it seems I
I mean the last game went very well but
it seems that based on history I just
can't play chess against
Maxim well I I would disagree I don't
want to play him
again you might have to in the finals
actually yeah I hope I don't face him I
just have such a terrible result against
Maxim like also in the grand chest tour
played and like in Norway he beat me so
it's just very very difficult opponent
I'm just so relieved to get out of it
alive well okay let's dig into the
armagedon here though maybe next time
like if I'm white and I play him I'll
just like make a draw in in five moves
or something you know well so first of
all you were you were regretting your
bid you went under 9 minutes for your
bid so you did have um yeah but it
worked very well because I didn't get
much problems from the opening like I I
was regretting it because I found out
what Maxim did and so I should have bid
n and a half minutes but it worked well
I was a bit surprised because hiar would
bid very low online but here everyone's
biding super high so I'm like really
confused and then let's dig into the
armagedon game as well there were a ton
of Moments One Moment you touched your
queen you were about to move it into a
night Fork you were able to move it back
to a more sensible Square I mean take us
through that
moment that's really crazy uh no
actually I saw the night Fork it's just
you I'm giving him some false
hopes I wanted to move it to H7 but
somehow my hands sto on F7 of course I
saw the night Fork but I was like you
know trolling not trolling I would only
thr Anish but I was like duping Maxim
but I was thinking we to put H7 or C7
but it's
really crazy because I thought I played
really well like I mixed up the opening
so I wasn't sure what was happening at
all like was so compx but I think I
played very well defended that maybe he
had some chances like after I played F6
I was really worried about A4 I wasn't
sure if he saw that maybe doesn't work
I'm not sure but I thought I played
really well and uh just when I was happy
with my position like I got my queen I
realized that I still have to work for
it wow Wesley and it is a great start to
the tournament now for you how are you
feeling perfect start yeah yeah I like
like when I lost the white game against
Maxim I had literally SE hopes to come
back in the match and somehow Miracle so
thank Jesus and uh another match coming
up today round four against Ali Resa
will we see some more Mind Games there
then like you touch the Thon and you
play you play C6 and then you play C5
please do that maybe when he plays E4
I'll go like E6 and then move it to E5
yeah like what Mel T against did against
Bobby Fisher he like he played C6 and
then he went C5 and then he looked at
Bobby just in a great mood here Westley
it's so good to see so what should we
expect from your final match here today
on day two in the finals well hopefully
I can play very well and not lose the
white pieces this time that was a big
that's a big
mistake well congratulations on a great
star Wesley and thank you for joining us
and so good to see you in a great mood
yeah for sure I mean uh probably lose to
Maxim like eight times out of 10 so
today is definitely special good day for
you so far thank you for joining us
Wesley he is just in a great mood
playing some Mind Games here Wesley so
back to you guys wow such a special day
for for Wesley right there mind games
from start to finish and what a time we
live in when the nicest guy on the
circuit starts trolling his opponents
Queen to F7 seeing that FK was never the
plan to fall into the blunder what's
going on is this where we start blaming
Anish giri for getting all the top
players into their Twitter troll senses
but you Wesley it's good to see him that
relax because often times players can
they can just get this pressure on
themselves where they're just not
letting loose at all they feel like they
can't joke around but Wesley he's in
great spirits right now after being
disappointed in his initial bid yeah wow
Wesley so clearly in great spirits great
mood and playing some great chess David
yeah yeah we saw Wesley's Victory there
in the Armageddon earlier but I wanted
to highlight a few key moments in the
other game that we didn't get to follow
too much between the two teenagers the
two youngsters Abdu satarov and Dennis
lazovic and it was a fascinating Rook
end game even end games can be full of
tactics and it was at this moment Abdu
satov pounced with a really nice trick
he played Pawn to E5 check with white
being a pawn up he threw one of the
pawns away because if King takes Pawn
suddenly the king is outside the box and
no way to catch this Runner the the
white a pawn about to become a queen if
the black king tries to chase back it is
just too slow and White's Rook now can
just move out the way the queen will
land next turn instead Black's King did
correctly step to the side but if we
fast forward all the way to the end a
nice couple of tricks to finish this
game white here giving a check forcing
the black king to take this Pawn on A5 a
nice drop back threatening a Checkmate
and when the king marched forward
another Checkmate threat forced
resignation the only way to avoid this
is to March forward with the King but a
rook trade would have ended this battle
and the white seor now free to run
beautiful T tactics beautiful technique
from Abdu satoro who took the win I
think even more impressive than the
technique was the speed with which he
saw it you have made that video on Abdu
satarov and how strong he is in the end
game and he's proving it time and time
again and that game is no exception
there were some mistakes there some
slips it's the nature of Armageddon
where all is on the line but he
continues to impress and now he's on the
scoreboard with a legitimate shot to
make his way to at least the survival
stage it's been such a dramatic day of
Chess and the action continues as we
will be having round four including a
match up between Magnus Carlson and
Hikaru Nakamura coming up and Magnus has
got to be feeling good about his chess
too as Ka caught up with him after his
win against
Fabby here with Magnus cson winning his
match against Fabiano caran first Magnus
little bit of inside information here
you've been watching the Norwegian what
do we call it even soccer qualification
for the first league so um that was was
a lot of fun and you're happy with the
result voring and Oslo team going down
yeah uh I think they will back stronger
but um um yeah it's always fun so happy
that about that happy about your match
win with Fabiano what happened there I
think um I probably well I I decided you
know to play somewhat unusual opening
going for a fight um and and um I mean
he was he was all for it so we had this
really complicated position where I gave
up a pawn initially for um some
positional compensation I suspect that I
was I was worse probably considerably
worse uh for a brief moment and then I
at some point I started to take over um
I was down on time but he didn't really
find the plan and suddenly you know
everything was was working out for me
he's been on fire lately everyone
talking about that so do you get some
extra Joy from winning a match against
him yeah I mean I've played with him
many years so I don't think um I don't
like think he magically gets much better
or much worse in um in a few weeks span
and then hikaro Nakamura it's a big day
for you hikaro Nakamura is coming up in
the next match what can we expect from
that one um I don't know I haven't
thought too much about it yet but um I I
mean I guess he won a fairly convincing
match now so pleas is showing um showing
some signs of improvement thank you for
joining us minus good luck in the next
match thank you all right Magnus cson
getting ready for his match against
Hikaru
Nakamura and there isn't much time to
get ready as in just a few moments we
will have the first moves of this uh of
the next big Clash coming up against
hakaru and this was these are the mat
stats coming in against Fabby a almost a
93% accuracy by Magnus Carlson 90% of
Fabiano Caro what stands out to you in
this one Robert well it's interesting
because there were no blunders but it
was consecutive moves where Fabby went
wrong he didn't drop a queen it wasn't
anything of that sort but he went in One
Direction and then immediately came back
so there was that indecision there
wasn't the cohesiveness of his pieces I
think Magnus played a better overall
match yeah Magnus his strategy was
interesting with white very solid with
black provocative he was basically
saying come at me and when he got his
chance he counterattacked it was really
impressive stuff from Magnus small
margins of at this level of course both
players uh kind of avoiding those big
mistakes but in the end Magnus just too
strong and this next Clash against n
Nakamura I'm expecting more of the same
it's going to be decided by one or two
moves here and there it's about who's
fastest who's strongest who's sharpest
and I cannot wait laru has made a bit of
recovery with that win against ala uh
but David you might need to make a
little bit of recovery as well I saw
your reaction with the whole Norwegian
soccer league Magnus was smiling you
couldn't believe it what happened
where's the Loyalty from Magnus he used
to play for voler chess club and now
he's supporting the fact that varanger
football club have gone down got
relegated it's my team as well I'm
disappointed must say David was a little
heartbroken with that news but it is uh
uh back to chess as the next round four
is about to start and this is where we
are going into the final run of the day
at the top of the leaderboard no
surprises there it is world number one
Magnus with three wins and Wesley so
after a dramatic dramatic Armageddon
against Maxim vasher lra Fabby with two
points there Maxim Hikaru alira and nbec
get up on the leaderboard Dennis yet to
score what can we expect from this final
round of the day coming up you see how
tight the pack is with one point all
those players down there they have a
real shot of Lea frogging others and
heading at min minimum to the survival
stage so Magnus and Wesley they're
pretty much in the clear they know at
minimum to make survival stage they want
to keep on going and get straight
through the semis but for those other
players including Dennis LZ he if he
gets a match Victory here he still has a
shot too yeah I'm expecting players to
fight even harder for their lives now as
you mentioned Rob it's so packed in the
middle I mean that match between Magnus
car and Nakamura it's mouthwatering I'm
hoping for Armageddon somewhere if that
if not in that mat I think elsewhere
we'll see them and that has guaranteed
enjoyment and a lot uh so far in the
event I'm expecting more of the same it
is indeed going to be a lot of exciting
chest coming up it is Magnus taking on
Fabby and not not just that one we've
also got Ali Resa who will be fighting
against Wesley so and this is also a
really really big Clash Wesley looking
Unstoppable right now ala's got to do
his best and we will be back with more
[Music]
chess I'm inational Master Alex banza
and I'll be presenting you silman's
complete end game course from beginner
to master besides what you will see from
Mr Silman I'm going to try to do my best
and share with you some of the insights
that uh I managed to Ste from my coach
trust me you have never really imagined
something like this could be compared to
chess you will notice that the
difficulty of these positions uh will
kind of uh increase exponentially as
long as we uh progress with the series
let the games begin Knight takes on A3
Bishop takes on A3 Knight B5 targeting
your Bishop targeting the pawn you have
to keep the bishop on the diagonal
Knight takes on C3 defending my Pawn
Knight E2 but now after the stunning
Knight to B1 one threatening Pawn to A3
Pawn to C3 threatening B2 threatening A2
there is just no way to stop prove your
end games and start crashing your
opponents with this very evil play
[Music]
style Magnus Carlson was qualified for
this season's first event as the
reigning CCT champion and so he began
his journey with a Target on his back
Unstoppable from the start his dominance
has been Undisputed winning half of the
regular events and sealing his spot in
the tour finals already in the air
things Masters that is beautiful
tactical awareness from Magnus Carlson
he is really earning this Championship
it's over we have a winner Magnus
Carlson takes it he wins the air things
moners the check meeting it's on the
board Simon there we go oh my God and we
have a winner Magnus Carson checkmates
Wesley so and wins the a chess Rock
black queen on the board now is going to
win this game Magnus he's got it he's
got it in the end wow what a fight
though that was amazing over Magnus
Carlson he takes it this is the winner
of the Julius bear generation Cup on his
way Carlson has played some epic matches
and proved his strategic Brilliance in
the Armageddon bidding Armageddon is
coming up and let's reveal the bids from
Hikaru and Magnus look at that Hikaru
has been 8 minutes minutes and 59
seconds beaten by 1 second Magnus
Carlson bidding 8 minutes and 58 seconds
oh no more
checks oh and what's happened there what
happened we see a reaction Magnus
is oh no Magnus Mouse slipped blundering
into that Queen Magnus with his unique
ability to just have all his pieces at
the right squares to execute an attack
and finished the game I don't know how
he does it but it seems to happen time
and time
again when did the pineapple things
start none of you fans get to see this
this was an awesome little streamer
tutorial here for any streamers looking
to improve their
setup this seems like a beautiful place
to set up the headquarters of the most
watched chest streams ever let's go see
how it happens hello hello is hicaro
here wrong
address
[Music]
just
kidding all right we're in we're here
with aaru and there he is there how's it
going Danny I was just in town wow
that's surprising yeah I guess but why
are you at my house I just wanted to see
where the uh where it all goes down yeah
well why not let's take a look at where
the magic happens man this is the uh
where the magic happens I've got my
camera on I've got my whole setup here
of course classic puzzle Rush everything
else I've never SE seen this shelf over
here this has not been opened it's a 4x4
Rubik's Cube I don't know who gifted it
to me I think my mom did or maybe my
brother did years ago um that of course
is a twitch plugin it lights up if you
plug it in I have this little Cube which
actually uh is from December 9th 1993
you can actually see right there so uh
it was actually carved I think by my
biological father and this of course is
my name so pretty cool pretty cool stuff
then of course we got this nice
controller to be used obviously anybody
who streams has to be a gamer can't just
be playing chess that's just not fun
this is ridiculous this shelf of course
is the special one this is the one that
everyone gets to see yes exactly this
has some pretty special stuff first of
all I have this Grand chest tour thing
which I won when I won the Paris
grandchester event in 2018 okay this is
Valen care the the winner this was a
gift from the um from a fan I think
during the Fay candidates in U Madrid
someone bought me this like it's like a
hologram of uh of the stadium the Real
Madrid stadium kind of cool this is from
the uh millionaire chest T 2015 when I
won oh my gosh yeah that's epic that's a
play button for my second Channel more
GM car for 100,000 then otherwise it's
all you got a little green pond here
little chest yes a little chest. comp
Pond that nobody gets to sees it's like
the smallest thing here the out of all
the things kind of kind of random yeah
yeah this was actually my parents bought
this for me in Hawaii I think last year
it's just a nice little Hawaiian
pineapple trinket and this I've never
really used but that actually lights up
if you plug it in it's a big pineapple
when did the pineapple thing start chess
teacher this guy comes with a pineapple
shirt to teach you a me and he says yeah
am a GM in chess I would say go back to
bikini
bottom that started in the middle of
2020 during the pandemic specifically
there was a foron stream on Twitch where
his community made a joke out of me
watching it I was wearing actually this
pineapple shirt that I'm wearing now so
they started making the joke about the
pineapple man and the pine pineapple
house under the sea and it just stuck so
I I keep with it and also even beyond
that I mean pineapple I think is the
main fruit in Hawaii and I've gone there
many many times so we have a chess.com
logo there thank you thank you this is
amazing well and then we've got this
angle here we're not going to show
anything incriminating on screen there's
there's nothing incriminating I mean I
can obviously just show you guys it's
pretty
straightforward yeah so I was going to
like what I do normally is my setup is
pretty straightforward if I'm streaming
on Twitch I'll have the chat basically
popped out right up here I'll just
extend this I have my dashboard via
streamlabs click on recent events
normally I'll have like OBS open as well
so I'll just have like OBS just one
second I have OBS over here and then on
this monitor is where I do it so I guess
just for fun we'll do one do it do one
puzzle Rush see how many I can get let's
go check for the record I am standing in
the fair play cam position exact none of
you fans get to see this except for when
a niche gei inappropriately leaks things
on Twitter we going to talk to you about
that in um but this is where the fair
play cam would sit right here looking at
Hikaru his Mouse his monitor so for
anyone who's ever wondering what it
looks like we got to keep watching him
over here he's crush he's crushing this
puzzle Rush all pretty good actually
there we go I I got a speed up though
I'm a little bit too slow right now
should be checking B be before Tak oops
oh that that was a mouse flip because I
I thought it was going to play another
move in the puzzle oh darn I should have
gotten 54 53 was pretty good though 53
was good yeah that was pretty good I
should have gotten 54 if I played Rook
H1 quicker but it was pretty awesome and
this was an awesome little streamer
tutorial here for any streamers looking
to improve their setup exactly yes
welcome to hicaro world yeah and then I
have my drinks always which everyone
always everyone always sees my my glass
and of course my my coffee mug I i' i' I
rotate a few of these mugs but this is
the one I'm using right now so so
watching this video are lucky they've
seen everything now yeah yeah that's
true yep thanks for having me yeah no
problem I I hope you enjoy the tour run
bye everybody and car Nakamura streaming
cribs I don't know how to unlock door
hold I have to get out of here okay bye
everybody thank you bye
[Music]
bye this is the 1hour chess lesson you
could take to make sure that you have
all the starting tips strategies and
basic understanding to really be
ready by owning the defi
white can do anything that he or she
wants if you don't understand what to do
here you might move the queen to safety
on C6 and immediately lose the first
lady to Bishop to
B5 King on the six Pawn on the 5th is a
winning King and pawn ending where no
matter what black does we are going to
be able to bring a new Queen to the
[Music]
board you can also skip the parts that
maybe you already know how to move the
pieces or the language uh and jump in at
a level that's appropriate to
[Applause]
[Music]
you with chess kids new live classroom
feature coaches can do so much more
easily create or preload games from your
library and invite your class in seconds
teach face Toof face interactive lessons
with without having to leave the site
teaching chess online has never been
[Music]
easier it's round four of the 2023
Champions chess tour in Toronto and it's
the matchup that so many people have had
circled in our round robin stage that's
right you see him squaring off right
there it's AAR Nakamura versus Magnus
Carlson and it's coming up in just a
moment we are here back in the playing
Hall alongside James KY I am Danny
wrench and well let's before we talk
about the big matchup we see the highest
rated player in history already sitting
in his chair behind me let's talk about
what we just saw in round three KY the
result that stuck out to you most that's
a good one there oh definitely that
Armageddon at the end wow that was crazy
with Wesley so just clinching that one
that was very very strong and it was
also very crazy match we all out there
just watching it happen it's crazy it's
funny cuz I agree I think so kind of
stole the drama because he lost the
first game comes back to winning
Armageddon but it's funny hikaro was so
dominant that we didn't even really have
a chance to talk about it right he talk
about a turnaround from a birthday that
didn't go his way yesterday he takes
down Aldi Resa fuja by a score of 2
didn't even need Armageddon to get it
done and uh yeah I mean that I guess it
gets him poised as we head into the next
round abduc Aur off one in Armageddon as
we already saw as well but all right we
uh we want to talk a little we want to
talk now about what that means as far as
where the players sit in terms of
standings you saw the the results you
probably watched it live let's be honest
you've been here all day you've got
nothing better to of course Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so are tied a top the
leaderboard have won all three of their
matches Fabiano now with two after
losing to Magnus Carlson you see Notre
Beck abaturov and Dennis lvic not where
they want to be if we ended the round
robin stage today the two youngest
players would indeed go
home so where does that put us well
we're back here uh in the studio I think
we're we're looking ahead a little bit
to this match up that a lot of people
want to talk about Magnus Carlson andar
Nakamura will be facing off yeah big
dogs going at it I mean of course like
when they're in good form especially
Magnus being in the form that he he's in
Nakamura if it was yesterday it may have
been a different story just birthday not
working out but today's a new day he's
won his match today now he's got to face
Magnus yeah you got to face Magnus I
think if you're hikaro maybe you want
that in terms of building on a match you
just had with fuia right you might as
well give me the biggest dog here while
I'm feeling and see what can happen so I
can't wait to see it of course yesterday
on hikaru's birthday we premiered a
video where we gave Magnus some trivia
on hikaro Nakamura to see how much he
knew a couple weeks earlier we actually
had a video released in terms of how
much Hikaru knew about Magnus and we're
going to replay that one for you right
now what better way to get you excited
about the matchup here then to remind
yourself of a video that broke the
internet a couple weeks ago just how
much does hikaro know about Magnus watch
this and find out let's see you ready
for some Magnus Carl trivia I'll do
pretty badly but sure let's go what is
Magnus Carlson's birthday his birthday
is November I believe November 30th it's
is it 28th or 30th I think it's the 30th
it's November 30th yeah do you know the
year well I'm 87 and he's part yeah he's
part of that next Generation so it
should be 1990 nailed it where was
Magnus Carlson born now this one is
tricky because I I get these cities
confused uh it's it's with a t but the
problem is in my mind I always want to
say it's Tron but that's not the right
one it's uh it's um it's tburg right
it's tburg that's what it is there's a
lot of T tromo but you got a tburg but I
always confus that with Tron actually
there's a picture of like the hospital
room on the Wikipedia page and I thought
it was kind of strange there is it's
like there's a picture of like the
window or the hospital itself and I just
thought it was kind of weird that they
Mor moralize that but anyway what beside
the point all right at what age did
Magnus Carlson become a Grandmaster it's
getting younger that should be it's 13
or 14 I'm pretty sure it was at 13 years
old I don't I don't remember exactly how
many days correct 13 years 148
days what is magnus's favorite opening
move in over theboard games I'm going to
assume it's E4 but I honestly don't know
correct he's played E4 762 times and D4
555 times okay on chess.com
specifically under his Magnus Carlson
account what is magnus's favorite
opening move for online what's his
favorite move uh it's probably not E4
I'm going to guess that it's um let me
think about this I'm going to guess it
is Knight F3 it's E4 it is E4 okay who
did Magnus play in his first fed World
Championship oh this I remember very
well this was actually cuz magnus's rise
was very quick and I I remember this
very well he played I think he played
the World Cup and then he played Iceland
those were two very very critical
moments for him in the World Cup I
remember was very well he played leavon
aronian in 2004 and in trip and I
remember this also because um like I was
playing the first round too against a
Russian player I won in won in like the
first two tiebreak games but magnus's
match against leavon went very deep I
think went to like six games I think in
the tiebreak if I'm not mistaken um and
everyone was watching that match very
closely cuz leavon was considered one of
the big favorites to win the World Cup
so it was against leavon Aron tripley
that was great we thought we were going
to get you with that trick question but
I remember that very well you nailed it
okay what do you have Genny BV gakamsky
buhang XI and Yan shista Duda all have
in common oh they've they've all um I'm
I think it's pretty obvious they've all
beaten Magnus in the World Cup nailed it
okay how many candidates Tournaments has
Magnus Carlson qualified for so it would
have been 9 11 13 so I'm going to guess
it's it's three it's my guess
four 2007 2011
2013 and then eventually 2024 oh so
you're counting this I wasn't sure if
you're counting this one but that's the
part of the trick question right all
right let's see how many tries did it
take for Magnus to win the main event
not the Blitz of Norway chess I feel
like he didn't I feel like the first
time he won was actually a year that I
was not there for some reason so I'm
going to guess that it he played 13 14
15 I'm going to guess that it was the
fourth try of was 2016 very good wow I
was right yeah took his fourth try
okay what happened first you playing a
classical game versus Magnus or him
winning the Norwegian Championship so
that that game and Bill would have been
July of 2005 so I'm going to I'm I'm
going to assume that probably my game
against Magnus happened first correct
okay Magnus recently co-authored a chess
book who did he co-author it with and
what is the title I don't know the title
but it's it's a book with um it's a book
with like David Howell mhm grind like a
Grandmaster grind L Grandmaster okay one
of magnus's first sponsors was a
clothing company what was that company
those are the very early days I remember
chess.com was at that event in New York
City um but yeah the company would be
gar raw nice
which of these has Magnus Carlson won
five of classical World Champs Blitz
World Champs rapid World Champs uh
classical nailed it what is the name of
Magnus Carlson's twitch Channel and do
you know how to pronounce it I mean the
the name is well I mean I I know what
how you spell it I probably mispronounce
but I think it's masinis correct will we
see more from the ma maskinen uh Twitch
in the future well I have to say that
your um pronunciation is a business
small mosan mosis how how I do Mosin
yeah Magnus Carlson trivia
wrapped I obviously mispronounced
the it was really bad it was pretty bad
it was the first time saying it under
pressure but all right Hikaru answered
those questions pretty well under
pressure were you surprised by how much
he knows yeah actually he knew a lot but
I mean I see that with you know Magnus
did the same thing with iaro of like how
just how many questions they knew about
each other man it's really cool they're
uh they their Rivals they're shaking
hands behind us we know it and we're
going to we're going to dive in now to
really just get the hype going right no
more pleasantries no more trivia about
how much we know let's check out this
hype video if the fans were not more
ready could they get more ready check
out this hype video we prepared for this
particular matchup when we knew it would
come before we dive into
predictions Magnus and I have been
around for a long time and I think
Magnus is clearly the best player who's
ever played chessar is obviously one of
the very best players in the world
certainly he has the best results he's
the highest rating in
history what is maybe the most
challenging about his style is his
resilience and also his ability to
calculate his end games are better than
anyone else in the world I don't think
it's even closed he does have a
psychological Edge as well like people
have to do something special to beat him
you know with Magnus will be a fo
thought game from start to
finish that's one of the challenges that
motivates me whenever I play him he is
the world champion he is the best player
in the world and I really do enjoy the
challenge I have beaten Magnus and I
think I have very good chances to win
there may come a time when I don't
consider myself the favorite for a
tournament but that time is left
[Music]
now we are ready we are getting set the
players are getting set and there's no
more waiting it's time for them to throw
down I think they're anxious and want us
out of here so let's just dive into it
KY it's nakam Carlson who you got got to
go my boy Naga all right it's got hearu
I'll say Magnus Carlson then wow this is
a this is one that I think I speak for
every fan in the world that I'm hoping
it goes the distance to Armageddon I'm
going to take Magnus in a closest of
close matches let's move on to MV versus
loic who you got mvl okay MVP MV yeah
we'll agree mvl I'm also going to take
Maxim obviously it's it's a hard one
here but I do agree with Robert's
comments that I feel like lzic is this
close to a breakthrough despite the fact
that I'm taking the Frenchman so all
right next matchup we're moving on
Wesley so Ali RZA fuja who we got here
so is just so solid right now he's
playing good great chest got to go with
so and he's also in such a good mood you
know his face is just a big big smile so
I will say Wesley so I'm also going with
so uh and just double- checking my
prediction I think I took so who did I
take I did take so sorry it's a long day
Levy's glass is getting to me I was
looking at Levy's prediction I think
Levy's prediction was going to be forio
but he's not here by the way we got two
pairs of glasses today in honor of the
second day that Co has defeated Levy
Levy we're waiting for you and the
glasses will continue to mount until
you're here yes but all right we got we
all got Wesley so there I think
unfortunately it might be a tough day
for fuia if that holds up our last
matchup to predict Carana against abduc
Aura defin gotta go with fabbi there big
Fabby gotta go with fobs yeah I will
agree Fabiano car okay it's it's content
ol Resa it's content I feel so bad
what I'm sorry about that we we'll we'll
we'll we'll talk about it all right last
matchup we have here is of duur off
Carana who did you take Fabby fobby I
think I also took Fabby there you go
that's what we got we got the games and
they're ready to start we're going to
throw back to the
studio and uh with it we have Oslo
waiting we have the studio ready to take
the games away let the content roll let
the commentary go Tanya and the guys
take it away
Danny you've got to watch out for your
predictions everyone can hear you at the
back and what's happening that's a lot
of fun and there's more fun coming up on
the chess board as in just a few moments
the players will be off and of course
our Marky match up Magnus Carlson taking
on Hikaru Nakamura that is going to be a
fun battle it's always fun when magaz
and hikaro play I think hikaro is going
to have a little bit more fun now that
he won his match earlier today uh but we
heard from the players themselves they
always have an epic rivalry but hikaro
believes in himself even though Magnus
has to be the favorite every time he
sits down on the board when you're about
to face Magnus beating Ali Resa the kind
of confidence boost you need that's a
decent warm-up I mean you need all the
confidence you can get when you play
these top players in the world and I
mean we've seen their battles throughout
the last year throughout the last two
years and it's always tiny margin so
close I'm expecting an Armageddon and O
I'm expecting a lot of fireworks well
well we have an armagon in this one two
mini rapid Games first it is handshakes
and we're off we're off Magnus pushes a
pawn Hikaru does likewise I believe that
is D4 D5 and uh Queen's Gambit oh a
double Queen's Gambit but Hikaru he's
been doing this right he's been playing
some offbeat openings he against Maxim
vrav chose a Petra variation That You
Don't See very often so hikara is
showing I'm going to think outside the
box hope my opponents can't prepare for
me yeah this one as you mentioned it's
uh a bit rare at the top level it had a
bad reputation years ago um it was
thought that you simply could not play
copy catch chess you could not bring
your queen out uh like this so early but
um yeah in recent times computers make
everything viable and uh black does have
a solid position the idea is just to
eliminate all of the central pawns and
get Symmetry and uh yeah Nakamura
looking confident yeah looking really
conf confident some Mind Games there he
plays Queen T spawn immediately gets up
and leaves the ball
Magnus after a think develops the other
Knight first defending the Central Pawn
he can delay taking it back because the
D4 Pawn is pinned so the knight from B1
can still jump on to C3 targeting that
Queen uh that's out quite early on in
the game yeah it seems like white can
gain another Tempo by playing this
Knight C3 move and I believe that Hikaru
he moves instantly he's analyzed that
with the center the C and D pawns
they're disappearing that maybe this
isn't actually that difficult to play
and perhaps white needs to find a F
string of moves just to keep the
advantage otherwise we may see equality
yeah we see the evaluation bar slightly
on white side but nothing significant
and equality will be the name of the
game if white isn't energetic enough and
I think he's relying on surprise value
hikaro Nakamura again getting up for the
second time within the first minute of
this of this game this Clash wow
impressive stuff he has landed the first
psychological blow against Magnus it
does look like Hikaru Nakamura has
managed to get that surprise in as
Magnus slows down and then Retreats with
the Knight continues to put pressure on
the queen traditional chess wisdom don't
get your queen out early on in the game
because it can be pursued by the pieces
allowing them to develop to the right
squares and we can also see Magnus now
he has to decide where to take out that
light Squad bishop and that's the next
move uh that is coming up yep he puts a
porn on e4 what could be more natural uh
we heard that uh that quiz with Dany and
Hikaru about Magnus he likes to put a PA
on e4 and move one he forgot to do it so
seven later better late than never but
occupying the center bringing the lights
squ Bishop out as you say Tanya and
black has wasted three Tempe with the
queen is Magnus looking amused right now
with what's going on over the board well
Hikaru certainly isn't so I can read his
expression and this could be a bad sign
because sometimes players play these
offbeat openings there it's not well
trod in territory and then when they're
out of preparation things can backfire
and Hikaru I can't tell and I won't try
again because Danny already chastised me
is he thinking looking aside relying on
his preparation or is everything played
from this point on his own over theboard
findings yeah he brings this night out
when in doubt develop a piece um yeah
I'm intrigued I think we need Danny to
tell us what face number this is but
Magnus he will just get developed as
well normally when you're surprised you
don't want to take too many risks there
we go Bishop to E2 he'll get the white
king to safety next turn and um very
stable position for both sides
symmetrical Pawn structure the central
pawns have been traded off the players
continue develop and now a very
symmetrical Bond structure with that
last move black also aiming at
developing the dark Squad Bishop getting
the king to uh the castling safety but
it just feels as if white with that
extra move might be the one who makes
the jump first this Knight can land onto
D5 First Once of course you get your
king to safety and these positions are
not without poison there's always
chances for this position to change from
quiet to Tactical as you said a knight
D5 jump at any moment can be in the
cards for white and for Magnus I these
little decisions that he's made he puts
Bishop on E2 rather than on C4 if this
bishop were on C4 right now it'd be a
more Dynamic aggressive position but I
think he's just going to get his King
castled and then try to figure out the
aftermath because for black where is
that dark score Bishop going these are
not easy questions to answer and I feel
like both players they are now on their
own and it's about who plays the better
chess yeah I'm expecting Magnus to
Castle you don't want to dally with uh
too many tactics uh especially with your
king in the central of the board maybe
he's contemplating whether to put a
bishop on G5 as well trying to eliminate
this defender of the D5 Square then he
has full access to this Outpost in the
center but maybe Hikaru would do the
same maybe bishop out to B4 and yes it
might come at the cost of wrecking your
own Pawn structure but taking this
Knight off the board could be a priority
uh Magnus just weighing up whether to
get tactical whether to get spicy or to
just take the Cal way out and Castle his
King when in doubt I think that should
be the default setting but hararo
looking confidence still Barely Used any
time on the clock
yeah Magnus has some very natural moves
as you see Castle King side first
develop your dark sore Bishop either all
the way to G5 or a little bit more
quietly on E3 Rook to C1 after so you
have these simple straightforward moves
the question really is how big will the
advantage be we see the Evo bar slightly
in White's favor as we all know from
experience that sometimes your slight
Advantage it dissipates in a hurry and
you're left with just pure equality yeah
that's why he's kind of highlighted this
he's identified this Magnus Carson as a
key moment despite how early it is in
the game because he knows he needss to
be accurate to pose any problems
whatsoever to a strong opponent like
Hikaru if he's too slow if he's
lethargic about things then it could
fizzle very quickly he does Castle and
how will Hikaru react I think the speed
of this next move will kind of show us
how confident he is and how deep he is
in his preparation he's already there he
plays Bishop to E6 this shows that he
still is within his preparation uh
because his King remains in the center
he's not castling at least not yet and
here comes Knight D5 so now we're going
to have some fireworks there might be
some pins there will be some options for
both sides but it is getting
spicier as Hikaru frowns looks off to
the side I'm not sure what face number
that one is but he's surprised confused
by magnus's
choice wow this one is heating up with a
night jump Magnus getting that one in
and now we are going to see some
structural changes of course we will
come back to our Marque match up as we
see head in hand Hikaru has his first
think but another ball where think is
perhaps required is Fabiana Carana with
the black pieces taking on nbec Abdu
satov and my guess David would be that
this came out of uh the Spanish and that
strange Rook that was on A2 perhaps the
light Squad Bishops got traded there
maybe we can back up take it from the
start and then do a deep dive into this
position yeah you're right uh you called
it correctly that Tanya the opening was
a Roy Lopez or a Spanish and it did
begin with E4 E5 and uh this variation
uh with the bishop coming out and
getting kicked back and uh let's just
fast forward to one of the critical
moments you mentioned the white Rook on
A2 it became a bit of an odd piece in
this position after black developed to
E6 still wellknown well-known territory
well-known opening Theory but now after
Bishop takes Bishop the rook recaptures
and it is left on a vulnerable square
and we'll see how that plays into uh
proceedings later on the knights simply
retreated and black broke out with D5
and this isn't the most uh kind of
popular move as far as I'm aware I
haven't looked at this for a while but
uh it did turn out well for Fabiano
because suddenly the White Knight gets
kicked around look at these black pawns
really strong in the center and not just
that but after the Knight Retreats Queen
to D5 a Tempo gaining move hitting the
Rook defending the center to me in the
current position if we catch up Fabiano
looks in control simply with black
already I would say Advantage black just
due to how much space you have how
strong these pawns are but look at not
Beck's last move Rook coming to C1 he
says your Center looks very good but I'm
about to strike with C4 Dynamite move
myself hitting your queen gaining some
space and opening up the queen side here
the E5 Pawn is a bit tender sometimes in
these positions your best option would
be can I actually push my Pawn backwards
one square put it back to F6 to protect
that pawn E5 a Pawn's best friend is
another Pawn we love our Pawn chains but
I think that right now it is n re who
trying to break free from the chains and
throw those pawns C4 and cause chaos
yeah I'm still liking Black's position
here it just look looks like there's so
much Harmony in Black species you
centralized everything gain space in the
center I hear you Robert C4 is always in
the air creating problems for black but
just with the peace activity even a move
like retreating with the bishop to d8
and I'm scared how the EV valbar might
react to it but Bishop d8 it doesn't
love it but it just feels as if you've
got your own pawns uh moving forward and
the Rooks are nicely placed in the
central lines yeah I think black is uh
at some uh well urgency needs to put put
the king in the corner as well there
might be some tactics I'm liking
Robert's idea for example uh if Bishop
d8 Pawn to C4 um of course black
shouldn't get too greedy here but if you
do take this Pawn for a second time
suddenly Queen to B3 would be a deadly
pin on the diagonal not just that but
Black's Knights are so loose along the C
file that something will drop off for
example if you drop back a simple Queen
trade and the Knight on C6 is undefended
so there are some tactics um I like your
idea Tanya moving the bishop out of the
way protecting this Pawn with your Rook
but uh maybe first you Shuffle the king
into the corner or
uh or other moves dealing with this
semi- threat of Pawn to C4 would love to
get E4 in but it just looks like white
might be the one getting C4 in before
black gets that Central break and Fabby
he slows down the clocks are leveling
out this whole Rook maneuver that we saw
by nbec first The Rook goes to A2
recaptures the bishop then comes back to
A1 then to C1 with this idea that's some
high class chess right there yeah it's
rerouting a piece it may take some time
but he understands that black cannot
crash through the center yet and I just
want to note that Notre he does pretty
well against Fabiano especially online
not he qualified for these finals by
winning the chess kid Cup who did he
beat in the final none other than
Fabiano Carana so their head-to-head is
quite combative these are two of the
most determined fighting players in the
entire chess circuit but not debeck
despite being just a teenager he's shown
that he can keep Pace with some of the
best Veterans of the game yeah and uh I
do actually like his approach despite
the fact originally kind of optically it
looks great for black white is provoking
the opponent forward he's trying to proe
for weaknesses later on Fabby maybe
overextended and Fighting Chess you
mentioned it Robert um Abdu satov just
always fighting always provoking um also
did he uh did he take down Fabby when he
won the 2021 World Championship um
either way he's got yeah just this
fantastic style and um so great to watch
this one is guaranteed to be a proper
fight right now and uh okay he's in the
tank Fabiano he realizes now that C4
massive massive idea hard to stop and
it's so strange because visually this
position looks like a beautiful outcome
uh for the black pieces out of the
Spanish right you've got so much control
and peace Harmony but very often it's so
Concrete in chess and now with modern
chess especially C4 is a big threat
using the tactics and fabby's taken
about what it's been a almost a 4 minute
think looks can be deceiving he has all
of these pawns centralized on his own
fourth the fifth rank of the board but
then when you push your Pawn sometimes
they go a little bit too far they're
overextended and it's easier for your
opponent to land a counter punch and
that C4 move is really available because
black has thrown that pawn up to B5 the
E5 Pawn needs the Queen's defense it
just seems like white is about to have
some fun it's a bit of retaliation but
it's coming at the exact needed moment
yeah and uh Fabiano continues to freeze
four and a half minutes now he needs to
speed up it's one of those positions
where actually the critical moments will
also be ahead so uh at some point you
need to decide just drop the queen back
drop your knight into D4 move the black
bishop move the king into the corner
something but you need to uh decide fast
make a move Fabby this is just way too
long and what you just pointed out is
opening success by white making Fabby
think at this moment when many critical
decisions lie ahead of him it's uh it is
success to get an opponent like Fabby
who's so well prepared to let him burn
the clock right now and I'm getting
worried he's touching the five he's
crossed five minutes just over this
position one can feel that Fab is
feeling the pressure on this one another
player and he finally does make a
decision it's not the king uh move to h8
but another quiet move to H6 we will
come back to uh the nbec board but
another player who is perhaps feeling a
little bit of uh the pressure and the
heat Wesley so take a look at that ala
with the black pieces he's going all out
he's got his pieces forward but is this
Brave or stupid what is happening here
my French is far from perfect but I'm
getting some Deja Vu here from the
French number one alira fua he's thrown
a knight on F4 he completely blitzed
Fabiano car's queen king side yesterday
and that was a piece sacrifice nothing
has been sacrificed thus far Black's
pieces look like they are storming
around the white king in particular that
pawn on G5 which can be joined by
another Pawn if the H Pawn decides to go
up the board but this is again one of
these positions where you have to uh be
super precise because one inaccurate
move suddenly white regains his footing
and then it's black who might be on the
back foot yeah this King could be very
just very very weak uh if you aren't
able to play energetically if for
example this beautiful Knight on F4 gets
straighted off just as I say the king
moves I'm expecting the black queen to
land on this uh promising this flexible
F6 square and your idea Robert I think
he might even back it up by a rook
sliding uh and some point later on and
white needs counterplay white is really
stuck this bishop on G3 is especially
bad if you have a take this Knight I
think black could actually take either
way but uh even with a G pawn and later
you have the semi-open G file to play
with and white has to contort uh rotate
the Knight back to E1 this is odd odd
stuff I was going to say you should
break in the center you should push a
pawn to D4 but where is this Knight
going this is mysterious I don't care
what the Valar ISS I'm loving what alza
has done here with the black pieces you
know it's his King on the king side but
he's gone 86 G5 he's making his
intentions very clear he's playing for
the attack the squad you're pointing out
for the queen queen coming to F6 H5 H4
ideas opening of the hline the Knight is
already on F4 um Wesley cannot be too
happy and it is good advice there David
that when your opponent is playing on
the flank with that idea you want to try
to open the center it looks like that is
the only break that Wesley has I'm
taking black in this one well it's also
break that Ali Raza has he brought his
King up he escapes a pin that pawn on F7
was previously pinned now he can thrust
his own Pawn forward opening up The Rook
staring down towards the white king so
this is going to be a messy situation
Wesley he typically prefers solid play
we saw what happened in game one against
Maxim vashir lra Maxim brought the
action to him Wesley was not able to
withstand the pressure Aliza he's
playing in a similar way yeah messy and
that suits Alisa's style Wesley wants to
control of course Wesley can do anything
he navigated that Armageddon very well
against Maxim Vash de gra earlier today
but um yeah this exact position I think
he won't won't be feeling too
comfortable right now I think we're
going to see H5 on the board um it feels
like such a natural followup and so much
uh up Ali Resa style of play and it is
on the board really nice plan there H4
you really want to force White's Bishop
to take the decision to trade on F4 so
that the G Line opens up uh vesley he
can't be too happy with the way things
have turned out with the white pieces
here yeah H4 for the score it's coming
and Wesley needs to do something he
pushes a pawn to F3 kicking back Black's
Bishop at least some breathing space for
his own Bishop that d s Bishop on G3 but
yeah these exchanges these potential
traits of minor pieces do not help white
whatsoever totally different position
but it sort of reminds me of his game
against Dennis lavic from yesterday
where Wesley he ended up winning that
game but early on it looked like Dennis
was having all the fun with pressure
down the king side maybe Wesley saying I
have the pair of Bishops for now one may
get traded I still have one remaining
this Knight on C2 after Rook E1 it may
go to E3 and watch out for Knight F5 or
D5 so there are some holes in Black's
position and Wesley he is down a little
bit of time but he's starting to speed
up because he's found himself a plan I
just loved Wesley's interview earlier it
was just the Joy on his face just the
the Innocence the way he's loving chess
right now it's just seems to have freed
him up to place just fantastic chess and
he's playing fantastic chess here
despite the fact he's on the defensive
he's playing calmly he's just retreating
his Rook creating squares for his KN
everything's flowing and this is the Wes
Wesley we know and love yeah three match
victories Wesley's got reasons to be
pleased with his play so far in Toronto
perhaps becoming his favorite City to
play chess in so rookie one he's trying
to activate his Knight Ali RZA making
his intentions very clear he wants to go
for uh the white king if black was to
push that pawn forward Bishop retreating
back to F2 trying to keep the files
closed on the king side I think you can
you can get away with it retreating
isn't always a bad thing to do um you
know taking on F4 it looks like it's
playing into Black's hand G takes F4
opening up that g file it just seems too
risky so that was why Wesley played
Knight back to E1 Pawn F3 he wanted to
vacate that square and that diagonal so
the bishop could Retreat and yeah he
then can control even more squares when
the Knight comes in E3 you're you're
just completely handling white the light
squares over there on the center on the
king side yeah I don't know if you
should push for fuia but if not that
then what else suddenly uh the move
moves that were so natural so obvious so
tempting uh he's going to be pausing
he's he's certainly hesitating right now
I'm not sure how to build up the
question is whether to take this bishop
it looks like you ruin White's Pawn
structure but then Robert's Point these
light squares suddenly juicy White's
Knight is coming in yes you can put a
Black Knight on E7 passively to kind of
block the white Knight's advance but I'm
not sure that's something you really
want to rush into and uh therefore fuja
pausing for the first time in a long
time since we actually jumped into this
game and uh yeah the more I look at it
the more I think this is just chances
for both sides it's becoming a position
that first looked Dynamic now is looking
strategic which is Wesley's Forte so
Wesley is handling this very well no
surprise given his three out of three
start he is playing Amazing chess in
Toronto year after year this seems to be
his City his type of tournament and in
match play in only two games you can't
afford to make any misstep especially in
a position like this yeah and I think uh
that's the whole point Wesley needs to
be so precise here it's hard to bet
against against Wesley these days with
the chest that he's showing but again I
really like what Ali RZA has done his uh
his creativity attack I would take black
here he's managed to make his chances on
the board is the kind of position he
likes to play but he's going down on the
clock right now so Ali Rea we are
waiting for uh his uh decision playing
aggressive playing Brave right
now what are you what are you predicting
in this one do you think this matchup
given their Clash of styles there's a
chance this goes into Armageddon or do
you think it will be decided with
decisive games in the
rapid tough to predict I'm going to say
it's going to be decis uh decisive
actually even just this game just
because the way fua has started the way
he's kind of set out his stall and said
I'm going to attack uh no real way back
from there but um you never know it's
early days and they're both extremely
strong of course both on form today yeah
well while Ali rosar has a think on how
to continue this attack that he's
created and he just as I was about to
say he does make a move a H4 is on the
board we will jump in we saw Wesley move
back with the bishop so the G file
remains blocked in that one let's head
back to our Mary match up Magnus Carlson
also reaching out to make a move on his
board I see that's a retreating one
Hikaru with the T here he was the one
who surprised Magnus early on in the
opening what is uh the current position
uh David well first of all I'm looking
at magnus' pieces and nearly none of
them have crossed his uh first rank it
look again it looks like Fisher random
chess and wow itics from Hikaru not
winning nothing too spectacular just a
double attack on the White Queen White
now has to move uh her majesty there
Black's Rook on the defile attacking the
White Queen Black's Knight attacking the
queen and uh I think the idea from
Hikaru is just very simply to trade off
White's light squared Bishop o the board
tested us Tas us there the queen did
land on a safe Square on F3 and Knight
takes Bishop would guide the game
towards equality just too sterile here
total symmetry I typically don't like
calling a game a draw you say level even
just one of those words this looks very
very draw there are only five pawns per
side equal material no weaknesses to
speak of so Magnus he looks displeased
it was a shady opening from hikaro
perhaps one he won't use again just
because if your opponent's ready for it
they may be able to take advantage but
this is completely equal there's really
not much to speak of about the position
itself it's just completely dead yeah a
picture Paints the words and look at
Magnus on the camera there does not look
too excited too interested in this
position um he knows this one with high
likelihood is going to be a draw uh
Hikaru just great opening preparation
he's neutralized Magnus effortlessly
here yeah and we saw this same narrative
in magnus's game against Fabby in round
three starting with the white pieces
Magnus really did not get anything out
of the opening Fabby neutralized all
pressure and it looks like aaru's
managed to do that as well getting that
early early early surprise in with his
opening approach it has worked to
Perfection uh and we will move on to the
world number two from World number one
to world number two natural progression
there Fabby starts with the black pieces
wow that looks like deep deep pressure
on the black king especially with that
last move that has arri that has just
arrived on the board H5 shattering down
Black's kingside Pawn structure look at
the eval bar is Fab in big trouble yeah
look at the death St that Abdu satoro
was giving Fabiano a minute a moment ago
as well he's actually down a pawn here
with white but it is that pressure on
the black king black is simply
overextended Black's pieces are loose
Black's Queen slightly vulnerable
Black's Knight on C6 undefended Black's
Rooks don't coordinate and yeah those
kingside pawns he's allowing them to be
fractured kind of broken here but he's
just trying to defend with his Rooks
he's got double the amount of time on
the clock as well Robert yeah the second
game in a row where we look at Fabiano's
pieces and they're all scattered across
the board which is not typical of a
Fabiano Carana game game and wow that is
a very surprising move to me from n Beck
abatar who is super confident playing
quickly but trading Queens when the
black king looks like it's in danger
that may let Faby off the hook white
remains with the advantage it's easier
to play but black is a pawn ahead in the
current position so if one Pawn Falls
maybe even two it might only be a one
Pawn lead for white and that gives
drawing chances yeah he's banking on a
favorable end game here but maybe he
should have been playing for checkmate
or playing for uh kind of higher
purposes there let's just show what's
likely to happen this last Bishop
Retreat just to highlight some
Alternatives he could have maybe moved
the queen out the way for example lining
up some discovered attacks against the
black queen but now the Queens have been
traded Bishop to A1 forces that to
happen and now the pressure on this
undefended Knight that we mentioned
earlier does force Fabiano to give up
this E5 Pawn no way to defend it if you
move the Knight backwards this would be
disastrous white could for example take
on E5 with a knight maybe even with the
bishop and Black's position collapses
attack against The Rook against the
bishop and the C7 Pawn falling Fabiano
drops his Knight into D4 giving up the
pawn on his terms giving back the pawn I
should say and uh this position still
Advantage white look at those weak pawns
on the queen side and on the king side
too in a moment actually all four pawns
for black will be isolated and uh big
Advantage but not much material
remaining that is the one major downside
is now Fab does to worry about his King
getting checkmated and if he can keep
initiating some trades that does
increase his chances to survive
yeah so Fabiano maybe breathing a s
relief but not out of the woods yet
objectively still a Advantage for Abdu
sator he just needs to make the time
Advantage count now Rook F7 I would just
take that pawn take on G6 break the
structure and then think later it does
look very very pleasant for white any
player would prefer to have the white
pieces in this position but I just feel
like with for Fabiano it was the right
thing to do at that moment give back the
pawn in the center now try to trade as
much as possible and that could put some
fear into not back who knows he's better
he like can I really keep trading even
if I win a pawn a rook endgame a pawn up
that may not be winning so I'm liking
the position I love the way that nck
plays chess but it's critical for him to
keep it up right now keep that pressure
going against Fabby he's got a great
position but will it be enough and we
just as we're moving away we saw a trade
that Robert takes you by surprise some
really surprising decisions there by nck
in a better position trading off the
queen trading off that strong Bishop
when there was no rush to do that we
will check in and see on that end game
but there is no end game on this one as
uh the attack does continue and alir are
asking more questions forcing Wesley now
to take a decision you really don't want
to fix the center with white right if
you go D5 you give black a free hand on
the king's side to continue with the
attack but is there an alternative well
I'm also knowing the A5 Pawn that one is
loose so for Wesley he can play D5 or
Pawn takes C5 first which is what I
would go for and then maybe just steal
the A5 Pawn black is hoping for
counterplay thanks to some control the
light squares the dark Square Bishop for
white oh and we got a queen sack for two
Rooks the engine saying that maybe black
is doing okay here David take it away
what's going on yeah it's a hard one to
evaluate two Rooks do mathematically
outow a queen and if white gets time to
bring the second Rook into the game kind
of team up with the two Rooks white of
course will be better that's what
Wesley's banking on but maybe there's an
attack some counterplay against the
white king later on I'm looking for
example if black just waits as soon as
the white Rook moves I'm looking at
checks there might be this nasty check
on E2 and uh the Black Knight Will plant
itself on a nice blocking Square on D4
watch out for H3 coming watch out for G4
or F5 blowing open the king side later
instead Alara plays Queen to B6 a double
attack another one maybe wesle had
missed Robert I just want to backtrack
and ask what was the downside why could
he not have just snagged the pawn for
free it looks like he could have taken
that pawn without really huge risk maybe
he was worried about some of the Knight
D3 ideas of something of that nature but
that's really a one move threat and it
actually doesn't threaten anything
because the Rook on d8 is also loose so
it's a a bit of a strange decision
coming from westle so who worked his way
out of some initial danger into a
positionally healthy position and now
he's like oh wait a second tactics once
more my rook's hanging my pawns hanging
Knight E2 check at some moment Pawn to
H3 for black all these different ideas
are in the air and I'm starting to like
other raz's position more and more yeah
and with giving up that Queen for two
Rooks the last thing you want to do is
get into a passive position trying to
defend the B2 Pawn you don't want to
come back with a rook on d8 to uh D2 it
just allows black extra tempos to get
the queen in and Meanwhile we're getting
our first result Magnus Carlson Hikaru
Nakamura as predicted ended in a draw uh
this game just heating up uh Wesley
attacks the Knight Ali Resa steps back
with the King wow this one is definitely
getting spicy and I want to give a shout
out to Dennis lazic who secured a draw
with the black pieces against Maxim
vasher lra so Dennis continues to
impress I know he's got zero match
points on the scoreboard but he has held
his own against some of the best players
in the world 17-year-old continues to
impress yeah he hasn't lost uh two Z to
anyone so far he's been very close just
small margins uh great result there with
black I mean against vashy L gra that's
a fantastic result he's one of the best
with white these days and G3 provokes a
decision from the Black Knight or do you
Counterattack do you hit the white Rook
I mean I'm looking where to jump I want
to plant that black knight into the D4
square but there will be tactics if you
Retreat and uh I think actually a bit of
a trap from Wesley so he's relying on a
trick uh the most natural move to me
would be to drop the Knight back and to
bring it into D4 but Rook takes E7 would
set up a nasty night Fork that's been
the theme of the day all these nasty
night forks and this is a royal Fork of
course of king and queen Queen so uh
what else to do uh maybe even in this
position there are tactics after Rook
takes C7 I realized Knight to D4 would
actually threaten the F3 pawn and this
is one to calculate but if in doubt
maybe you flick in a check and take this
bishop and uh the game goes on that's
what he's going for these tricky tricky
Knights and uh what to do now you can
take this bishop take this pawn it is
chaotic well the chaos in this one
continues we will check in uh what
happens there in just a moment but first
let's take a look at this one because
Fabby is in trouble as NC's Rooks are
sweeping the pawns that black has on the
sixth rank but Fabby going for
counterplay on the G line is this closer
to a NB win or a draw look at the clock
Fabiano under 10 seconds with that in
mind I think it's going to be a win for
white two protected uh pass pawns as
well connected pass pawns on the queen
side if somehow he can trade off one at
a Rooks it's game over that's Abdu
soro's goal right now he can take
another Pawn on H5 two pawns up and Fab
is trying to get a Counterattack he's
using his Rook that's in front of the
white king trying to bring the other
Rook down but the problem is Fab's own
King is very exposed so there could be a
latter Checkmate where the Rook on A6
cuts that King off you see it won't get
access to go up the board and so if the
second Rook slides on over to the queen
side maybe we will see a latter checkm
so I don't believe in Fab's chances here
and it's going to be a shame for him but
noar backck he's earned this point if
he's able to get it yeah fantastic play
so far by nbec can he put the Finish in
touches to this end game and he goes
with the idea that Robert you were
pointing out sliding The Rook to C5 so
that if the black Rook jumps in there's
a check on C7 followed by a mate on A8
so Fabby forced to keep one of his Rooks
on the seventh rank defense let's just
show that idea if Fabiano had brought
his Rook down it looks like severe
counterplay but a check and this is the
Checkmate that everyone needs to know uh
Rook end game 101 this is a checkmating
pattern the latter ladder Checkmate even
and the lawn mower Checkmate sometimes
but Fabiano he's just stuck what to do
white can simply just push these pawns
forward now this black Rook is stuck
defending the seventh rank zero
counterplay this should be a win and
ample time 3 minutes left AB satov big
favorite to take this Fabby with just 7
seconds on the clock in a position that
looks close to losing right now it's the
only thing that he can rely on is trying
to get counterplay with those two Rooks
somehow getting them either to double up
on the G file or The Rook jumping onto
the second rank is there any hope for
Fabby to put pressure on that G2 Pawn
here I don't think there's any realistic
hope as long as Abdu satov doesn't panic
um he's trying to force the issue
potentially but okay he drops back with
his Rook still same idea persists you
cannot move the Rook from D7 but the
white king does get checked around a bit
and uh still yet to decide upon a
winning plan clever play by Fabiano here
because he wants to deliver a check but
even better play from nybeck a check the
King goes up you are allowing that
ladder Checkmate but now with the King
sliding over to H7 there won't be the
same ladder checkmate because the black
Rook can backtrack and stop it but two
extra pawns or two extra pawns but he
does have a threat he wants to either
give a check from the second rank or
double up on the G file so putting
pressure on G2 and nag doesn't have the
time just yet to start advancing the
queenside pawns yeah not quite yet but
if he removes the black F Pawn from the
board then he can always uh bully the
bully kowana here with the the uh
thought of a trade of one set of Rooks
if one set of Rooks comes off it's just
game over Black's King is so far away
the white Pawns will simply advance but
okay counter play at least one small
threat maybe takes Pawn check you really
don't want to lose the A3 Pawn because
two on none that's a very clear win but
one on zero and one on zero on separate
sides of the board kind of got a split
like in bowling and that may not be the
best for not's winning chances and you
can see him he seems shaky and the eval
B also shaking but it's going back down
towards the center yeah the nerves are
jangling here Fabiano going for this
type of idea potentially you could
imagine the black Rook G7 somehow
landing on the first rank again another
ladder Checkmate uh suddenly counter
playay the a3n attack he's retreating
going passive suddenly big threats on
the board Rook to see1 it's not
Checkmate yet white can block but it's
certainly in the air the momentum has
certainly turned Fabby getting his
chances with just seconds on the clock
not fact he needs to slow down right now
he's got about a minute and a half and
he needs to use that time uh judiciously
to try to find the right way forward and
I think he's done just that freeing up
his King from that last TR Frank yeah
rook2 yeah there's a couple checks for
black but as you say Rook F2 was such a
great defensive try yeah just getting
the white king breaking it out of jail
out of prison there and again just just
floating this idea of a rook trade but
still some work to be done Black's King
isn't quite checkmated both Kings
actually in a bit of trouble in this end
game but uh yeah still some work to do
to convert this Advantage maybe the
white king should go up to H3 you slide
The Rook behind the king he goes to H2
instead but he's just going to bring one
Rook to the G file now the F2 Rook over
and try Rook H3 but look at Fabby he's
being clever he's saying please bring
your Rook on over to G2 because if you
do that I force a rook trade but I win
one of your pawns and that may give him
chances to survive tricky Fabby with
that last move Rook to C4 threatening a
check on the hline so still not giving
nbak the position that he's aiming for
nbak is trying to trade off a pair of
Rooks keeping both pawns alive if he
achieves that it's game over Fabby has
to get counterplay with both these on
the board he's visibly nervous though
nck he's got over a minute why is he
behaving like this he was fiddling with
a piece he's kind of panicking every
move and yeah he's repeated the position
now this is the second time we've seen
this he cannot give another check and uh
yeah he feels like he's just yet to find
the plan and Fabby defending so
tenaciously here threatening some checks
from behind now far from over this one I
think King H3 I think it's now is the
time he brings his Rook to E3 instead
the eval bar is going right back towards
the center and the black king this is a
checkmating net if he did not check the
king back black would have had a
Checkmate by Forest let's just show that
there was a massive threat on the board
if White had been careless and for
example pushed his B Pawn forward what
could be more natural push past pawns
check check and mate this white king
could have been caught watch out for
this theme to persist um yeah this
recurring idea of checking the white
king is causing him real issues right
now abov and he looks nervous he's
fiddling with the pieces he's getting
low on the clock he still has aead on
time but Fabiano's task is easier
because even if both players think that
white is winning winning a one position
they say is the hardest thing to do in
chess and Faby keeps bringing the king
forward trying to get white in that
mating net and not about he's shaking
his head he knows that he hasn't been
able to find a way to free up his pieces
or trade those Rooks he hasn't made any
progress meanwhile Fabby he is putting
on great resistance and we might see a
three- time repetition if brings that
Rook back we have seen that position
numerous times at this stage but now the
white a porn is suddenly hanging there's
still some threats of checks
behind wow Fabby he repeats and I think
Fabby is he about he almost I think he
was about to claim could he have claims
but this is the big difference between
online and iners OTB events it doesn't
automatically get a draw you have to
make the claim it's tough when you're
not taking notation down the Arbiters
will step in if it happens enough times
but right now noty he's seems like he's
lost his entire Advantage you look at
the Eva bar it's at zeros which means
that it might be now a three-time
repetition yeah those threats of those
checkmating Nets and threats against the
white pawns combined are just too much
white cannot fend off both of those
ideas and I did check I don't think it
was a three move repetition so it was a
good call not to claim there Fabiano but
uh he's defending he's focusing on those
moves and playing Perfect Defense here
just amazing amazing resistance here by
Fabby playing for that piece activity
the king participating in it and nbak
just unable to make progress with two
extra pawns and it's something all the
players complimented Magnus about how
resilient he is that he doesn't lose
when he even should be lost and Fab is
doing much the same he's improving his
defensive tenacity his resourcefulness
and right now he just keeps chasing the
white Rook yeah what to do with white
now he's really in danger of repeating
the position all these checks won't help
the black king will not get checkmated
on its own there it can defend itself
and okay he moves across suddenly there
are checks o the white king in a bit of
danger suddenly Fabby gives one of those
checks where are you hiding you can't go
to the third rank you've got to keep
that A3 Pawn defended and it's going to
fall you just give a check on D1 pick up
the Rook pick up the pawn but he might
think that his King is close enough and
the black king might be cut off so is
this a theoretical draw that's the
essential question both players just
like the audience don't have that answer
in front of them so Rook takes Rook King
takes rook and Rook takes Pawn on the
flank Pawn with check the white king
slides up diagonally and the black king
is it close enough I think it does get
back in time Fabian is calculating that
right now yeah I just checked he cannot
take the Rook he cannot he will get cut
off across the board and uh we'll show
this later on unless it happens on the
board right now he doesn't trade Rooks
he saves himself Faby that was a trap
Abdu satov looked a bit disappointed
there that it didn't happen but now a
bunch of more checks Fabby still
extremely active I think this was a good
practical decision keeping the tension
because Abdus stov still cannot make
progress in incredible Precision there
by Fabby and he's getting the extra
seconds on the clock as the position
gets repeated
and look at not he's trying to set up
ladder checkm ideas his the black king
is cut off along the fourth rank he's
going his own Rook on the fifth rank but
Fabby continue to check this King the
white king does not have much shelter so
check check check check where is that
King running too and if you trade Rooks
too far away from those queenside pawns
then black will happily happily pick up
the A3 Pawn he's driving the king
forward but the king can hide in front
of its own Rook here okay it keeps
marching up the board and the white Rook
will Zoom behind to block it on F4 but
it's almost Checkmate that second Rook
the black rook in the corner when that
slides over to give a check only that
white Rook on the H4 Square can block
that check otherwise it would be made
the black king almost checkmated as well
the black king barely with any squares
look at it getting chased back now this
is surely winning Fabiano he's blundered
he's allowing a rook trade even check me
and game over oh my God that was a mid
at the very end what a game what a peace
f there by both nbec and Fabiano Carana
but nbec comes back on top takes that
end game incredible resistance but not a
back incredible power play by him as
well persistence trumped resistance
there n backck he never lets up not for
a single moment and he should be feeling
good about himself today he beat Dennis
lazic in the round three matchup earlier
now he takes game one against favano
that was Stellar stuff and that was the
only decisive game of round of game one
off round four nbec Abdu satov takes
down the world number two
meanwhile alira fuja with attacking play
Brave play but Wesley so keeping it so
solid that ended in a draw and Dennis uh
lavic Maxim B grab great result for the
17-year-old also a draw and of course
the Mari matchup ended peacefully and Ka
spoke to Magnus Carlson after that
draw
heard in the Norwegian interview uh a
little bit surprised out of the opening
here with hiar and also some thoughts
about a queen sacrifice in this game
yeah there were several there were
several points where I could actually
think about sacrificing the queen and I
very much wanted to um but I didn't get
the chance really yeah so obviously it
was a surprise to see him play this this
line and um I mean I've played it like a
couple of times as black so I know a
little bit about it but not too much
detail so I was just trying to play
something you know with common sense and
um then yeah I just missed his move
Bishop to B4 later um I was going to
just capture on e4 earlier and thought
that was slightly better but um yeah the
way the way it went I had no chances I
mean I was probably even like very
slightly worse so for that the draw is
okay so what will you expect in game two
when he comes you with the white
pieces it's very hard to say sometimes
in these situations he just likes to try
and force to draw other times he's um
you know trying to give you your best
his best punch it's hard to predict it's
uh been some epic Armageddon battles and
bidding with Hikaru throughout the
season do you really want to avoid
Armageddon with him or do you think U
that would be a cool thing um no I
wouldn't I mean playing Black in the
second game without lead uh it's hard to
be too unsatisfied if it comes to
armagedon but you know I'm prepared for
um whatever like you know he he tries
and and then we'll then we'll see if I
have to play Armageddon then that's okay
thank you for joining us Magnus best of
luck in next one thank you that's Magnus
Carlson let's see what happens in game
two the ball is in Hikaru nakamura's
court with the white pieces will he get
ambitious or will he take this match
into our mageddon we will find out but
what a round one we've had David some
big moments big end games what's to that
to you yeah I just want to highlight
that key moment in the only decisive
game of uh that round it was where
Fabiano could have saved the draw he
defended so tenaciously he gave a check
he gave another check and actually when
the king marched back he did avoid the
Trap of taking this Rook because in this
position uh very instructively uh the
white king marches forward and and the
black king gets driven uh away white is
indeed winning this end game but uh
instead he could have simply repeated
why did he' come back to G1 that is the
mystery he could have just given checks
forever and would have secured the draw
Fabiano in the end did go down to defeat
but he was so close and Abdus stov took
the win it is so difficult to also just
keep the resistance going amazing
pressure there put by the usbek Phenom
nbec takes the win which means that
Karana has to win on demand to take it
to Armageddon big big game two is coming
up and another player who was very
impressive in game one round two was a
17-year-old Dennis lavic holding the
former World Blitz Champion to a draw
they'll be battling it out in the action
coming up in just a few moments from
Toronto don't go
[Music]
anywhere I can guarantee that working
your way through this course and solving
all 1,1 exercises will reward you not
only with a greater tactic and knowledge
but also with spotting more tactics in
your own games my name is FES dantony
and I'm a woman International master I
wish you a warm welcome to the course
101 chess exercises for beginners
authored by Franco mati and Roberto Mesa
with videos by me in this case the KN on
C5 is not protected and so the winning
move is G6 G6 is the discovered attack
but it is also a double attack because
not only are we hitting the Knight on C5
we are also threatening mate on H7 in
this case Rook C7 black has no choice
but to capture and now our Queen comes
in we've lured the queen away now the
king is too far removed it cannot
protect the black queen so we are going
to pick up the black queen on the next
move
[Music]
any good chess tactics book has one
pattern in it that feels like it is on a
completely different level than all of
the other tactical patterns bearing the
Vivid and accurate moniker the windmill
this pattern features an amazing
sequence of repeated discovered checks
that can be used to win a nearly
unlimited amount of material the most
famous windmill is definitely the one
played by Mexican Prodigy Carlos té
against former world champion Emanuel
Lasker but Bobby Fisher's game of the
century also features a windmill here's
another one that I really like white
starts with a rook sacrifice that leads
to a combination of Bishop and Rook
checks that simply consume Black's
forces the lefong is a dirty dirty trick
that will probably only work at bullet
but you have to pull it off at at least
once in your life when you sense that
your opponent is pre-moving G6 and
Bishop G7 to start the game you can play
D4 and Bishop H6 to try to win the
bishop on g76 guys no one is watching
oh they all missed that I see the Tilt I
can feel the
tilt
it is a high-risk and high reward
strategy because you are hanging your
own Bishop if you don't catch them in a
pre-move but it is certainly hilarious
when you do pull it off like one of my
friends AOS he made a um bot the report
was ba partly based on hyper bullet
games so then you can see a lot of the
Leons and queen C2 takes H7 and
[Music]
so
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
I am beyond excited to announce on
February 23rd through 25th we will be
hosting the first ever chess.com
Invitational presented by Discraft at
the famed course in Brooksville Florida
we will be kicking off this year's disc
golf pro tour in style with not only
incredible disc golf but many more
activities there will be a one-of-a-kind
chess disc golf crossover you won't want
to miss as well as an exclusive
chess.com fan Zone I personally couldn't
be more pumped to bring epic disc golf
competition and fun hope to see you all
[Music]
there
don't miss out on Twitch drops during
the CCT finals watch four cumulative
hours of Chess on chess 24 or chess
channels and unlock a free 14 days of
diamond membership on chess.com connect
your accounts at go. chess.com connect
to redeem and enjoy two weeks of Premium
features and right now it's time to
enjoy the over the board action coming
in from Toronto as we are about to kick
kick off game two of round four in just
a few moments it's already been an
incredibly dramatic day of chess can we
expect some more armagedon coming in oh
I definitely think so we had a decisive
game there at the end between no de
Becka dusar and 5in Carana but Magnus
Carlson Nar Nakamura I think that one is
definitely going to Armageddon we'd love
to see that one go all the way David
into the Armageddon yeah I want to see a
fight in the game first but I wouldn't
complain about Armageddon it's going to
get faster more Furious and yeah whoever
gets black in that one I think would be
the favorite they're just looking solid
right now and Hikaru is really pucked up
today he's looks so much better than he
did yesterday uh that first day blues
and yeah it's hard to predict that one
suddenly I think Dennis lvic he gets the
white pieces against Maxim Vash gra and
in that first game a solid draw with
black white in game two I don't think
he's taking too much risk he's a very
solid repertoire I think we'll see him
in armag once more oh that's going to be
amazing as well and Dennis he's been
having these great games against the
very best in the world he hasn't managed
to get up on the leaderboard but that
hasn't been reflective of his quality of
Chess here yeah the zero doesn't tell
the full story he's been very accurate
he's that type of player and he could
beat Maxim if Maxim gives him the
chance the action is about to get
started we're going to go into our
playing Arena as we see the players are
ready to go and to start some more chess
wow no handshakes there yeah I think
they must have shaken hands beforehand
just uh before the game started when
they sat down uh no animosity here a lot
of mutual respect of course but D4 and
Magnus thinking he does play his Knight
out to F6 uh his trademark move and
Bishop to G5 for trpovski just as
Nakamura was displaying yesterday he
ventured this on several turns Magnus
must have prepared what's so interesting
about this is the openings that hikaro
have been playing they're usually for
surprise value but when you play them
over and over again there's no longer
the surprise yeah shows his faith shows
his confidence in in these openings and
Magnus does play something slightly
unorthodox there usually in that exact
position black recaptures with the G
Pawn towards the center I think usually
in chess the default setting is towards
the center uh unless you're kind of
aiming to open up pieces trying to
accelerate your development now Black's
D5 Pawn is going to be eternally a
Target so Magnus has to compensate with
active pieces and I must say bizarre
that Magnus is the first one to really
think especially as you say Robert that
this is no longer a surprise weapon from
Hikaru and Magnus just made the Big
Choice he is the one who captured away
from the center this kind of resembles
some lines in the Dutch defense he does
defend that D5 Pawn his Knight on B8 can
develop next the dark score Bishop is
already protecting the C5 pawn and
perhaps Magus wanted to avoid the
territory that Maxim Vash lra got
himself into because Hikaru showed he
has very deep preparation in some of
these lines and Hikaru had some deep
preparation in game one of this match as
well as Magnus himself admitted that he
was taken by surprise and F felt the
pressure can Hikaru continue with that
he takes out the knight in front of the
king it will eventually land on F4
trying to put more pressure on that D5
Pawn the development continues uh are we
expecting White's Knight to land on F4
quite possibly if not now then in the
near future first he might decide to F
and ketto his Bishop White's light squ
Bishop is stuck there we go who pushes
the pawn creating a nice beautiful home
for it on the G2 Square again peering at
that weakness the target the D5 Pawn for
and Hikaru if he gets two more moves if
he gets his Bishop there on G2 gets
castled I think he's going to be loving
his position long-term strategically
very strong for white better Pawn
structure and targets especially if the
center is closed Knights will Thrive
rather than Bishop so Magnus needs to
play energetically and uh creatively
here to hold the
balance and once again it is uh Magnus
who goes into a bit of a think in this
position how can he try to play
energetically in this position does he
start attacking Hikaru Center take out
the queen to B6 Target the B2 Pawn not
give white the enough time and Tempo to
put pressure on the D5 Pawn I can tell
you what I wouldn't do if I were Magnus
I wouldn't close the center by pushing
the C5 Pawn because that feels like it
leaves the D5 Pawn is a long-term
weakness he starts by taking on D4 that
makes a lot of sense to me it opens up
his Bishop on f8 gives it full scope of
the diagonal maybe out to B4 to pin that
Knight his Queen can go out to B6 that's
one of the benefits of pushing your C
Pawn so early and Sicilian or in this
type of game the queen can venture out
putting pressure on B2 and the white
Central Pawn on D4 so I like the way
that both players are handling it thus
far I think it's early stages but for
Hikaru he's the one now taking a think
here clearly both players are on their
own yeah if he takes with a knight it
does look nice for white long term but
short term I think black has enough
counterplay this is a big big weakness
in the center of course isolated Pawn
iqp uh here but Bishop to B4 as Robert
also mentioned uh you hited it at this
one and unfortunately white isn't quite
in time okay he's actually played this
but white isn't in time here to put
enough pressure on this isolated Queen
spawn and Magnus blitzing down this road
it does feel that Magnus maybe was in
preparation just took a while to uh kind
of familiarize himself remind himself of
what he had planned and Bishop takes
night is actually a big strategic threat
long-term white would be suffering with
a broken structure there so maybe you
need to defend this Knight with your
queen maybe you step back with your
fellow Knight but you're losing time uh
you're not playing Happy moves here you
need your king to get to safety but
Magnus
energetic really nicely handled by
Magnus Carlson and a non-standard bond
structure out of the opening but he
doesn't give Hikaru the chance to get
the ideal development structure he does
move ahead with the queen so keeping the
pawn structure intact in any reality
does white go alongside
Castle maybe only if you're feeling
super Brave maybe Reckless um I've got
to say seile yeah the sea file it just
looks too dangerous right now now and uh
yeah just while this position settles
down I do like the quality of Black's
pieces I don't like the quality of the
DN though the pawn structure uh but the
air quality there looking Fair looking
fair and uh I think this position is
fairly balanced right now uh just level
chances and it is about who uh feels
more comfortable uh out there in Toronto
in this Arena feels like both players
just again probing testing each other
and I like the fact that we're
guaranteed a fight in this game uh no
peace treaty uh in sight anytime soon
yeah because hikaro when he wants a draw
he forces it he plays openings that
require repetition we've seen these two
have various repetitions like uh in the
Berlin is what hiar usually does against
Wesley and some D4 lines against Magnus
but here we have a fight we have a pin
along the B4 Bishop down to the King on
E1 with the queen in between them so I
like the position that we have it seems
like we could get quite some rich play
but will hiar learn a lesson that
Fabiano might have taught him that
Fabiano played on maybe a little bit too
far and then Magnus was able to seek
control of that position yeah talking of
trying to kind of just maintain control
trying to uh kind of kill the fun for
black here how do we achieve that do we
test uh magnus' intentions with the dark
squared Bishop so we just rush to get
castled with the white king probably on
the king side I think Tanya at this
point it's probably just a distant dream
castling uh on the long side castling
Queen side right now we were talking
about the C file The Rook has already
landed on that the long Castle would uh
be hard to imagine as a possibility but
black he's already threatening Magnus is
already threatening to jump ahead with
the Knight targeting White Queen side
while Hikaru takes a think about how he
wants to get those pieces developed and
how he wants to get his King to safety
let's head over to another juicy match
up Wesley so with the black pieces the
man in form the man to beat is playing
against Ali Resa fuja and regardless of
how the tournament goes we know alira he
always plays aggressive Dynamic chess
and what is that Rook doing on e4 yeah
wow this is Juicy allara has already
sacrificed a pawn he's fighting against
the Berlin War the Berlin defense
normally one of the most Rock Solid
openings for black but he's thrown a
pawn away and he's saying I've got
active pieces you mentioned that Rook on
e4 T it looks weird it has just landed
there uh that white Rook has uh yeah
maybe aggressive intentions in mind but
I don't really see the the compensation
right now maybe it's just in the fact
that black cannot quite fight for the
center yet looks DC right that this Pawn
on D4 was threatened that's why the Rook
came up to E4 that Knight on C3 for
white will jump forward into the
position putting pressure on that Bishop
on F6 so all of a sudden we see where
White's pieces are going should black
just develop with that Bishop on C8 to
B7 it will stare through the Knight
towards that Rook on e4 the B5 Pawn is
loose can that be captured they're
difficult questions to answer and you
know both players they are trying to
evaluate this position yeah how to
evaluate it it's the hardest thing Tanya
and I'm trying to evaluate how we even
got here uh David we got to do an action
replay of how this opening went because
to me I'm I'm struggling I get that this
is perhaps coming out of Spanish what
happened in the opening here yeah as I
mentioned it's the Berlin defense so
after E4 E5 the knight's coming out
Bishop to B5 this is the Spanish the Roy
Lopez white puts pressure on this Knight
the Black Knight comes out white just
castles allowing a pawn to be grabbed
and here after Pawn to D4 Knight back we
normally see the Berlin endgame after a
trade on C6 Pawn's coming off and queens
coming off as well this is welln well
explored it's actually happened in this
tournament already in the last game
between Maxine vasra and Dennis lavic
but here fua surprised his opponent weso
by dropping back simply saying I'm going
to be a porn down I don't care uh White
is ahead in development and the black
king is slightly vulnerable but uh here
white simply pushing forward with C3 and
this is crazy stuff Robert another Pawn
right he could have captured on C3 but
that would give white such a rapid lead
in development and Raz of fuja during
the cidis he played against Daniel
nitzki in this really long bullet
marathon when maybe some said he should
have been preparing for his game da
plays this style from the white side so
maybe he's picked something up from
Daniel neski learning from the best ala
F there and uh yeah the second Pawn
should not be captured it was not
captured black prioritized development
and if we catch up with the current
position B5 is a very clever move uh
this is recommended in various sources
uh you need to activate your pieces
black knights in the way of the Pawn so
you need to activate your Bishop on the
long diagonal and wow after Bishop to B7
uh in the game position we were talking
about some x-ray vision here on the
white Rook the white Rook simply
sidestepped Robert attacking this night
ambitious play do you think this is
preparation for Malera it feels like it
because who puts their Rook on F4 rather
than say a bishop if not being well
prepared in this line but I like this
for white I think that Wesley right now
can bring his C6 Knight back to E7 to
open up the scope of his Bishop on B7
but we're getting into territory that is
about to get very complicated 97 has
just been played white is down a pawn so
do you think David that he's got enough
compensation for it the evaluation Bar
says yes so I'll say yes but this is not
what I would be risking as you say I
mean who puts a rook on F4 uh definitely
not me I would never dream of such a
creative idea but this is why Aliza is
such a strong Dynamic attacking player I
have a feeling uh just trying to get
into his mind right now he wants to play
the move Pawn to D5 blocking out this
bishop you need to play against your
opponent's pieces here who cares if
you're a pawn down actually the lack of
a Pawn on C2 means you do have a nice
Square for your Bishop to retreat to
later on a beautiful diagonal if you can
line up the bishop on C2 the queen on D3
along this diagonal later on but first
it makes sense to block out this bishop
and maybe actually this comes with a
threat of Knight to E4 and this black
Bishop is slightly trapped if you can
take it you would wreck Black's Pawn
structure so I'm going to say it's
growing on me White's position the
compensation is there certainly I'm
really liking what alas Don Hill playing
for the initiative down upon bit a
critical moment right now the idea that
David pointed out will put big questions
to Wesley to handle the threats on the
pieces that are quite clamped on the
king side for black right now we will
check in with Ali Resa how he proves his
compensation another very uh interesting
game that is developing is Fabiano
Carana against nbec now Fabby has the
white pieces he needs to win this to
force it to armagen nck is leading the
match with that first round Marathon
victory that he had and the position up
front I see that Valar says it's level
white does have the bishop a but to me
it just feels like black species are
more active the queen and the bishop
lined up on the diagonal the Knight on
G4 all of them eyeing F2 the Knight on
D4 doesn't look very stable there is a
threat to actually pick up that pawn on
the next move I see the bishop there but
I'm liking blackp activity here agreed I
couldn't have put it better myself
just every piece is active for black who
cares about the bishop pair even if it's
an open position as long as the rest of
your pieces are playing a part and yeah
it's difficult Fabby is going to be in
the back of his mind he needs a win so
he will be taking risks and okay he does
kick the Knight back out I'm assuming it
drops back into the center uh to E5 but
yeah no issues here for Abdu stov but
considering how quickly n plays in more
complicated positions that Knight if I'm
not mistaken has no other moves right
that Knight is under attack can't go
forward so Knight E5 is the only option
so what is he thinking about here very
good question okay eventually he dropped
his KN back maybe he was trying to peer
into the future and uh work out whether
now he can go for that idea Tanya
mentioned of taking a pawn taking
this night I was going to say Rook takes
Pawn now does look Frau with danger you
would be walking into a pin trying to do
some quick calculation I don't think you
should I don't think you can get away
with taking the spawn and if that's the
case then now I like the bishop here
because two Bishops against two knights
the D4 Pawn can be blockaded so what Aon
nimich always taught everybody is that
if there's an iqp and I said que Pawn
you want to blockade it with a knight so
it can never push forward and that is
what he has available to him he goes the
other direction Knight to G6 similar
idea just get the Knight out of danger
block with the the piece on D5 but as
David you were pointing out the brook
takes D4 move ago that was not a free
Pawn in fact it handed white a free
Advantage yeah this would have been
disastrous for black two pieces
vulnerable on the diagonal so uh very
level position but Bishops versus
Knights is about who Maneuvers those
minor pieces better in this ensuing
middle game speaking of maneuvering
perhaps NC's Knight can also maneuver
from f8 to E6 putting more pressure on
the weak D4 Pawn that we're looking at
right now this one is going to be quite
a long long fight and we will check back
in with it uh meanwhile also
developments happening on our Mari
matchup Nakamura with the white pieces
against Magnus Carlson the first game
did end in a draw speaking of the the
bishop it looks like Magnus is the one
who's got the bishop a the pawn
structure as we see uh was uh was
shattered out of the opening but in
compensation there we see the bishop a
how much does that count right now it
counts for a lot I also think we don't
want to read too much into body language
at least in a typical game this is not a
typical game it's Magnus versus aaru and
Magnus before he looked like he was
upright just hunched over the board
think yeah my position looks good and
hiar is deep in thought I like black
position you have this bishop pair in
the center you have great files for your
Rooks the queen on B6 is on a a nice
Square as well I don't see how white
builds up the pressure and black Magnus
he plays A5 he may even throw away that
pawn Jedis in it with A4 to try to get
his pawns U into territory where they
can't be counted on the C and D files
yeah I fully agree certain positions
like the one we mentioned earlier it's
unclear with how strong the bishop pair
can be but right now the Bishops are
complimented by some very strong Pawns
in the center Center uh for black and
there was a small trap in the position
that we can maybe highlight and wow
Magnus going for it right now trying to
open lines for his Bishops uh first he
pushed this Pawn to A5 and I just want
to mention this Pawn was poisoned do not
take it you walk into a horrible
horrible uh double attack here after
Queen takes uh recaptures the bishop
suddenly a hit on this rook in the
corner and a hit on the queen this is
why Hikaru actually preemptively shifted
his Rook from the corner over to B1
instead of taking on D5 and there was
potentially a threat against this Pawn
Magna says okay take me if you dare Pawn
to D4 and this relies on the fact that
after an exchange suddenly white is
again caught in two minds suddenly this
bishop hits the a pawn suddenly Black's
Rook is Unleashed against the backward
C2 pawn and if you take with the queen
again a skewer a double attack whatever
you call it disaster for white this
diagonal is just too vulnerable and I
think this would be disasterous suddenly
The Bishop's really dominating the whole
board uh so the question is can you take
with a knight um that's one I haven't
figured out yet I think that's one
Hikaru is trying to figure out in the
current position can he take twice feels
like Magnus has something in mind here
this looks so so dangerous with a pin
maybe you move your Bishop to attack
this Knight and it's just hanging by a
thread right now for Hikaru with the
bishop air seeing all the files and
diagonal open up one gets a feeling that
D4 might have been also an intuitive
sacrifice rather than Magnus having
calculated all the lions and how he's
going to win the pawn back or take
advantage of it it's really s tempting
and you have a feeling that with the
Bishops and the Rooks lined up something
has to work for black here yeah for sure
all the pieces are on optimal squares
and even if white can grab the pawn on
D4 the worst thing that happens for
black is you grab the A3 Pawn so you're
like it's just a pawn trade that's not a
big deal I didn't blunder anything so
that's the good news for Magnus as you
said Tanya it might be an intuition
decision there like let me just go for
it at the very least I'm equal material
but he may even have more yeah I'm
looking at ideas like Bishop to E5 Maybe
Bishop to G4 kick away this Rook before
taking back on this square but Hikaru
goes for it he's uh maybe obliged to go
for this otherwise he's just suffering
for nothing often in chess if you're
worse if you realize you have a
disadvantage you might as well grab some
material you might as well get some
long-term advantages and hope to survive
suffer uh for a reason but right now
it's up to Magnus Carson I'll let him
make the decision rather than myself
because it's calculation time he needs
to justify uh this sacrifice if he takes
that pawn uh as you mentioned Robert on
A3 he's probably still slightly better
but um he might be looking for more
first of all so many options here for
black and that's can be difficult for a
player in fact it can backfire like oh I
have so many options my position is
great but then you burn clock trying to
figure out the best path forward I'd lik
this move Bishop E5 or Bishop C5 to
induce C3 that's an option I'm wondering
in those lines can black also go after
the B3 Pawn but their are pins Galore
it's not easy to calculate so Magnus
he's investing time wisely and as Magnus
does just that trying to figure out the
way forward after giving up that pawn we
will check in with this game meanwhile
action is really heating up as alira fua
has sacrificed an exchange for once
again to get that attack and initiative
against Wesley so we are going to jump
into that as it is a critical moment
between these two players their first
game ended in a draw and this one looks
like draw is perhaps the least likely of
the results is there enough compensation
for white hair I'm surprised I've got to
say the evaluation bar if I were black I
would be tempted to resign it looks like
Checkmate but with cold blooded defense
which Wesley so is capable of uh it
looks like black should be able to
survive this Onslaught look at that
White Queen though look at the White
Knight the two white Bishops both
pointing towards the king side the black
structure is totally shattered I mean it
looks so so dangerous right now but uh
this is where engines kill the joy kill
the fun I love it though fuja playing to
his strengths but he's also maybe
playing into a trap because Wesley so he
may not bring the heat he doesn't always
initiate the complications but when
they're brought to him he says let's do
this thing and Wesley has been in great
form thus far I think he was fortunate
to survive the first game between these
two he ended up sacrificing his Queen
for a couple of Rooks rather than
stealing a pawn but in this position I
mean Wesley he's shown that he can
defend he did it against Maxim sh grav
in their Armageddon game and in this
current position we see that black has a
rook for just a bishop and black also
still has an extra Pawn so it's one of
these things where if white is not quick
if white doesn't seize the initiative
right here and right now you're down a
whole lot of material and black has a
basic but an extremely strong threat on
the board right now let's show it Tanya
big threats uh should not be missed and
I don't think ala FIA will miss that
there's actually a Checkmate in one
threat back rank uh Checkmate here Queen
to E1 uh but he does need to therefore
cover this Square on E1 or at least
cover the first rank it makes sense as
well to try and activate this white Rook
eventually so that does beg the question
where to move this bishop uh therefore
you would cover the E1 Square you can
choose D2 E3 H6 multiple options uh but
what to do here um I mean the first one
I would look at create a threat why not
but the problem is you might want to use
that square for your queen and after the
black Rook simply moves same threat
persists again Queen to E1 would be a
back rank Checkmate within 2 minutes
moves even at the cost of a queen he
does Play Bishop to D2 instead and uh
wow Wesley bringing the other Rook into
the game I was going to say this is a
bit odd to trap your Rook on f8 but um
yeah he's activating all his pieces
still needs a break through fua here
something we've yet to speak about
though is look at Fu's clock I feel like
usually it's Al Raza putting pressure on
someone on the clock now it's Wesley
doing that he has nearly 8 minutes now
Al down to three and a half minutes in
this position where f is down in
exchange has to deal with some back rank
threats constantly doesn't have a clear
path to delivering any sort of checkm
attack of his own I have to like
Wesley's chances here just the way he's
playing overall and given this current
situation Wesley so looks like he might
go four out to four yeah and that last
move Rook to E8 uh it does have a deep
idea as well not only are you blocking
White's Bishop from stepping on to H6
because the mate on E1 if it's black to
play here let's say white makes the
natural move H3 creating a lift for the
king black is threatening to actually
push out that knight from C3 with
advancing that B Pawn and then black
sque would have landed on E2 which is
why I think alira he's played a really
nice prophylactic move here with putting
that Bishop on D3 it might look like
he's just attacking the B5 Pawn but he's
also controlled a very key E2 Square
from where a queen trade could have been
offered yeah and here we see a helping
hand from the engine from stockfish
suggesting three moves that give black
quite a significant Advantage so it uh
basically proves that Black's material
the extra material the extra exchange
and porn that Robert mentioned I mean
it's the most important factor right now
White's attack is an illusion Black's
Knight on G6 Knight are a king's best
friend is holding the for covering
everything and okay he plays Pawn to B4
not one of the moves suggested by the
engine uh but still looks very natural
and white apparently only has one move
to minimize the damage that's Knight to
B5 that is not an intuitive move because
Knight goes away from where most the
action is taking place but you're trying
to distract the Black Knight and he
finds it he understands that Knight on
D6 is the critical defender of this
position and if you take this Knight on
B5 in comes that white knight to F5
Queen H6 to follow Queen G7 Checkmate
thank you very much wow what a trick
what a trap so Vigilant there just full
board awareness and and this is Ali
resa's strength right he finds these
creative ideas on the board just
voluntarily sacrifices the exchange for
a long-term initiative and now finds the
defender he's getting rid of it Wesley
so he needs to be precise in this uh
position he's got a lot to think about
and meanwhile big update coming in uh
Dennis lavic has drawn his second game
against Maxim vasher lra the 17-year-old
should be very proud right now Maxim VRA
he has been on fire he's had some
tremendous Gams one of the best in the
world and the youngster for whom this is
the platform that he's been waiting for
the opportunities that he's been waiting
for he's been showing Amazing class
himself that one goes into Armageddon
and here anything can happen this was a
position I thought Wesley had the
obvious upper hand now I'm looking at it
that F5 squar is Juicy and a night might
plop right on it and try to help deliver
a checkmat so Dennis lvic Maxim Vash
they'll go to Armageddon for Dennis lvic
0 out of three thus far in match play
but he's really been just a couple moves
away in every single match from being on
the scoreboard we'll see if he can get
that done but right now we're going to
have to see if Ali Raza can turn this
disadvantage into a win yeah Wesley just
missed this one I think it was that
simple Wesley assumed that he had full
control and he nearly did but just one
careless slip and suddenly tactics again
uh Knight and F5 will Thrive that's the
rhyme Knight and F5 we're live as James
KY would say and uh yeah suddenly big
big threats actually a narrow path
potentially for Wesley to save this game
I think it's just that powerful the
White Knight if it does land on F5 would
just spell the end so uh this is a
narrow window of opportunity to kill
White's attack but I'm struggling to
find it why I mean Wesley so struggling
to find it as well he's t now for a
couple of minutes he find he finds the
move Bishop to A6 wow clever clever
defense there lovely move by Wesley so
he's realizing that I've had a material
advantage if I have to give some of it
away to save my king that is the best
decision and he may be saying okay if
the Knight takes the Knight on D6 then
the bishop on D3 can be captured here
and you just don't have enough Firepower
Knight F5 still looks really scary I
don't even want your Rook I'm going to
go for checkmate but once I take your
knight on F5 and you take back with your
knight I can make this move Queen to E5
four and the point is Queen H6 still
checkm in one is the threat but I get to
take your knight away on F5 you don't
have another Defender yeah just in time
it's all hanging by a thread but it is
surviving for Wesley so and the critical
line therefore is after night takes
Knight to take this black Rook but as
you said Robert you're no longer at the
exchange up you still have an extra Pawn
though as long as you survive this
attack only black can be better with the
queen coming into E2 it's all of these
ideas we mentioned uh Tanya's Queen E2
and uh yeah right now I think ala a bit
disappointed that Wesley did find the
best defense just precise play by Wesley
he's so resourceful and just so hard to
crack or beat even in these positions
Knight B5 arrives on the board and mayor
mles would just collapse at that moment
but he finds the right path and it is on
the board will Ali Resa now grab the
rook and more exciting news coming in as
we will have another Armageddon as zaru
Nakamura and Magnus Carlson have drawn
their second game I knew I recognized
that shirt blocking all's camera for a
while there it was Magnus Carlson he did
finish and we have more chess to look
forward to from him a bit later on but
uh Magnus is out of there and uh let's
focus back on this one where ala
Retreats not a good sign usually but
that night was no longer playing a
purpose on the edge of the board I'm
still looking at the clock and ala down
nearly to a minute and a half whereas
Wesley has nearly 5 minutes on his clock
so Knight goes back to F3 the black king
is no longer In Harm's Way perhaps at
this point ala just wants to say rookie
one start trading pieces and going for a
draw but I don't see an advant for
either side at the moment one does feel
though that white has to have enough
compensation with Black's destroyed Pawn
structure as well Bishop E2 played uh
it's also against the idea of the queen
sliding onto A5 White's Rook you've got
to be a little careful do you want to
make a move like Rook e one allowing
tactics like Bishop takes Knight and
perhaps Bishop takes Knight he plans to
take on E E7 and things are still under
control so while these players work out
the tactics we will uh keep an eye out
and uh come back to this but Fabiano
Carana against nbec Abdus satro also
very very critical as fabi's got about a
minute on the clock and it is his move
right now nck ahead on the clock nck
needs only a draw and we were quite
happy with his position last when we
left it and I think we still should be
Fabiano needs a miracle it's as simple
as that Robert so he needs a turn into
Wesley so and then thrive in Toronto but
that's not happening here this is
dominance on display from notc abdar
he's kind of a Kryptonite for Fabiano he
beat him over the bo classical chess in
the Olympiad he beat him to win the
chess kid cup here he won game one and
he might even just win game two I don't
even think he'll offer a courtesy draw
he's not that type of player sometimes
when you're at one- nothing all you need
is a draw to win the match we saw Wesley
do this against Hikaru gave him a draw
kind of a a sympathy draw that's not
happening when n Becka buaro is playing
because there also Fay rapid points on
the line he wants to increase his rating
yeah and look at that the computer says
there are two winning moves for black
right now white has just snapped off a
pawn Fabiano decided to suffer for
something and there is a material
advantage but the black Rook coming into
F3 being the top move that's the most
natural move in the position as well and
I think he will play it it's more about
the followup it looks like the white
king is just devoid of any Defenders
right now black has a queen coming in a
knight coming in Rook coming in
everything's Gathering the storm clouds
are just hovering above there and he's
going to move his Rook look at that body
language it's on the board and now
you're thinking yes all the sacrifices
but he first picks up the pawn you're
hitting the D2 Bishop you're attacking
the G3 Pawn the F2 Pawn is pinned uh and
uh Fabiano Cara has only 40 seconds to
solve all these problems can he do it no
there's no way it's even material so
it's not even like no had to sacrifice
anything to get to this position and he
does attack that Rook on F3 did Fabby
The Rook goes to D3 so B3 is loose
there's some checks on the first rank
that are about to happen I see the
evaluation bar going up for Fabby but I
see his time going down and it just
doesn't give me much hope for him yeah I
just want to highlight one moment where
actually he could have wrapped it up in
style Abdu satoro after Rook to F3 the
queen dropped back guess what Black's
best move is uh this isn't me this is
the computer that suggested it or Rook
E3
Rob this would have been the I'm going
to say it sexiest move of the tournament
so far um just overwhelming white
defenses there's a threat of a sacrifice
here going for checkmate and a knight
coming in would have been disastrous for
white but if we catch up with the
current game is he surviving Fabiano
that's the question the answer is no
he's the exchange down uh we saw a
tactical uh kind of sequence there and
simply nothing to be done let's just
show that in slow motion Queen to B2 an
attack a double attack against this
bishop he did try to defend by taking
giving up his queen with the idea of
Bishop to C3 check but Fabiano played uh
no sorry Ador played Queen take C1 check
intermediate move uh in between move
there and now it's just a lost end game
yeah this is easier this stage cuz
they're pawns on both sides of the board
if you could sweep off the queenside
pawns if none remain then maybe there
would be some chances for Fabiano to
hold the draw and he's going for this
technique he really would like to trade
B Pawn for a pawn but why in the world
would n Beck allow that he can instead
bring his Rook to D3 He does just that t
try to take the B Pawn for himself and
there's nothing Fabiano can do it's been
a tough day and the office for Fabby he
lost his uh round three to Magnus
Carlson it looks like he will be losing
round four to nbec Abdu satov he's got
so much time on the clock as well Fabby
under 30 seconds and I like that NC has
slowed down because this got him a
little bit into trouble in their first
game in their first encounter so it's a
good idea you're up in exchange you want
to just you just want to draw you want
to try and wrap it up as quickly as
possible n back he keeps playing fast
yeah you saw the frustration on his face
he was trying to force himself to slow
down he's so excited right now and
rightly so because he's about to wrap up
a win I think this last maneuver was the
Clincher putting the black Rook behind
White's oh but there's tactics yeah that
was actually really nicely done by Fabby
he trades off the queenside pawns yet
it's still losing according to the
engines and it's probably just because
the black king will Infiltrate The Rook
is in a perfect position and here comes
King F5 Pawn G5 he may be able to spring
for an outside pass Pawn as well yeah
this is still is still winning but I was
about to praise him for pinning and
winning uh instead it's far less simple
uh sometimes you can hold Fortress here
but unfortunately rook and three versus
bishop and three usually is a win and
white just cannot hold the light squares
long term and not a b now big question
is will he just get a draw and uh wrap
up the match or is he going to try for
more because points do count here Robert
points are important in those top eight
standing I see you shaking your head but
you know these youngsters I have a
feeling he's going to try to push this
one there could be nothing on the line
and abitar would still be playing like
he could be in his backyard playing
against his favorite person in the world
and a draw is still good enough he says
no he's that much of a fighter and I
think that's what people love about his
style he should get invited to all the
tournaments where it's you know the
organizer has to pick some people
because he always fights there's never a
game where he takes it off and why
should he give Fabian a draw he's got no
risk in this position yeah I even forgot
that a draw was sufficient for him
because he's been playing such
aggressive chess he's not been backing
down and this is good wisdom for anyone
at home as well even if you're happy
with a draw play objectively correct CH
play for the win that's the best way of
securing that result later on if you
play too passively negatively
tentatively it will backfire your
opponents will punish you and uh he's
being rewarded for his courage here Abdu
satoro he's trying to break through wh's
holding the Fortress Fabiano still
tenacious defense but it shouldn't be
enough long term although the EV are
going right back towards the middle so
just as you said that he pushed F5 which
was apparently the wrong idea and now it
seems that Fabby May hold this draw but
without time on the clock what should
happen doesn't usually happen yeah this
last move putting porns all on like
squares a bit strange but uh yeah we'll
see how this one plays out yes and mck
undoubtedly will go for as long as he
can and Fabiano Carana will have to earn
this draw meanwhile we've earned
ourselves a lot of fun because we're
already guaranteed three Armageddon as
ala fuja and wesle so also ends in a
draw Ali are sacrificing The Exchange
finding his counter plate it's amazing
play and Wesley with his resistance
impossible to crack but in the end there
will be a sudden death in each of these
games and this one continues Fabby doing
all that he can to hold on is this now
closer to draw territory I think yes um
I mean I was just singing his Praises
after dorov but he's kind of allowed
Fabiano to get a fortress he probably
was thinking can I sacrifice my Rook for
this bishop you can tell that the wheels
are turning in not bre's head it's King
is coming around I don't know where to
but King can go to D1 E1 F1 G1 H2 I
don't know what to do with it but the
king can just wrap itself around and
actually Faby block that but there may
F4 at some moment Faby does need to be
very careful because if that pawn
structure is shattered and the H4 Pawn
is loose that could once again give nerb
some winning chances and the thing about
these end games is you can play
accurately for 20 moves for 30 moves but
very often the pressure just keeps
accumulating till uh eventually you
allow a break like F4 or a winning King
Pawn ending and has that happened well
the King has found its way to E1 things
are getting NY for white already yeah
the King has infiltrated it's found its
way Behind Enemy Lines and yeah I think
holding this one now is going to be well
it's going to need a miracle it's going
to be super tough and what's the winning
plan here for black something to do with
Robert's F4 I'm not sure when where why
but it is F4 you need to break White's
porn structure everything's defended
right now you need to ensure that that
won't be the case long term F2 is the
base of White's Pawn chain as well so if
you attack that one um you do tie down
White's remaining pieces Fabby playing
under 10 seconds and aack still enough
time he's putting the pressure on the
board and on the clock and making
progress slowly but steadily yeah he
wants the now he gets F4 so he finally
at long last has been able to push the
pawn he's shattering White's Pawn
structure and Fabby takes it but that
can't be good the PA are split and you
probably just losing one on the spot
look at that body language he shifts he
knows he's got the job done that is big
progress once he split the pawns he's
going to go for them uh now the king can
also go up to F3 you start threatening
Rook takes F2 Pawn at the right moment
ooh yeah Rook G2 and are Rook F2 is Rook
F2 winning in these positions yes it is
and that is it Fabby resigns a King Pawn
ending would be lost and look at nck
he's happy of course he is he beat
Fabian of Carana who had the the best
year in classical chess of anybody two
in a must-win match so not entered the
day with zero match points now he's won
two in a row and he has found his form
and Fabby immediately leaves without
setting up the pieces it has been a
disappointing day for world number two
he lost to Magnus now goes down to nbec
abdat who after a tough start on H day
one where he lost both his games he's
made a comeback on the leaderboard and
these are the results of round four
we've got three big arm eddon coming up
hiar Nakamura Magnus Carlson fuja Wesley
lazic Maxim VRA all go down to the
Wi and David what was the highlight for
you and once again tough to choose tough
to choose but it will be that only
decisive game uh from that last round
and uh it was nbec AB zoro's attack in
the end he did find a way to convert his
Advantage it took a while though and uh
after Rook to F3 it was this little
sequence the queen dropping back and
there might have been stronger moves he
found something strong and simple Queen
takes D4 double threat attacking this
bishop and due to the pin along this
diagonal threatening this G3 Pawn after
Queen to G3 he wrapped it up with this
nice tactic Queen to B2 and a slow
action replay of this trick Queen takes
Knight was not a defense do not take the
queen it is poisoned after Bishop to C3
check white would save the game by
winning the black queen back instead the
black queen is doomed anyway so why not
give it away for the highest price Queen
takes Rook check and only then winning
the Material Exchange up he converted it
smoothly BR taking play there and hold
your breath everyone as we are going
straight to Toronto as Kaa is with
Hikaru and Magnus and their Armageddon
bids at the moment everyone is waiting
for Armageddon bids between hikaro and
Magnus you guys turn your boards let's
see it Magnus oh 15 minutes I guess that
means you win it 9 minutes 40 seconds
was your reaction Hikaru well it's funny
because I actually thought about bidding
1550 minutes just to get white uh in
between these two games but yeah that's
what it is you just play the game can
you Reveal Your tactics with butting 15
minutes minus yeah I wanted to to play
white but I thought he would be a little
bit lower so uh I I mean knowing that I
could have B uh 939 and
one not so happy with that but that's
okay well you guys go prepare thank you
for uh placing your bids here back to
you wow 15 minutes by Magnus making his
intentions very clear that he wants the
white pieces at any cost yeah I think he
doesn't trust hikaru's repertoire at the
moment because he keeps playing these
odd lines but when it comes down to one
game against Magnus Carlson with a Time
deficit I think that's when hikaro he
won't be as adventurous he'll stick to
his main repertoire yeah I mentioned
earlier Magnus is traditionally the king
of Armageddon so many Armageddon wins
but you saw the doubt in his voice there
he wasn't sure Hikaru still has enough
time and if Hikaru gets out of the
opening in good shape it's going to be a
race on the clock wow this is H going to
be a lot of fun the armagen that is
coming up we've got three of them uh and
Magnus there with his bid against Hikaru
Nakamura they are ready to go Magnus
will start with the wi pieces Hikaru
takes on black hiar needs only a draw to
win this match and we will be back with
this armag Garden that you don't want to
miss do not go
[Music]
anywhere we're here in Toronto for the
global Championship I got Fabiana Carana
with me you don't need to talk yet I got
James K we're going to see who
recognizes these guys out of the out of
the random passerbys and we're going to
ask them some fun questions about Chess
for five bucks do you know who this is
no okay actor an actor when you see this
guy any idea who he is somebody very
famous M he is RA this is actually 50
cents brother his name is darl that's
right goes by 75 you want to play chess
okay so what is he a player or something
of Chess he is a chess player I'm not
but he is I play on the side yeah I've
been taking some coaching lessons from
Grandmaster KY over here recently
calculation over everything what's your
name again sir uh my name is Jimmie
what's your name I already know it it's
it's yeah Daniel
nitzki there it is come on on the attack
baby on the attack if he wins I know the
guys at chess.com we'll get him a
diamond membership okay do you know what
that is yes okay is that something you
want yes yeah okay look at you is this a
London a yo we got a pro here with the
London full on London how to go I Won
Won the that's great hey good game all
right I should have said youtube.com SL
csq what is the URL just YouTube
actually don't
remember look at the
[Music]
Pod chess again no this is spell chess
do I dare read the instructions or
should I go in without reading them I
didn't read the rules this man is just
blundering what basically it's normal
chess but there are two spells jump and
freeze the freeze is applied to a three
by three area man this game is what
freeze here night check boom that's me
oh that's that's that's incredible stuff
oh oh
freeze wait I froze my a jump spell
which allows you to jump over a piece
and I'm setting up a win oh then black
would just freeze
me then I make a double threat you don't
have any freezes left so if here
this is too hard wait once I get the
hang of this we're going to be winning
so many games though I can't block with
any of those pieces but I can use this
this and then
this raise this and then go
here yay I won let's go he cannot take
my Bishop he cannot take my
Bishop it's a nice feeling when you
start understanding the game and you win
oh they resigned I know even li I think
I'm one of the greatest spell chess
players to ever played spell chess that
was fun I'm enjoying
[Music]
this
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
registration is now open for the CCL
spring 2024 season represent your school
in the Premier University league for
team chess compete against top talents
like GM Aang Benjamin Bach and aarin St
your claim for the
$25,000 price fund use the command CCL
in chat to learn how to register and uh
the chess doesn't stop even on two of
the Champions chest finals as we have
not just one but three armagon coming up
and uh we're also going to be revealing
the bids as Kaa caught up with weso and
aliraza
fuja this guy is so sneaky he has been
peeking Wesley no peeking no peeking all
right yeah I thought a little bit oh oh
okay let's not keep DET tension you guys
turn your boards and let's see what your
armag get on bids are let's see it show
it to the camera so we do have
853 that means you will be playing with
the black Pie as Sala was the thought
behind this bed that's low yeah I mean
um I think I have better chances if I
have two results in my favor so but yeah
it's always double Ag and Anything Could
Happen he's incredible with beat this
guy so how do you feel about playing
with the white pieces now Wesley well I
need Danny wrench's help he need to like
pred who's going to
win in the playing Hall one minute
before the game yeah we I need I need
his help now yeah you guys best of luck
in your game thank you so much for
placing your bids here armagon is coming
up back to you guys K we are so excited
three amazing fights coming up Ali Resa
gets the black pieces was that a cat
that Wesley so just drew on his
Armageddon bed I think it was his cat we
know how much Wesley loves his cat
brings him some good luck so why
not yeah they've both uh been playing
chess worthy of works of art that was
Wiley's work of art I mean I admire it I
admire it that picture alone could be
worth a lot of money especially if he
wins the Armageddon game this is going
to be really exciting and speaking of
armagon we got one more let's take a
look at the bids between these two and
this was a close one Maxim V lra takes
it with his 9 Minute 24 second bid and
will be starting with the black pieces
Dennis lazovic with white will have to
win on
Robert what do you make of that Maxim
happy with his bid and getting black
it's quite low I mean all these players
are bidding in that territory with the
exception of Magnus at 15 full minutes
but I think for Dennis lavic you have to
use the time as a weapon the problem is
you're playing one of the best prepared
deepest prepared players in the planet
and someone he looks cozy in that
t-shirt yeah Maxim I think he's made a
good bet just based on the stats Dennis
is yet to win a single game in the final
so far but on Dennis's side what speaks
for him is that he's been upping it day
by day day one he drew a couple of games
but lost both matches now it's his
second Armageddon of day two feels like
he's moving in the right direction he
just needs to make that breakthrough he
just needs a stroke of Fortune or that
Killer Instinct he needs to make use of
those extra minutes dnis lavic has to
forget the match score he has to look
within himself and find the strength in
The Amazing chess that he has been
playing against the very best in the
world he starts with white it's no easy
task for the 17-year-old but one win is
all that he needs right now I feel like
he must play something different than he
normally does because he has such a
solid repertoire he can draw any of
these players in the field with the
white pieces and he drew Maxim with
black as well but he to win on demand he
I think is going to have to choose a new
opening something that has more fight to
it these two did draw their rapid games
and we'll fight it out in the Armageddon
and hiar Nakamura also drew his two
rapid games against Magnus Carlson he
starts with the black pieces Magnus with
that 15minute bit do you think he kind
of got a little bit into hikaru's head
there I'm not sure maybe he got into his
own head because 15 minutes that is
brave but if the opening doesn't go
magnus's way he will regret choosing
white and uh Hikaru does have enough
time uh Hikaru has plenty of time by his
standards at least you make that bit of
15 minutes and you're just saying I'm
going to crush you well Magnus also said
yesterday that it's good to switch up
your bid so you're not predictable when
it comes to the next armor again that
said as you're suggesting Tanya he wants
the white pieces he feels confident he
can win game and the big question is
what will Hikaru play with black because
in most of his games he's playing
offbeat stuff but the line that he chose
earlier with pushing his DNC Pawn
forward he managed to survive out of the
opening and neutralize it really quickly
but Magnus will not let that happen this
time uh he has to win uh black needs
only a draw in the Armageddon Magnus
Carlson stop starts with 15 minutes hik
nakura starts with result odds and this
isn't the only exciting matchup it is
also Ali Resa peruja against Wesley so
guys this is going to be a hard hard
Armageddon to call we'll have to do a
lot of jumping around yeah it's going to
be tough we'll have to follow the action
where it lands but I mean one thing
that's going to be tough is avoiding
being distracted by that shirt during
the Armageddon I mean that could be mind
games with a clock ticking just kind of
look at my shirt well leavon aronian
called he wants a style back but I feel
like leavon will be cheering on Ali
Rizza just because of that shirt and his
play has also been stylish in this event
even his match against Wesley I mean the
way he's just sacrificing material first
a pawn then an exchange in the first
game I think he had Wesley on the Rope
so ala now gets the black pieces I think
he'll tone it back though you don't want
to continue playing so aggressively when
all you need is a draw Ali Raza fuja
playing the chess that he's best known
for and there we see Wesley so has a
arrived handshakes have happened the
three armagen games are ready to be on
the
way the world's best players and uh now
we go handshake and we're off Magnus
Carlson he starts with the Kings porn
instead so veering away from that double
Queen's Gambit and we see Nakamura
employed the Petrov defense solid stuff
and it's again the Damiano variation
that we saw yesterday he employed this
with success what do you think Rober
it's one of these decisions where either
Magnus looked at hikaru's games because
he played this yesterday or he didn't
look at it because it's so ridiculous
that he would play this at the highest
level and Hikaru well what risk does he
have right now that being said it's an
equal position on move four move five
who cares it's Magnus Carlson he's
proven time and time again he can
somehow squeeze water out of a stone
will he be able to this armor get game
that's the big question yeah and
interesting that Magnus doesn't go for
any forcing lines any direct lines we
saw complicated battles in this
variation yesterday Magnus says my
Approach in this Armageddon is to slowly
outplay you later and uh maybe hustle
you on the clock it's very strategic
very slow right now actually this is a
well-known position with colors reversed
and uh it's odd to see the White Knight
stay on E5 in the Petro defense um looks
like Nakamura is prepared though playing
Super Quick up to this point only
spending a few seconds Magnus brings his
Bishop out slight Advantage because he
has that centralized Knight he has the
first move in uh these types of
symmetrical positions and it is about
fighting that Knight on E5 with your own
pieces as black here expecting Hikaru to
line up his Rook on the E file develop
his own Knight to C6 try to trade off
that very strong piece that is posted on
E5 the task is clear for both these
players Magnus has no choice but to keep
the game going he has to try and keep as
many pieces on the board but one more
set of minor one more one set of minor
pieces will come off uh in the center of
the board very very likely but it's hard
to know when to capture it because if
black captures that Knight on E5 at some
moment a pawn will replace the Knight
and then there will be a attacking
chances for white namely with that
Bishop on D3 so I think Magnus he needs
to play a little bit quickly here hiar
with N9 minutes remaining on his clock I
think he's off to the best start
imaginable yeah Hikaru will be thrilled
he might not look it I'm not sure what
face number that is of hikaru's right
now5 oh Danny might tell you off for
that one but shielding uh the glare of
Magnus but he's solid and that's all he
can ask for solid uh is the name of the
game right now with the pet off defense
Rook has lined up we are expecting a
night development and meanwhile Magnus
takes his time but he's got to be
careful because he has to keep the
pressure on the clock as well if the
clock's level out then it's just result
odds for white and uh Hikaru does not
develop the Knight but strikes
immediately in the center targeting the
main defense of that E5 KN huge decision
though because if Magnus just captures
the pawn that was placed on C5 there
will be an isolated a queen Pawn for
Hikaru that's not a bad thing
necessarily but when you don't have so
much time I think players tend to
struggle protecting that pawn you
operate around it that's true but
defending it that's a different story
yeah big uh big decision as you
mentioned Robert to change the pawn
structure I just don't know whether
Hikaru is playing for the result or
sorry I'll let you take it away there
you're absolutely right here C5 is a
very committed move by Hikaru and we
will come back to this and see what
Magnus decides how does he respond to
these questions being asked at the
center of the board remember it's all
about the fight for that E5 post
meanwhile action is heating up on the
other armagedon as well and uh big
fights all around right now Magnus
really taking his
time 12 minutes on the clock he's and we
will come back to this but let's jump
over to Wesley so and alira fuja that
one I am expecting not to be such a
strategic fight the kind of chest that
we've been seeing from Ala I think we're
going to see some fireworks already on
the board you don't wear that shirt and
then just play for a boring draw and we
have a position where white has these
double Pawns in the sea file that may
seem like a bad thing but inherent to
having double pawns is an open file you
see the queen and the Rook for white are
more active than Black's pieces the
queen on d8 doing not so much at the
moment but will there be an attack
that's the big question white will need
to storm up the kingside try to open up
some lines and uh yeah sorry everyone
about that it's been a long day of Chess
a long day of action and uh yeah I've
got to say I really like White's
position here but my question is is it
Wesley so style uh if the only way to
break through is to throw pawns forward
towards the black king I don't know it
feels risky somehow it feels like you
might have to sacrifice something at
some point and the time Advantage is now
down to 3 minutes it's not going to be
easy and wesle so needs to take action
now or in the next few moves if he
really wants to motor forward and attack
win this game and what way to do do that
is to start pushing the G Pawn right you
want to get that pawn rolling you want
to try and open up the G line get G4 get
G5 in perhaps even look at sacrificing
the gwn to open up uh the G file and
Wesley is trying to find his way forward
while White's plan is clear you either
prepare it with the line that David's
pointing out F3 G4 maybe bishop B2 G4
maybe Rook G1 G4 but what is Black's way
of getting counterplay against white
King on the other side of the board well
if White's going to porn storm on the
king side why not Pawn storm on the
queen side and uh I'm not sure how
exactly you do this uh sometimes you can
throw this Pawn forward that might not
get you anywhere you can throw a pawn to
A6 maybe then you hint at a move like C5
at the right moment but yeah every Pawn
push comes with consequences maybe A6 B5
and then throw a knight into C4 um
various options but I think because he
has draw odds fora he can sit the
pressure is on white the onus is on
white and maybe he doesn't even need to
attack maybe just to move like Queen to
E7 just uh kind of centralize your
pieces connect the Rooks and look at
this uh okay he's pausing now but
Wesley's a Time Advantage down to 2
minutes only I was going to say
something similar that because ala only
needs a draw instead of pushing pawns
forward maybe he'll bring his Knight
backwards because he might want to offer
a knight trade then he can might bring
his Bishop that's on F6 over one square
to G5 offer a trade of Bishops so trades
I think they're good for black in this
position when all you need is a draw
yeah just so solid this pet off defense
it's been the bane of so many uh one4
players careers and uh it's just Rock
Solid so trustworthy even if it goes
wrong you end up in a position like uh
this one and actually uh unless white
can attack nothing to complain about so
fuja he needs to speed up though one
minute on this move is a bit too long
maybe just centralize the queen queen E7
just keep the status quo and uh okay he
does play one of the ideas we suggested
Pawn to A6 this one will heat up but
it's on Wesley to heat it up at the
right moment all right so both players
eyeing that flank attack pushing their
own pawns to towards enemy lions and
meanwhile our third Armageddon also well
underway with quite a crazy position we
have been talking about Dennis lavic
having a slow strategic style but take a
look at what has come out of the opening
Maxim's King is in the center White's
Knight on e4 eyeing those dark Square
weaknesses I am loving Dennis's position
here if white is able to trade off those
dark Square Bishop with a move like
Bishop G5 and land a knight on either D6
or F6 this could be big trouble for
maxim and Maxim is the one who's got six
minutes on the clock I don't need an
evaluation bar to tell me that this is a
great opportunity for Dennis lck in a
must-win position you want chances
that's really all you can ask for and
not only does he have chances he's got
space that pawn on E5 is a thorn in
Black side it's covering some really
important squares and look at that F7
Pawn that's a backwards Pawn that may be
targeted so how to actually convert this
Advantage into something that is instead
of aesthetically pleasing where tactic
will land in White's favor that's a
different story and he moves his Bishop
all the way out to H6 I like it Bishop
G7 maybe the H7 Pawn will be picked off
Dennis this is the style that I've
wanted to see from him and he's taking
it right to Maxim yeah whatever he's
done just uh you mentioned switching it
up whatever he's done he needs to keep
doing this you need to attack the top
players that's why he hasn't had that
breakthrough yet but finally he gets a
dream position and it's horrible for
maxim this black king is stranded in no
man's land it can never now Castle on
the king side that would be illegal
castling Queen side as well brought with
danger especially once the a file opens
up so I love this last move keeping his
options open Maxim wellow 5 minutes now
how does he defend he can plant a knight
on a nice square but one good piece is
not enough Rook to G8 wow just stopping
Bishop to G7 and Dennis immediately just
drops back big threat on the board and
uh Knight jumping into D6 on the cards
as well this looks almost terminal now
for black deeply unpleasant as you're
saying numerous threats with every
single turn played I don't even care if
the evaluation bar is going down down
slightly what is Maxim's plan I don't
see an easy one taking the Knight on e4
that looks terrible the bishop will
replace the Knight attack The Rook in
the corner that is probably just losing
on the spot so what Maxim can accomplish
here is unclear he's only on move 20
he's about to get 5 minutes left he
pushes his H Pawn but Knight D6 check as
you mentioned David that looks very
appealing you don't need to do it but
you get the bishop pair and you start
opening up more lines yeah you also can
open up uh on the queen side at will you
can maybe repurpose this White Queen
first and move like Queen to G3 save
this one for later no rush it's not
running away anytime soon keep the
tension maybe would be my advice because
you do have the added time on the clock
and you have an Attack Force your
opponent to kind of suffer defend defend
defend and only pounce later um Dennis
he's spoiled for choice and dream starts
this game for him I like what you just
said though instead of just going too
quickly May Rook F1 to B1 just continue
to apply pressure on that black queen
side there's no rush over there black
doesn't want to take on A4 anyway so
Rook F1 to B1 instead of Knight D6 check
I like your idea David I think actually
that will be a better choice big
question will Dennis lazic be able to
keep the tension undoubtedly he knows
that he's managed to get big Advantage
out of the opening but we know just how
resistant and resourceful Maxim can be
how tricky he can be Dennis instead goes
for a more direct approach he gets that
Bishop air and Maxim blitzes out his
moves putting pressure on that G2 Pawn
tying down White's Queen to defend it
but it looks like Dennis had calculated
his way forward the bishop lands on E5
black king not feeling safe but you
might be forced to put it on the queen
side yeah still very good but I'm
slightly afraid lazic is playing
positionally in a position that kind of
Demands dynamism at some point that
being said white does have a dream
position look at the clock as well Maxim
is not comfortable at all we used to
seeing Maxim Blitz even in uh kind of
the most dubious of positions but here
Maxim is in the tank that clock is
ticking ever further down and still
glorious for white that Bishop controls
everything on E5 you see a move at a
time for black you Castle Queen side
good for you that F1 Rook does slide
over to B1 that side of the board will
open up sooner rather than later and G5
played look at that desperation from
Magnus with the evaluation bar went all
the way up do not take that pawn on H5
Queen takes G2 would be Checkmate so
that's what Max team is relying on right
now is that there are threats on the
diagonal and look at how simply Dennis
lazic plays F3 Bishop E4 next H5 is
truly hanging this might just be over in
the youngster favor yeah I think Maxim
was banking on the fact he could play
Pawn to G4 but now white can just slide
forward remind black that there's a
Checkmate threat in this side of the
board as well and this would simply be
terminal look at this black king
stranded and uh soon to be M this one is
almost over he just needs a few more
accurate moves H4 aims to trap this
White Queen but we said it Bishop to E4
just looks so strong right now and he
does play it this is looking just
fantastic for the youngster he might get
his first match win of the finals and
what a win it would be against Maxim V
lra can Dennis lavic finish off this job
he's so close the queen moves back now
big questions do you trade off the
bishop do you go for Black's Rook
because Bishop 87 you don't have so many
squares yourself first Dennis decides to
liquidate the queen side uh he wants to
trade off the Rooks there are a lot of
pleasant choices already upon up wow
this is going to be a huge breakthrough
in his career in the tournament for
Dennis lzic this will fill him with
confidence this is I mean look at the
control the calmness he's done the hard
work he realizes he doesn't even need to
do much anymore he's won a Pawn One
material he's just sneaking in now with
the White Queen blocking Black's
counterplay black is stranded black is
helpless and Maxim didn't take the pawn
back because he wanted to keep files
closed he thinks that if the second Rook
would appear on the queen side for white
that would have been disastrous but this
is no better we see Dennis lazic
pouncing first establishing as Bishop in
the center then taking a pawn then
slithering his Queen forward up to G4
maybe it goes to H5 and further into
Black's camp but Maxim he is trying
desperately to close down the queen side
to close down that front so his King
maybe can escape but even if the king
escapes he's positionally in huge danger
and black has to watch out of that
Bishop from E4 moving to 87 and it has
happened Bishop 87 is he about to win
big material Now The Rook it's got no
squares you go to f8 the other Bishop
can jump on to uh G s G5 Bon is hanging
and Maxine gives up more pieces this is
just too much material and now white is
up the exchange and a pawn and look at
the white D6 Pawn just beautifully
entrenched in Black's position I don't
see any counterplay the White Queen
isn't trapped she has squares the only
good thing for Maxi Vash grav is the
black king for now is safe the Black
Knight is the glue holding everything
together what a move D5 he just gave his
Pawn away that square is covered by
three different black pieces and he says
take me with any of your pieces the
queen it can slide to D4 all of a sudden
and it's going for checkmate if the
Knight moves A4 drops more of an attack
so that was a wonderful decision you see
the evalar approved of it D5 that was
sick so classy those invisible moves as
we call them on squares that are
protected so many times by enemy pieces
they break the enemy's coordination they
open up lines and Bishop to D4 back
lining up with the White Queen would
have been a Terminal Threat there okay
maxi he's fending things off move by
move but longterm he's busted he's down
material and the black king is a target
he simply slides back and uh sooner or
later that white Bishop will drop back
kick away the Black Knight and
everything will fall apart and that's
all you need to do the Knight on B6
holds Black's position just for now and
Dennis lazic finding the right squares
for his pieces he needs to put pressure
on that Knight Bishop D4 will be the
final touch to this Dennis has to be
feeling confident and look at that clock
he's kept it under control on the clock
as well and this no ways against Maxim
but this will be a phenomenal phenomenal
win for danis lavic you have to feel
happy for him if he gets a job done here
and Maxim now in time trouble his King
is being hunted he's down material and
as you said it's nothing against Maxim
we're all friends with him he's the 2021
World Blitz Champion so for Dennis to
just bring it to him I think it will
give him some serious confidence boost
because instead of playing a quieter
positional style which we know he loves
he just said let's go and he went for an
aggressive attacking game and right now
he's completely winning but will he be
able to convert this I'm sure a lot of
the chat is perhaps rooting for Dennis
right now we know how tricky Maxim can
be we've seen him trick his opponents
with even in positions which look even
more hopeless than this one so it's
really not over that's the thing about
these top players it's so hard to beat
them even in positions that you're
completely winning and finally that
Bishop does arrive on D4 Bishop takes
Knight is the big threat Dennis is up
and exchange what what does he need to
watch out for in these positions well H
it's hard to imagine too much going
wrong for white but now the D6 Pawn has
dropped watch out your Rook on A3 is
hanging uh Dennis blocks that threat I
guess he has just has to just cash in at
the right time you just want to make
sure you don't kind of transition too
early into an end game where black keeps
the A4 porn alive for example black
keeps the D5 Bishop on an outpost
because there might be no way through
later so don't trade off everything
don't take that black knight yet that
end game might be holdable for black U
so you just need to keep calm need to
keep patient and okay he's building Rook
to B4 I was wondering if the Knight can
drop back to D7 here because of the
bishop slides back to D4 E5 that almost
traps the bishop so he goes up instead
of back he saw this all that was really
brilliant by Dennis there because now A4
is falling the bishop on E7 you can go
take that for black as long as the Rooks
crash through the a file white will be
winning and because this has been so
much action we've just forgotten about
some of the other Armageddon already one
has been decided as Wesley so takes the
win against alira fuja we've got our eye
out on the Hikaru Magnus match we will
go to that but for now let's stick to
this as it's about to reach its uh final
critical moments yeah H3 is a randomizer
it's a desperate attempt but he's just
collapsing now on the queen side Maxi
Vash gr big threat of Rook to A7 check
there so that was blocked but Black's
Knight is not going to hold this one
together for long no it's not take a
pawn G2 leave it there that's an
umbrella Pond bring that Bishop back to
C5 kick the Knight out of there it feels
like white is just in this game he
doesn't go for the night he just takes
pawns why not there is no attack for
black and that Bishop will come on D4
with the same idea that you were
pointing out but he's picked up a keep
on along the way yeah and the Black
Knight desperately trying to defend
squares now still no checks black king
is miraculously still surviving you
still need to land the killer blow but
look at the clock as well we're at move
43 Maxim only has one minute left you
can even play for time right now okay
Queen H7 there is a hint of counterplay
coming down to B1 watch out for the
white king but it's just one check it's
just a ghost right now protect it though
cover it and Maxim chances of
counterplay should slip away and you
don't win the world Blitz championship
by accident Maxim has done just that and
queen H7 is one of those moves that you
scare your opponent but this isn't Blitz
for both sides Maxim is playing bullet
and right now Dennis is the one with
five plus minutes on his clock so Queen
B one check is it actually a threat I
would just avoid it altogether but I
think it is only a single check down
there and the King can pick up the G2
Pawn is no checkmating attack yeah just
when in doubt though protect guard kill
the counterplay wh Rook could at the
very least come back to the first rank
back to A1 just stop an e checks no
checks ever there and uh you can slowly
but surely go about your business uh
Dennis he's doing the right thing he's
so professional at such a young age
slowing down almost 5 minutes still and
uh he just has to battle his own nerves
that's the only thing that can stop him
now and maturity there by danis lavic as
in this critical moment he knows he's
got it in his hand but he has to wrap it
up as quickly as he can without giving
any chance to Maxim vashir lrab for mvl
you give him one opportunity and you
know that it will be uh it will be back
to being a level game but it looks like
he's calculated his way through he grabs
a pawn loses two pawns but he keeps
majority of his Advantage but I think
Maxim should be pleased with this I was
surprised by that decision from Dennis
to take a Pawn on G5 it looked like it
was away from the action but now black
doesn't have very much material
remaining it's a rook and a pawn for
just that Knight is stuck defending the
black king is wide open this would be a
miracle for Max Team to survive oh look
at that check black is just immobilized
now black can barely move White's H Pawn
could just motor down the board that's a
potential future Queen uh maybe he's
looking for checkmate here Dennis lazic
maybe there's something more Queen you
got ideas like Queen D6 but I think you
have to watch out for TRS here because
Knight into Bishop Queen into bishop and
then suddenly Bishop takes Pawn could be
a big tactic so Queen D6 might look like
you're threatening Checkmate but you
could just walk into some danger
territory there I think you just back
that Bishop up all the way towards your
king then bring your Rook next to your
king so there's no attack whatsoever and
then that H Pawn goes up the board so
Dennis has everything under control
especially his time management he
started with a huge Le on the clock
that's the nature of Armageddon but he's
been taking it to Maxim and he's only
slowing down when he knows he needs to
be precise so cynical Robert I can tell
you've done this before that would be
the most professional way of doing it
just killing all risk in the position
but uh still under Black's King coming
out to C6 surely it's time sooner rather
than later to push that white H Pawn
maybe he wants to repurpose the White
Queen which is a bit offside right now
he's still in
control what to do next where's the
killer blow all right well Dennis lawick
looks like he knows exactly what he's
doing The Rook might jump into A7 the H
Pawn might start advancing we will keep
an eye out on this one but let's uh
check in with the dust settle in that
and Dennis in driver's seat Hikaru
against Magnus and what expression
number was that oh look at the position
Hikaru is losing as we tune in because
of the weak dark squares around his King
you see the board on the bottom right
hand side of your screen a rook trade
just happened and Hikaru his dark
squares he doesn't have a fetto bishop
over there the bishop for white just
going one square forward in the diagonal
I think the black kings is getting
checkmated yeah and Hikaru he did such a
good job on the clock but unfortunately
one slip just as we joined the game and
there we go Robert you mentioned it the
white Bishop landing on E5 and Black's
Knight simply stuck it cannot cover
enough squares G7 is a potential
Checkmate Square the corner Square on h8
all the dark squares potential uh
Landing spots for the White Queen and
it's sneaking in no way to stop it now
how is he going to try and cling on he
drops the Knight all the way back but
there we go the Queen's coming in oh
he's allowing some checks at the very
least white can grab the A7 Pawn because
the bishop on E5 d dominates the Knight
there are no moves without giving a
check and if white can force the queens
and the Knight off the board it's a
winning King and pawn end game but be
careful in positions like this because
just trading the Queens if those
disappeared maybe black would have some
chances because white doesn't have the
easiest path towards a pass Pawn still
some work to do he doesn't trade off
immediately and my question was going to
be if he did take Bishop takes Knight
were there some threats of perhaps
Landing into a Perpetual but Magnus
doesn't even want to calculate that that
Bishop on E5 is dominating the pawn on
F3 dominates that Knight on F6 uh and
it's U magnus's pieces that are playing
all over he's up upon but at some point
you have to start making progress he
sidesteps any checks and now he's
threatening to grab that Knight and
perhaps go into a winning King Pawn end
game definitely he wants to transition
he wants to transform his Advantage uh
make things easier simplify the equation
also that white king can start walking
its way forward now on the dark squares
black is just really stuck hikaro needs
to avoid this trade Bishop for Knight
but if he drops his Knight back still no
threats nothing to do he's stuck and
look at the clock suddenly under 20
seconds increment is still a distant
dream it only kicks in at move 60 it's
physically going to be impossible surely
14 seconds left and here's the big
question and you can see that Magus is
thinking about can I take this Knight on
F6 and if the queen thinks out can I
then put my queen on E5 with check and
trade queens now sometimes you try to
liquidate too soon and it's actually the
black king that will March quickly up
the board and start stealing some of
White's pawns so it's a big moment here
for Magnus Carlson I do not think he
should take the Knight and trade queens
that could easily backfire as black will
shut down the protection of that pawn
and go and Win It moral ethical decision
here do you just try and play quick
moves flag the opponent or do you
actually slow down and try to find
objectively the best moves because uh 12
seconds for Nakamura physically so tough
and queens off the board Now Queens off
the board Hikaru needs only a draw
somehow but he needs a big miracle right
one to convert this into a draw at least
he can feel safe that he's not getting
checkmated anytime soon but he's going
to lose his Rook Pawn that's on a dark
Square only one side is a dark Square
bishop and here it goes Magnus breaks
that little Pawn chain there steals The
Rook Pawn so now he'll have a pass Pawn
on opposite sides of the board that's
going to be too much for the black
pieces to deal with and four seconds for
Hikaru he has to make a
move whoa Magnus is playing surprisingly
slowly but
Hikaru she look at that speed he's
trying to pre moove but he's running out
of time there's no mouse there's no
mouse and okay hiar resigns handshakes
Magnus Carlson does it takes it in the
armagon wow some fantastic technique
there by Magnus and big news coming in
Dennis lasic takes his armagon against
Maxim VRA he gets his first win against
the 2021 World Blitz champion on fire
Dennis the Menace we all knew what he
was capable of he himself said this was
going to be his toughest challenge to
date and he's able to beat Maxim in
Armageddon in fact all three players
with the white pieces won their
Armageddon matches and we saw Fabby when
he lost a nbec he immediately got up
left did not put the pieces back Hikaru
with the same reaction definitely upset
the game was leveled for the most part
of it and then Magnus doing Magnus
things strikes and there we see the
world number one after his win walking
off what a day he's had and that was the
end of it as nbec took it against
Fabiano Carana in the two rapid games
the rest of the three went into
Armageddon Wesley Soul Dennis lazic the
man of the moment with his win against
Maxim VRA and Magnus against Hikaru ends
in magnus's
favor Pras David what stood out to you I
just want to break down the critical
moments of that Mammoth Clash that
monster clash between Magnus Carson and
Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru was on the back
foot slightly just as we joined in but
then one move let it all slip and Magnus
was able to break through through the
defenses here white has a small
Advantage mainly due to the activity of
the pieces the Queen the bishop The Rook
but uh here Hikaru helped white out by
weakening the dark squares further Pawn
to G6 was simply mistaken he should have
just waited a move such as king to H7
maybe Pawn to A5 just maintaining the
tension would have given him great
drawing chances instead G6 allowed a
transformation of the advantage a simple
Rook trade and this move that Robert
mentioned earlier Bishop to E5 the
killer blow because simply the black
King is in too much trouble the Knight
has to move if for example it drops back
this way then a check would have been
deadly on the back rank potential
checkmates in the air if black isn't
careful instead it dropped back to E8
but the White Queen snuck in anyway and
the threat of this Checkmate was deadly
black was forced to push a pawn forward
but after a couple of checks white
simply pocketed this Pawn on A7 and the
dominance of this bishop ensured a
winning end game what a turnaround in
that game because it looked very solid
for black and we understand why he
pushed this Pawn to G6 he realized I
don't really have too many options I
need to defend my Pawn that sticks out
like a sore thumb but unfortunately he
defended a pawn but lost his King yeah
wow that was a amazing play there with
the queen and Bishop combining together
to finish off the game in what would
look like a level a level position but
Magnus doing Magnus things but I'm just
thinking about Dennis lazic I mean the
guy is 17 years old he is an underdog in
this tan the lowest rated player he's
got the X on his back he's the big
Target and he's been showing his spark
here you know he's been holding those
draws finally he gets that win in and
once again maxim of course you've got to
be a fan of Maxim but I feel like we
were all at some point rooting for
Dennis to get that win with the position
he had out of the opening well Dennis
may be a teenager but he's not kidding
around he's here to play and he just
showed a dominant display of Chess from
start to finish that was all Dennis
lazic and he's proven over the years
he's capable of winning in big events he
started in title Tuesday when he was 15
years old a feay master was like who is
this kid then he goes to the world rapid
and Blitz he becomes a grand master his
good showings pretty much everywhere
gaining rating you can look online and
see it but Dennis lavic to this point
hadn't won a single match now he gets on
the scoreboard and I think everyone's
looking at like that's no longer a free
point we got to be careful about Dennis
yeah and this should be inspirational
for everyone at home just uh when you
play these higher rated players first
you need to learn how to draw against
them how to survive Dennis has done that
day one we saw a couple of draws then
you need to start taking your chances
start learning how to attack them kind
of being brave against the high rated
opponents and we see Dennis growing
learning in front of our R and everyone
at home should be doing the same you
will take hits you will take defeats but
as long as you improve and keep the
confidence which he has done you will
get your results in the end and he did
get his result in the end what a day of
Chess it has been we had Mind Games we
had dramatic Armageddon we had some
brilliancies we had turnarounds we had
all of it and it was so much fun calling
the moves and the action here from Oslo
but the action continues in Toronto
while we're signing off we're sending
you over to the playing arena with
Donnie and James guys what a day of
Chess take it
away what a day of Chess unbelievable
chess I honestly don't even know where
to begin wow I think we have to go back
to the Marquee matchup obviously Magnus
Carlson gets the job done in Armageddon
fashion what an incredible game a
grinded out Magnus fashion I mean it's
incredible how he does every in game
everything goes to an ingame no really
CR
attacks here doesn't care about the
opening Advantage doesn't care about
what opening you play we get to an in
game I do my thing he does it every
single time it's funny because in the
critical moment Magnus didn't have an
advantage and the clocks were almost
even up until that fateful G6 by hearo
so your heart goes out to Hikaru there
losing that Armageddon but he did get
one win today let's remind everybody
real quick what the standings are after
the play is done here the uh four rounds
are in the books where does it put
everybody after that we also had another
Armageddon victory of course I think
Dennis lvic getting his big win is uh is
huge for the standings as we bring them
up if people thought it was a sure thing
that the youngster would go home I guess
think again KY think again like H said
Robert was like yeah you free point
walking free point try again in fact I'm
walking around with my chest out not cuz
I lift weights it's because my name is
Dennis lzic and I got my first dub today
I'm feeling great the other person who
not only got his first dub today but got
two dubs today Notre Beck of du Satur
off up there in third place now what
what a tale of two days Fabiano car won
a wins two matches in Armageddon fashion
today he loses both matches I guess I
jinxed him I picked Fabby to win both of
his matches that didn't go very well
dang Danny you always doing that I'm the
commentator's curse is real but Notre
Beck Abus aov's chess is real and he
caught up with Kaa just moments ago
after his huge day
two I'm here with the man of the moment
beating Fabiano Carana congratulations
yeah thank you you were high on energy
after that first game how are you
feeling right now after winning the
match yeah I'm um I'm relieved so you
know it's been a very good match and uh
yeah I I
really um I really played well I think
in second game without a mistake so yeah
um looking good for me what was your
plan heading into this match with
Fabiano who's just been so good Lely
yeah um but today I think he you know he
was maybe a little bit um not shape but
uh um I think it's partly okay because
also he played Magnus and um and after
losing to to him it's maybe he he was a
little bit frustrated so
yeah I am I'm I think after beating
lasek I was
I was very confident and you know I was
I was really uh really in in good shape
and uh with three rounds ago how do you
see your chances now to go through from
the round
robin um it's still looking very tough
right now because there are a lot of
players with on two points so yeah we'll
do my best and just just looking forward
to to to to get to play some interesting
games you mentioned that confidence you
got from winning against lazovic heading
into this match with Fabiano for us who
don't play Chess at the level that you
do how important is momentum confidence
when you do play these big guys like
Fabiano yeah it's really important
because you know then everything goes
well for
you um and uh yeah it's but it's also
very very hard to to to keep that
momentum you know it's not um not every
day you you you can bid it uh Fano so
yeah it's really really really tough so
uh the other matches we'll be going to
Armageddon you are done for the day what
will you do now the rest of the night to
celebrate this great day so who's going
to be who's going to play Armageddon the
other three matches are all going to
Armageddon yeah oh okay then it's really
interesting to watch yeah you'll be
enjoying that yeah of course all right
well congratulations on the great day
not backck thank you thank you for
joining us wow the man of the moment you
guys SBE up to Soro back to
you thank you bro was so focused on his
own dominance he didn't even know the
other three matches we going to
Armageddon we got to love it there you
see he took down Fabiano Carana despite
big age Gap there you look at the
accuracy just fantastic chess day I mean
really good in fact uh Robert said it in
a way this is Kryptonite we've seen nck
do this before in different matches OTB
as well so you know nck is just feeling
good after that he's feeling good you're
right for some reason maybe he likes his
match up against fa maybe he also didn't
like our prediction to take Fab and he
used it his fuel who knows whatever it
is notc Abdus turov is right there in
the thick of things behind the only two
guys who remain 4 and0 of course we
already talked about Carlson got it done
in Armageddon fashion against Nakamura
but Wesley so also still 4-0 still four
I mean Wesley so is absolute Beast right
now he's walking around he's feeling
good I'm like yeah I'll do the interview
yeah I'll talking doing puzzles he's
having a time of his life it's like you
know Wesley sorono because Toronto is
his place right now Wesley so loves
Toronto he is 4 and0 I can't think of
any more ways to rhyme with that so
instead we're going to throw to Kaaya
who caught up with Wesley after his
second perfect
day it's a perfect start for Wesley so
another match win how are you feeling
Wesley yeah very happy uh like to
glorify the Lord Jesus for all those
wins my
goal before the start of the tournament
was like to finish in the top
six like at least not to go home so
early so it's looking good yeah it's
looking good so far uh things are going
well so far couldn't have asked for a
better start crazy and how are you
feeling about your playing Armageddon as
well here pretty good pretty good yeah I
think against Maxim I played really well
and against Alesa I did I wasn't
familiar at all with the opening like he
had a very comfortable position but uh
he has he hesitated I believe with
A6 when he could play D5 maybe like he
hesitated a little bit and then next
thing I knew I had a very good position
like I knew I had to play G4 if I don't
play G4 I'm just going to lose and he us
he used so much time like I didn't even
have to win the
position you're walking around here in
the player Lounge Wesley with just a big
smile on your face you seem relaxed how
important is that and how big of a
factor is that in your perfect score
here so far yeah well I won all my games
yeah which so does does the results come
first or does the you know the great
mood come first well they go both hand
in hand yeah like uh becoming determin I
was just putting no pressure in myself
if I win I win if I if I lose then it's
just you know go home and then prepare
for the next one so it's my it's my
mindset like I love the game I know this
tman has a huge humongous price money
but I'm not really playing for money you
know I'm just trying to enjoy have a
good career and uh live life and uh
tomorrow on day three in the finals you
will face Magnus cson among others
thanks for letting me know I I I didn't
know who my pairing was like I was
taking it one round at a time so thanks
for letting me know do you prefer not
knowing until like the same day uh well
for for speed tournaments preparation is
not that important so like I tend to
check the pairings in the
morning well what can we expect when you
do play Magnus Carlson tomorrow both of
you looking extremely good here ah what
can I expect well it's it's up to
him
uh yeah it's up to him which Magnus
shows up I
hope I hope the best Magnus doesn't show
up but if it does it will be an uphill
battle obviously but the best Wesley so
will turn up like I remember he beat me
so convincingly in San Francisco last
year and he just won the tournament like
he had six match wins out of seven
something crazy like that so when he's
in good form he's uh just crazy crazy
strong uh so um yeah we'll see he's an
amazing incredible player what what can
I do yeah so are you Wesley so
congratulations on a great day yes thank
you yes good luck tomorrow as well
Wesley so you guys perfect start to the
tour
finals well we saw Wesley so say that he
hopes the best Magnus Carlson doesn't
show up tomorrow because the result is
in magnus's hands and there you know
what the round five pairings are Wesley
so will be taking on Magnus Carlson
first thing in the morning and that is
the matchup of two players who've been
perfect so far of course we have a ton
of other matchups to talk about lvic
Carana and the many others but right now
we have Magnus to the death so I'm just
going to jump right in Magnus Wesley
said that the result tomorrow depends on
which Magnus Carlson shows up if the
best Magnus shows up he says you win but
what do you think about that um well I
usually I usually do but uh um I I don't
know he's generally playing quite quite
well here but um no generally I agree
like if I play at my best I I usually
usually do pretty well so I I I hope for
you hope to agree with him what what do
you think talk a little more about
Wesley's play here he seems to like
Toronto he's obviously had a couple of
Armageddon matches to get there but your
thoughts just on on how difficult he'll
be to beat
tomorrow um he hasn't been like
extremely solid recently in in Rapid but
um I don't think he's played like too
differently from from what he has
recently here um I mean he's a very very
strong player but but u i I wouldn't say
he's done anything too too special uh
but obviously score is his score is
great and if he plays the way that he
used to play back in 2020 2021 online
then he's very tough to to beat for sure
yeah physical fitness is of course very
important this is something you do and
follow as well are you doing any type of
exercise while you're here in Toronto
not so far not so far we got to take it
to the gym probably should but I mean at
least I had a couple of weeks of
relaxation before I got here so I still
I don't feel particularly anetic but I
feel fairly calm and I think that's
that's helped me in some critical
moments very nice shifting away from so
to the match you just had with Hikaru
obviously that was huge for all the fans
you did get it done in Armageddon but
take us into the final moments of that
game you were getting under time
pressure you guys were about dead even
on the clock even with him having
drawing chances right before hikaro play
G6 so were you nervous at that moment
what were your what were your feelings
at that point in the game I wouldn't say
I was nervous uh but I wasn't 100%
confident either um at that point um
well I did have some structural Edge and
I do know that he's very strong when he
gets his nights going but it felt to me
that um it was not so easy and that he
would have to jettison the pawn to get
any sort of activity and clearly he just
blundered there um yeah which was good
for me but to be honest like he had been
under a pressure for a long time there
so I'm I'm not shocked that he that he
he blundered you beat Notre Beck with
white in Armageddon and you wanted that
you wanted that color and then you bid
15 minutes against taru I know you
already gave some thoughts on it with K
but take us back into that what is the
is it really based on the opponent
because we're all talking about the meta
it's fascinating to understand that
sometimes you want black sometimes you
want white is it based on the style the
opponent take us in into that a little
bit Yeah I think you should have sort of
a balanced strategy while bidding for
Armageddon but uh that was like one of
the extremes of of course um I thought
also I thought psychologically it would
be um it would be fun like if he if he's
uh thought longing hard about his b and
he thinks he got it just on the second
and I just
did um and I was yeah I was happy to
play play White um I mean considering
the the fact that he bid that his bid
was so high yeah uh I probably gave away
a little bit of equity there uh but
still I didn't feel uh didn't feel too
bad going
into uh going into the Armageddon cuz
even though I hadn't defeated him in
Armageddon as white before and I I also
think like he hadn't defeated me either
so I think black has won every time I've
won loads of games against him on demand
as as white so I I knew that I could do
that so I was just trying to play as
normally as um as possible and uh you
know with his Mimi opening then it's not
bad but it just means that we get a game
right nice uh with strategy you
mentioned staying calm so is there any
strategy or Preparation that keeps you
of course in these highle matches every
day of course they're coming at you they
trying to beat you strategy and
preparation on staying
calm um no I haven't done anything not
nothing too much I just I just feel feel
relatively calm man that's nice your
your mindset is strong so you play
Wesley so tomorrow uh you played loic I
think after no you've already played
lavic I've already played loic so I've
got the I got Wesley and the Frenchman
Wesley and the Frenchman your thoughts
on you're just focused on Wesley for now
or do you do prep for both players the
night before I'm really not focused on
anybody right now I'm happy with the
score the way it is and then I'll start
thinking about the the matches um
tomorrow yeah well appreciate you
joining us and uh congrats again on a I
don't think we're quite done okay what
do you got cuz uh you know one of the
reasons why I get here early sometimes
is that I really like oh you like
hearing the prediction I like hearing
the predictions and you guys had some
interesting ones today
so appreciate that I did take Fabby
against you but I took you against and
you've got against me twice right yeah
it's just it's content of you know it's
content but I mean you also have to like
I understand you know what I mean it's
definitely hard to to pick you every
time I don't I don't take offense but I
notice it that's what I'm saying okay
well you know we might as well dive into
that I'm glad you brought it up because
we've already chatted about it obviously
there was the interaction with Aldi Resa
he didn't the prediction I think that I
think most the players are okay with it
I think we will continue to do it but
maybe try to get it done earlier so it
doesn't feel like it's right before the
game what do you think I if it's up to
me do it as the players are hearing I
think that's like that okay well maybe
that's a good lesson in the in the the
mental F and remember like every time
you bet against me I get like a couple
of per better well maybe that was
secretly why we were doing it but anyway
no I appreciate that it is it's
interesting because this is different
than other sports football players don't
hear the pundit saying things right
before the game right so you have this
mental toughness do you think that what
would be your message on that because
you want us to keep doing the
predictions you like it obviously one
player didn't like it today what what
are your thoughts on on the difference
in your mindset there I think it's very
easy like if it's if it's going well
then yeah then you just enjoy it if
you're if it's not going so so well then
I can see why it would be annoying right
100%
yeah well appreciate appreciate that
I'll think long and hard about whether
I'm going to predict you or tomor I'm
going to try to take three steps ahead
in the meta whether I'm picking Magnus
or Wesley tomorrow Magnus Magnus Magnus
Magnus Magnus well thanks man thank you
appreciate your time buddy and we'll
we'll let you balance that's Magnus
Carlson loving the candid thoughts there
this has been quite the day from Toronto
can we just say that 100% ups and downs
all day everywhere we've had we've had
amazing fashion by Gucci Resa W Ollie
Ollie didn't take too kindly to some
predictions we had some real time
discussion about the content with Magnus
himself the goat the goat bringing his
thoughts about it and obviously you got
a huge match up tomorrow between Wesley
so and Magnus Carlson that's going to be
amazing can't wait for it two players
undefeated we will be back tomorrow for
everyone thank you to the crew in Oslo
the crew here in Toronto we'll see you
for the championship the Champions chess
tour in Toronto
tomorrow the Queen goes all the way back
to the corner blunder from fuja this
will end in Checkmate hiar Nakamura
relieved after his first win can go
Queen B instead that is stunning Magnus
Caron he plays he
wins oh my goodness oh that would have
blundered and lost blocking black
counterplay black is stranded black is
helpless what a move Magnus gson does it
takes it in the armagon
I feel
[Applause]
confident
[Music]
sh
w
[Music]
[Laughter]